take that as far as shipping is
concerned there's various shipping
things on the platforms live auctioneers
has their own shipping Department it
will automatically be on your invoice at
the end of the sale you can opt out for
live ship and you can get the local UPS
Stores to ship it or you might have
in-house shipping so on all platforms we
do have in-house shipping in-house
shipping is a 12 per lot handling fee on
top of actual shipping Plus Insurance we
handle only small items I would venture
to say everything that is unframed today
we can handle in-house if you buy one of
the frame pieces of art it will
definitely be sent out to the local UPS
Store there are three local UPS Stores
to choose from Kendall Park New
Brunswick and Mama Junction you can pick
your own shipper if you want but it must
be out of our building by Monday so keep
that all in mind all right and I think
that's where we're at I think that's
everything so we want you to spend your
money as far as soon bid limits there's
been all kinds of questions on bid
limits ladies and gentlemen you know uh
obviously you've already uh got in touch
with me your bid limit is taken care of
but you know you have if you're bidding
on uh our platforms it's a fifteen
thousand dollar bid limit or you must
contact us to have an increase uh could
we need to know exactly who's bidding
not just an internet business is that 15
for one item or a 15 total total 15 000
total yes that's a score of the 15 000
total yes so if you're spending more
than fifteen thousand dollars total on
our platforms you need to contact us in
advance and we take your uh driver's
license we take your uh uh different
information like that I'm just getting
feedback I'm trying to figure out
exactly why but I'm not sure but but at
any rate
um that's the deal if you're on live
auctioneers if you're a brand new person
uh you have to uh uh also uh get
background checks Etc and then we up
your limit so anyway just so you're
aware if you get if you're maxed out of
money that is why you need to contact us
immediately so we can raise your bid
limit But there again there we have it
all right right with all that being said
I I am honored here to be here today
sewing this fantastic collection yes
what's that
I'm sorry
I couldn't hear you I'm sorry at any
rate I'm honored to be here today
selling the uh Personal Collection of
Kevin Smith on uh on his comic art
collection I'm going to introduce my
staff and then we'll introduce the man
himself we got Erica back there
how you doing she'll be putting uh uh
taking care of the camera today we got
Ruth Ann back there how you doing
yes
I keep wanting to say good morning man
I'm not I'm so used to going in the
morning here at any rate at any rate
she'll be uh bringing the stuff up we
got my daughter Willow
she is outside right at the moment
putting stuff under the camera uh I got
a yepper next to me a professional
yepper that's gonna be yupping bids
Georgie good to see you today how are
you doing we got Alan taking foam beds
and absentee bids uh my son will be
taking some photographs he's kicking
around here somewhere too ah he's right
there
how you doing Joey good
wonderful great to see you and then uh
it's directly in front of me I got my
comic book expert Darren hi everybody
and we got the main man himself here
today Mr Kevin Smith
yeah there he is
[Laughter]
happy to be here it's gonna be fun going
through all this
um it's gonna be like a four hour
podcast
180 Lots yes
so whether you're in uh
take your Terrance
[Laughter]
there we go
thank you very much guy we appreciate
you being here and uh it's gonna be a
great day here we go uh we're starting
off first with uh two charity items and
uh item number one I'll have uh Darren
describe it but the charity just so you
know basically we run a toy drive every
single year this will be the seventh
Year my wife and I are actually my wife
really runs it I help her out but I
guess we both do it but at any rate
um my father's a pastor in downtown New
Brunswick has a been at the church for
52 years Pastor over there at any rate
uh seven years ago we decided to do a
toy drive and 200 kids showed up then we
uh the next year we had 500 kids 600
kids last year we had 650 kids now last
year it actually caused double the
amount of money to get presents if you
could believe that we used to cost about
10 15 per kid but it's gone up to about
15 20 to get presents and everything
else so the first two charity items
today are going towards that toy drive
um and if you'd like to donate to the
toy driving go to our website at
bodnersauction.com
and you would just look at the top of
the screen there's a toy drive with a
GoFundMe up but it generally tossed us
about five to seven thousand now back
before pre-pandemic everybody donated we
would have a live sale and everybody be
throwing money at us this that
everything else we'd get five six
thousand dollars no problem but since
now we're online a little bit tougher
you know we're not in your face asking
for money so uh we really appreciate
anything that you can give because there
again it does go out to 650 young kids
Santa Claus even comes and everything
else and uh we're honored that the first
two items were donated by Kevin Smith
and the secret stash we really
appreciate that very much uh but what do
we got there and what's the first item
here uh first up is an autographed Buddy
Christ bobblehead signed by Kevin Smith
and Jay Mews new in the box there he is
foreign
statue as seen in the motion picture
Dogma from the year 1999.
all the other stuff I'm gonna keep the
money but these first two items this is
going to the toy drive man you heard it
it came from a from a past
he made the plea the only boy who could
ever reach me that's why I'm here with
Joe boner right now so pick this up kids
my my favorite song to be honest is it
really yeah there you go I sing that one
loud at any rate and I will match
whatever you guys spend today so make me
broke I got 150 been 160. well if
anything about 160 160 160 160 170 170
170 170 170 170 180 180 180 180 180 180
181 81 81 91 91 91 91 91 91 91 91 81 90.
180 199
200 200 by 200 200
[Laughter]
[Applause]
75 going once
250 bit 275 going twice last call
oh just in time 275 now 300 300 about
300.75 300 about 300 by 275 300 300 300
three and a quarter three and a quarter
three and a quarter three twenty five
three twenty five three twenty [__]
about three twenty pocket about three
hundred by three twenty [__] about
three hundred about three twenty five
going once 300 by three twenty five
going twice last call
first off like props to whoever bought
it that's really sweet yes bigger props
to you holy [__] that is the best oral
I've received in a long time thank you
all right I could watch that for hours
and I guess I'm going you're about to
yes you're about to watch that for hours
it's phenomenal well thank you that's
only in the first slot wait till we get
into the 20 and 30 thousands Joe what
must you be like in bed [__] uh that
that I can't answer
let's find out shall we God
yeah good point good point there are
kids here with a mouth like that those
are impressive as [__] well thank you
very much I appreciate it I like I'm
sitting here going like I used to really
prize the work of Affleck and Damon but
I'd much rather watch you read my
dialogue we'd be through the movies in
30 minutes there you go that was that
was sweet thank you Lot number two is an
autographed Kevin Smith's secret stash
book signed by Kevin Smith again this is
being sold to support the Christmas
charity this book is thick as a dick
kids if you drop this from a building on
a head you will kill a human being this
could be a registered Lethal Weapon this
book signed by me and Jason
as well yeah Jason Muse tagged it as
well uh this book is thick man it's got
pictures Galore from across my entire
nearly 30-year career
um and uh the Story of My Life as kind
of told to the author of the book Jason
amused at the uh the uh forward in the
front then there's a bunch of nice
things written by famous people I've
worked with over the years hell of a
book man all right I got 171.80 171.81
81 91 901 91 91 91 91 91 91 81 91 91 91
90. come on guys 190.80
181 91 91 81 90 for the toy drive now
180 190 180 you get about 198
going once 190 200 200 by 200 by 200 is
that a yes over there 200 about two and
a quarter 200 about two and a quarter
two and a quarter by two and a quarter
200 by 2 2500 by 200 you're in 200 by
225 200 by 2 2500 by 200 by two twenty
five two hundred by two twenty five
going once 200 about 225 dollars going
twice last call
sold 200 to 101 200 the 101. and now we
are moving into the proper auction part
of it yes you know what I would talk
like to just say one quick thing though
uh the rest of this there is a portion
of the uh proceeds today going to
another charity uh and I would like to
Kevin just talk about it real quick and
then we can go from there it's the
Colbert cubers like cuber like the video
game
so you set up a school here in New
Jersey right where he trains folks to do
the very thing that we're auctioning off
today uh draw Comics so percentage of
what we make is going to the school okay
very good all right but once again that
that was musical well thank you what you
did at one point it like it it it
transcended auctioneering into just flat
out musicality that's the goal if the
goal is to get you in a trance and take
all your money and once we take all your
money we want your credit too and did
you say like my man was a yepper yes
because I literally at one point heard
him go yep is that the job that is the
job today he but he's got to be loud I
think I'm gonna give him my headset I
heard him though I heard him yeah you
can hear him man that's fine I can hear
him in my ear yes all right dive in all
right here we go so Lot number three
this is four pieces of original comic
book art from Disney Comics the demon
number 58 final issue by by McRae and
Tatiana wood and includes the
preliminary pencil the ink Dart the
color proof and the cover out with the
stat and overlay the pencils and the
inks are by McRae that's a huge McRae
fence to limb uh back in the day look at
that cover yeah damn gorgeous stuff man
um and this run of the demon was
absolutely uh tremendous you'll see
there's other McRae art later on I got
some Hitman pieces as well yeah the
gartheness uh McRae demon was awesome it
was a lot of fun tremendous book yeah
yeah cool 1400 1500 1500 about 1500 1400
about 1500 1400 about 1500 1400 1500
about 1500 1400 1500 1400 1500 what the
talking about 1500 about 1500 1600 1600
1600 1600 1500 by 1600 1500 by 1600 1500
by 1600 come on guys 1600 come on back
1600 1600 1700 1700 1700 1700 16 talking
about Seventeen hundred eighteen hundred
eighteen hundred eighteen hundred
eighteen hundred eighteen hundred It's
Only Money Now eighteen hundred eighteen
hundred Seventeen eighteen hundred
eighteen hundred Seventeen hundred by
eighteen hundred eighteen hundred by
eighteen hundred you're buying all four
of them guys eighteen hundred nineteen
hundred dollars Nineteen Hundred by two
thousand dollars two thousand dollars
two talking about you talking about two
talking about two talking about Nineteen
Hundred by two thousand dollars Nineteen
Hundred by two thousand dollars like
Teen Hunger about two thousand five
hundred by two thousand dollars Nineteen
Hundred by two thousand dollar going
once come on now get in there ladies and
gentlemen those everything does come
with a COA the cohs aren't junk either
actually really nice coh we had printed
up I like to shout out to my epic
Communications in Hillsboro who did that
in the backdrop behind you guys but they
did a great job and it's signed by Kevin
Smith himself ladies and gentlemen come
on now your autographs were two grand at
least I would say I think my autographs
worth about 20 bucks so there you go we
should bid another 20. a 1920
going once 21 to my 2200 going twice
last call
sold for 2100 to buy our number 100
buyer number one hundred Lot number four
is an original comic book art for DC
slash vertigo's preacher this is issue
three page 14 the art is by the late
great Steve Dillon this is signed by
both garfans right and Steve Dillon the
dialogue is stated on and we got
numerous images of Jesse and tulip and
there is profanity which really you want
if you're buying a preacher page you
want some it's enough yeah you want to
drop somewhere on a preacher um buying
this preacher artwork because I was
massive and remain a massive preacher
fan uh got me introduced to Steve Dillon
and Garth Ennis in the first place man
so buying combo guard was also a bridge
to like some of my favorite creators so
I got to have a beer with Steve don't
well he had a beer that was awesome yeah
it was a legend yeah
I want it in the there all right Joe all
right I got 1500 by 16. 15 hung into my
1600 1500 by 1600 1600 1600 1500 1600
1500 by 1600 1500 by 1600 1600 1700 1700
1700 1700 1600 by 1700 1600 by 1700 1600
by 1700. once in a lifetime ladies and
gentlemen you're not gonna see a
collection like this all come up at once
again whoever buys this stuff's gonna
tuck it away for another 10 to 15 years
let's go fifteen hundred and Seventeen
hundred fifteen hundred by Seventeen
hundred by Seventeen I'm gonna buy
sixteen hundred by Seventeen hundred
thirteen hundred by Seventeen hundred by
Seventeen by sixteen by Seventeen
hundred eighteen hundred eighteen
hundred don't let them have it now
eighteen hundred it's only a hundred
dollars more eighteen hundred eighteen
hundred eighteen hundred Seventeen
hundred by eighteen hundred one more
time hit it again eighteen hundred
dollars everything about eighteen
hundred thirteen hundred by eighteen
hundred eighteen hundred by Seventeen
hundred by eighteen hundred thirteen
hundred by eighteen hundred dollars
going once
Seventeen hundred by eighteen hundred
dollars going twice last call
and I sold it for Seventeen hundred
dollars buyer number 200 buyer number
two hundred lot number five preacher
original comic book art issue number
seven page 18 again signed by both Ennis
and Dylan
low number in the Run what number was
the book issue number seven issue seven
man yeah yeah with any other ten books
first year of preacher yeah um with with
um
with any art the the earlier in the
series that the art is the more
desirable it is because it hasn't caught
on with this many people yet whereas
many people are chasing it so while all
preacher pages are great having you know
some have an art from Paige from issue
seven is even cooler than from 57. hands
down but not nearly as cool let's listen
to Joe Cool himself Joe Bodner
bit away let's hear that voice again Joe
give us that sweet oral [__] somebody
talking about 500.
45 575 575 75 600 600 600 600 above five
seventy five hundred six and a quarter
six and a quarter six and a quarter six
twenty pocketed by 625. they cook it by
625 650 650 650 650 625
675 675 675 6 75 70 pocketed by 700 700
700 700 700 700 by 675 come on guys
seven hundred dollars nothing to think
about 700 x 70 pocketed by 700 pick 70
pocket by 700.75 700 Divine seven
hundred by six seventy five big seven
hundred seven and a quarter eleven
twenty pocketed by seven twenty five
seven fifty Seven fifty Seven fifty
Seven fifty seven twenty pocketed by
seven fifty seven twenty bucket by seven
fifty seven twenty pocket about seven
figures about seven fifty another twenty
five seven by seven twenty five bid
seven fifty going once 720 pocketed by
seven hundred and fifteen dollars going
twice last call
foreign
to buy our number 200 buyer number 200.
Lot number six another page of preacher
original comic book art Dean issue eight
page 20 signed by both Ennis and Dylan
dialogue is stated on you got a lot of
images of Jesse tulip and Marie longell
which I believe is how you pronounce it
and again you got Carson on there as
well
pretty cool you're paying for cuss words
kids Joe take it away I like the curse
words that's the kind of book I like you
know what I'm saying Seventeen hundred
and eighteen hundred Seventeen hundred
about eighteen hundred eighteen hundred
by Seventeen hundred by eighteen hundred
eighteen hundred eighteen hundred
Seventeen hundred and eighteen hundred
eighteen hundred Nineteen Hundred
Nineteen Hundred by two thousand dollars
two thousand dollars two seconds
two thousand two thousand twenty one
hundred twenty one hundred twenty one
hundred two thousand about 2100 2100
2100 2100 200 by Twenty One Hundred by
Twenty One Hundred by two thousand
because about twenty one hundred two
thousand by Twenty One Hundred by Twenty
One by two thousand by Twenty One
Hundred going once nothing to think
about ladies and gentlemen you're right
there you're not gonna see it again two
thousand dollars but 2100 going once two
thousand by Twenty One Hundred going
twice last call
and we sold it for two thousand dollars
here buy our number 200 200 buys and
again folks um I mean clearly from the
prices I think most of you understand
but these are all literal one-of-a-kind
pieces like this is the actual art for
the page this isn't a copy this is
literally gar Thanos wrote the script
and then Steve Dylan Drew this out and
then Inked it and that's how the comic
book is made so this is a paper nft if
that makes any sense better than that
not functional piece of artwork that's
fungible you know that that nft stuff I
mean what I found out they I just read
an article yesterday how it's all dead
nothing it all went to nothing you know
and here I was thinking about trying to
sell nfts I believe they last year I was
brainstorming we could sell nfts how can
we do it how would we auction them all
now now I'd be making no Commission
side step to well done Joe yep there you
go number seven another original feature
page from issue number nine page four
art by Steve Dillon signed by both Garth
Ennis and Steve Dillon we have a Vietnam
War era flashback here with John custler
Jesse's dad and Christina langel Jesse's
mom spoiler alert uh you get Jesse's
parents in this page kids but nothing is
going to be more satisfying this is I I
I'm I I honestly like I'm glad people
are buying the pieces but watching you
auction
like you should just sell tickets for
that [__] I like that idea well yeah
that's not a terrible idea we were
getting there you don't get ideas but I
already had thoughts about it yes
definitely well we had we we back in the
day we had a VIP right before the
pandemic we went into this Vib the very
important bidders and he would get a
permanent bidder number you have private
previews yeah no people will pay and I
was I was getting paid we had paid
subscriptions everybody thought I was
nuts but people paid it's a gift where
did you train I trained myself did you
really yes I I started working for an
auction house when I was 17. and he gave
me some do some things like Betty butter
but some butter but she said the butter
bitter if I put it better make my batter
bitter and do some other exercises like
that and do numbers back and forth in
this and then that's what got me and
started with auctioneering and he put me
up there I was scared to death I did it
I think I screwed up I was like 100 600
500 sold and he was like oh you're
getting down
but then again I then I opened my own
place at 19 so I've been doing it since
then so I tell you man I one of my uh
Mall Rats is the second movie I made and
I think honestly the fastest anyone's
ever delivered the dialogue that I've
written was Shannon Doherty maritz I
always found that impressive I would
read shoot Mall Rats with you in the
Shannon Doherty role
and you would get through that dialogue
way faster there you go I'm in 850 875
900 875 number 900 875 number 900 number
900 number 900 number 900 number 871
99.9 and a half nine according to get a
knife
twenty five nine fifty nine seventy five
a thousand dollars thousand dollars
thousand dollars thousand I'm gonna buy
five hundred by talking about nine
seventy Pockets
by 12. 1200. well I'm Gonna Get It by
1200 by 1200
1300 1300 1300 1300 1300. 1300 well I'm
putting it about 1300 1200 1300 13.
1300. what's another 100 hit it again
well I'm gonna get about 13. I'm gonna
get about 13. I'm gonna get about 1300
to get about thirteen hundred thirteen
hundred fourteen hundred fourteen
hundred do it again fourteen hundred one
more time fourteen hundred fourteen
hundred fourteen hundred fifteen hundred
It's Only Money fifteen hundred fifteen
hundred fifteen hundred
1500 1400 about 1500 what are you
talking about fifteen fourteen hundred
about fifteen hundred about 50 get about
1400 get about fifteen hundred dollars
going once 14 how do you get about
fifteen hundred dollars going twice last
call
sold fourteen hundred dollars buyer
number two hundred buyer number two
hundred Lot Number Eight preacher
original comic book are issue number
nine page three signed by NSN Dylan
another Vietnam War era flashback
multiple images of John Custer and
Christina langel Jesse's uh appearance
and there's also uh Jesse and tulip are
on that one as well so and don't forget
includes profanity kids yep most comic
book pages that you're gonna buy there's
no cursing on them no way you know no
right comic book artwork that's my word
balloons on it with curse words in them
if you've spent your life going what are
the curse words this purchase will help
you right said I'm learning something
right now they have curse words on these
ones well that's the [__] ones I need
there you go I got a thousand but Eleven
Hundred
don't miss out for another 100 hours
guys once in a lifetime here that would
have been a hundred and twelve hundred
dollars going twice last call in time
thirteen hundred dollars don't wait till
the end you will miss out 13 gigabyte
Thirty get about 13 12 1300. well I'm
gonna get about thirteen hundred well
put it in my thirteen hundred by
Thirteen hundred by twelve hundred by
Thirteen hundred twelve hundred by
Thirteen hundred going once twelve
hundred about thirteen hundred dollars
going twice last call
so twelve hundred dollars player number
200 buyer number two hundred Lot Number
Nine preacher original comic book art
issue and number nine page 14 signed by
NSN Dylan includes flashback to Jesse's
childhood with multiple images of adult
Jesse and numerous panels of Jesse as a
child and John Custer I have this cool
reference to John Wayne in there too
which is you know it's a big deal in
that book now this bit is already like
way higher than the estimates and way
higher than we've gone before what do
you think that's attributed to is there
an origin story told on this page uh I
mean there's if there's a John Wayne
reference I guess that's kind of part of
the origin right maybe that's kind of
part of what's interesting all right Joe
take it away if it was he Cliff I'd pay
five thousand for it but he's Cliff yeah
I think the East Coast origin story is a
guy going like that Garfield seems to be
doing well exactly perhaps another cat
of sorts there you go I gotta get up
there Sing Sing 52 but you get about
fifty five hundred fifty five hundred
57 56 000 six thousand dollars six
dollars gonna buy sixty two fifty sixty
five hundred sixty five hundred sixty
five hundred sixty five hundred he came
all this way sixty five hundred sixty
five hundred sixty seven fifty sixty
seven fifty seven thousand dollars seven
talking about seven talking about seven
thousand seven by seven thousand six
seven thousand by seventy two fifty
seventy two fifty seventy five hundred
seventy five hundred seventy five
hundred seventy five hundred seventy
five hundred seventy seven fifty eight
thousand dollars eight thousand dollars
eight thousand dollars eight thousand
eight times gonna be talking about six
eight thousand dollars eighty two fifty
eighty two fifty eighty two fifty eighty
two fifty eighty two fifty it came all
this way now eighty two fifty eighty two
fifty eight thousand eighty two billion
eight thousand gonna buy eighty two
fifty eight thousand by eighty two bit
Again by eighty two fifty I got an
eighty two fifty eighty five hundred
eighty five hundred eighty five hundred
eighty five hundred eighty two fifty
eighty five on eighty five I'm gonna buy
eighty seven fifty eighty seven fifty
eighty seven fifty eighty
what's one more bid you came all this
way ladies and gentlemen hit it one more
time trust me you're gonna find yourself
tomorrow going you know I should have
bid one more time it was the under
bidder and I could I've had that happen
plenty of times where I was the
underburning decided damn I should just
win another 250 this is your only chance
to get it that's true not another one
and whoever's buying it is keeping it at
this price I'm telling you right now
8 500 bit 87.50 8500 by 87
15.50 going once 8 500 bid 87.50 going
twice last call in time nine thousand
dollars nine thousand dollars nine
thousand dollars I saw it in your
collection and it slipped away hit it
again nine thousand dollars nine
thousand dollars all right talking about
nine seconds nine thousand of a ninety
two fifty ninety two fifty ninety two
fifty ninety two fifty nine talking
about ninety two picking up a nice
talking about ninety two fifty five
pocket about ninety two fifty ninth how
to get about 92.50 going once don't miss
out nine thousand ninety two fifty going
twice last call
and I sold it for nine thousand dollars
congratulations ladies and gentlemen
buyer number 200 buyer number two
hundred Lot number 10 original comic
book art preacher issue number nine page
15 signed by NSN Millen includes two
images of the adult Jesse one image of
tulip two of Jesse as a child we have
Marie longell and one image of Jody one
of the uh one of the bad guys in the
show in the comic rather and we got more
profanity all right Seventeen hundred
and eighteen hundred Seventeen hundred
of eighteen hundred of eighteen hundred
eighteen hundred by Seventeen hundred
eighteen eighteen hundred nineteen
hundred nineteen hungry about two
thousand dollars two thousand dollars
twenty two hundred twenty two hundred
twenty three hundred twenty three
hundred twenty four hundred twenty four
good about 24.23 you get about twenty
four twenty three hundred by twenty four
hundred twenty four hundred twenty three
hundred about twenty four hundred twenty
three hundred by twenty four hundred
twenty three
about twenty five hundred going twice
last call
sold 2400 buyer number uh 200 buyer
number two hundred Lot number eleven
preacher issue number nine page 18
signed by NSN Dylan includes multiple
images of Marie longell and Jesse has a
child static on dialogue which I always
love that I just think it's so cool if
they stick to Dialogue on to me it makes
it even better when it's done that way
nowadays everything is generated on a
computer right so it's like your your
dialogue they don't stat word balloons
on anymore because they do it right on
the page um this is original comic book
artwork kids back like they used to do
it and a lot even now with a lot of the
viewer books like even the art itself is
just digital yeah you can't even buy you
can't even buy an original page yeah
yeah I tried with Saga like 10 years ago
because I asked and she was like Oh No
It's All Digital oh man this is uh this
is a return to a different more innocent
time kids I'm so delighted to see these
preacher Pages going as well yeah means
there's a lot of preacher fans out there
1600 and 1700 1500 by 1700 by 1600 by
1700 1700 1700 1600 1700 1500 by 179
1700 1600 by 1700 1500 by 1700 1600 by
1700 1500 1700 going once
sixteen hundred and Seventeen hundred
dollars going twice last call
sold sixteen hundred dollars buyer
number two 100 buyer number one hundred
Lot number twelve preacher original
comic book art Issue Number 10 page 17
signed by NSN Dylan includes numerous
images of Jesse and tulip and I believe
the quote is they are screwing like
bunnies all right it was one of those
sex pages yes this is a sex page so we
went from rated R books kids for
language and sex rated R to rated X no
one swoop I got 28 in my 29. 2800 to my
twenty nine hundred twenty nine hundred
gonna buy three packet of my thirty two
fifty thirty two fifty thirty two fifty
thirty two feet about three knocking
about thirty two fifty thirty two fifty
three thousand gonna buy thirty two
fifty get about 325
3250. are you talking about thirty two
fifty are you talking about thirty two
fifty three talking about thirty two
fifty thank you thirty five hundred
thirty five hundred thirty five hundred
thirty seven fifty thirty seven fifty
thirty seven fifty come on I think you
could think you should thirty seven
fifty thirty seven fifty thirty seven
figured about 35
going once four thousand get about 42.50
going twice last call
oh my goodness 4500 42 picking about 4
500. that's how you miss out ladies and
gentlemen don't do that there's always
about a half second to two second delay
but I say going once you should be
bidding because boy oh boy that was
close 42.50 now you should bid don't let
them have it after all that commotion
come on now one more time 4500 4250
about 4 500 42 but you get about 45
[__] about 42 picking about 45 how to
get about 42 50 get about 4500 going
once 42 but to get about 4500 going
twice last call
sold four thousand three hundred and
fifty dollars buyer number one hundred
buyer number one hundred Lot number 13
for sure preacher issue number 11 page
19 signed by Ennis and Dylan includes
Jesse and tulip with uh off panel sex
scene and several instances of taking
the lord's name in vain I liked how cute
I was when I described this stuff yeah
and also that I I can't believe taking
the lord's name in vain is a selling
point there's somebody out there might
be like oh it's one of those pages where
they're sacrilegious I mean we put this
two thousand dollars there you go that's
the whole point of this book
yeah this is the most sacrilegious
man beautiful damn book thirteen hundred
about fourteen hundred thirteen hundred
about fourteen hundred about fourteen
hundred about thirteen hundred about
fourteen hundred thirteen hundred about
fourteen hundred about 1400 about 13
about 14. we're thinking about 14. 13
about 1400 about 1400 about 1300 about
1400 about 1400 about thirteen hundred
about fourteen hundred yep fifteen
fifteen hundred about fifteen fourteen
hundred about 1500 right 400 1500 1400
and 1500. fifteen hundred sixteen
hundred sixteen hundred sixteen hundred
sixteen hundred come on back now sixteen
hundred sixteen hundred by sixteen
hundred fifteen hundred by sixteen
hundred by sixteen hundred fifteen
hundred by sixteen hundred going once
Seventeen hundred Seventeen hundred
sixteen hundred Seventeen hundred
fifteen hundred Seventeen hundred
Seventeen hundred Seventeen hundred
fifteen hundred by Seventeen hundred
fifteen hundred Seventeen hundred
thirteen hundred about Seventeen I'm
gonna buy something one more time
fifteen hundred by Seventeen hundred
going once sixteen hundred by Seventeen
hundred dollars going twice last call
eighteen hundred dollars let's go
eighteen hundred eighteen hundred
eighteen hundred eighteen hundred by
Seventeen hundred eighteen hundred
thirteen hundred eighteen hundred
thirteen hundred eighteen hundred one
more time eighteen hundred eighteen
hundred by eighteen hundred by Seventeen
hundred by eighteen hundred that's like
one hit on a slot machine right yeah
it's like one hit on the slot machine
with the Wizard of Oz is what you play
right eighteen hundred Nineteen Hundred
Nineteen Hundred Nineteen Hundred
Nineteen Hundred eighteen hundred 1900
do it again
1900 Nineteen Hundred eighteen hundred
or Nineteen Hundred eighteen hundred
Nineteen Hundred eighteen hundred
Nineteen Hundred going once eighteen
hundred been nineteen hundred dollars
going twice last call
and I sold it for 1800 buyer number 200.
Lot Number 14 preacher Issue 11 page 13
signed by Garth Ennis and Steve Dillon
multiple images of tulip and God
statadon dialogue God folks this is your
chance to own a Graven image at the Lord
him or herself I gotta spoil it if
you've read preacher you'll know you
could actually get a picture well there
it is I'm gonna say he's right there it
was pretty Jesus like right 1600 1700
1800 1900 1900 two thousand dollars two
thousand dollars two thousand dollars
who's not gonna buy two thousand about
1900 by two thousand dollars Nineteen
Hundred gonna buy two thousand about
2000 by Twenty One hundred twenty one
hundred twenty one hundred twenty one
hundred two thousand by Twenty One
hundred twenty one hundred two thousand
by Twenty One Hundred about twenty one
hundred about two thousand by Twenty One
Hundred you're talking about twenty one
hundred about twenty one hundred two
thousand twenty one hundred of my Twenty
One Hundred about two thousand twenty
one hundred going once come on ladies
and gentlemen one more time you know
you're gonna miss it you know you're
gonna wish you had it
If you bid one more time I can see it in
your collection two talking about twenty
one hundred who's talking about twenty
one hundred going once two talking about
twenty one hundred going twice last call
sold two thousand dollars higher number
200 buyer number two hundred Lot Number
15 preacher Issue 11 page 20 signed by
Garth Ennis and Steve Dillon multiple
images of Jesse and tulip implied nudely
plus profanity what's implied news yeah
it's kind of like a little bump or
something
you could tell that they just made love
and are undressed but you don't see uh
well I I don't see the boobs I should
have paid more attention when you
catalog this I would have been looking
Not only would this be a fine piece of
art for your collection or hanging up on
a wall at home but exactly expect
material as well I like it 26 27 27 28
2800 about 2800 by 27 into my twenty
eight hundred twenty eight hundred
twenty seven hundred by twenty eight
hundred twenty seven hundred by twenty
eight hundred twenty seven hundred by
twenty eight hundred about 28 about 29
2900 2900 2900 2800 by 29 I'm gonna buy
three thousand dollars three thousand
dollars three times
three thousand dollars 2900 about three
thousand dollars twenty nine hundred
number three Target about 300 by 2900 by
three thousand dollars
three talking about thirty two fifty
thirty two fifty thirty two fifty thirty
two fifty three packet about thirty two
fifty three Target about thirty two
fifty are you talking about thirty two
people about 32 minutes we're talking
about 32.50 are you talking about 32
minutes about 32 picking up by three is
not gonna buy 32.50 going once nothing
to think about Asia and you're not gonna
find it again are you talking about
32.50 going twice last call
sold three thousand dollars fire number
200 buyer number 200. Lot number 16
preacher issue 12 page two signed by
garthennis and Steve Dillon includes
multiple images of tulip and one image
of God's hand stated on dialogue
including profanity all right sixteen
hundred bit Seventeen hundred bit
eighteen hundred Nineteen Hundred
Nineteen Hundred Nineteen Hundred two
thousand now we're gonna buy 2100 2100
21. two thousand now we're gonna buy
Twenty One by 21. I like that big
eyeball in the middle there you know I
guess that one segment his eyes her eyes
sticking out who's talking about 2100
she's not gonna buy Twenty One Hundred
two thousand by Twenty One Hundred by
Twenty One Hundred by two thousand by
Twenty One hundred twenty one hundred
twenty one hundred twenty one hundred
two thousand by Twenty One Hundred by
Twenty One Hundred by Twenty One Hundred
going what two thousand dollars with
twenty one hundred dollars going twice
last call
in time
22-23 23 get about 23 get about 22 get
about 2300 2300 2300 22 about 2300 22
get about 2300 about 2300 by 22 by 2300
going once 2200 by 2300 going twice last
call
sold 2200 buyer number 100 buyer number
one hundred but 17 preacher issue number
16 page six signed by Garth anus and
Steve Dillon includes multiple images of
Jesse and Jesus desade it was like a
Marilyn Manson type character that's in
the book uh really includes images of
Jesus to start getting his teeth punched
out
all right he's a bad guy I guess so
I I I'm telling you like I would love to
sit here and give you like an anecdote
about this piece but I'm so hypnotized
by the
bidding process by listening to your
voice well thank you sir oh my god I've
wanted to bid a few times
you've almost like caught me into it hey
there you go 2400 2500 24 get about 20
pocket about 2500 about 2500 2400 about
2500 2400 by 2500 2500 2400 about 2500
about 2500 by 2600 2600 2600 2600 2600
2600 2600 2500 by 2600 2500 by 2600 by
2600 by 2600 2500 by 2600 about 2600
about 26 about 2700 2700 2700 2700 2700
what is here by twenty seven hundred
twenty six hundred by twenty seven
hundred twenty six hundred by twenty
seven by twenty eight hundred twenty
eight hundred twenty eight hundred
twenty eight hundred twenty eight
hundred twenty eight hundred twenty
eight hundred twenty eight hundred I
know you're thinking about it hit it
again twenty eight hundred twenty eight
hundred twenty seven hundred by twenty
eight hundred one more time twenty eight
hundred twenty eight hundred twenty
seven hundred by Twenty Eight about
twenty nine hundred twenty nine hundred
twenty nine hundred about three thousand
dollars three thousand dollars three
thousand dollars three thousand dollars
come on back now three thousand dollars
three thousand dollars three thousand
dollars I know you got it three hundred
by thirty two fifty thirty two fifty
thirty two fifty thirty two fifty thirty
two fifty thirty two fifty thirty two
fifty thirty two fifty three talking
about thirty two weekend about thirty
two fifty are you talking about thirty
two fifty one more time he's talking
about thirty two fifty you're talking
about thirty two people about thirty two
fifty are you talking about 32 picking
about thirty two fifty can about thirty
two fifty going once
three thousand dollars with thirty two
fifty going twice last call in time
thirty five hundred thirty two minutes
about thirty five hundred thirty five
hundred thirty five hundred thirty five
hundred one more time thirty five
hundred he came all this way thirty five
hundred thirty five hundred thirty five
hundred thirty five hundred thirty two
biting about thirty five hundred thirty
two predicted about thirty five hundred
going once
32 but again about thirty five hundred
going twice last call
so three thousand two hundred and fifty
dollars buyer number two hundred buyer
number two hundred Lot number eighteen
two pieces of original comic book art
for DC's Hitman issue number two page
18. one of the pages is preliminary
pencils and the other one is the final
Inked art the artist by John McRae
includes one image of Hitman as well as
uh Mad Hatter mentioned a joker and a
large image of the Batman it's set in
Arkham Asylum and Hitman is such a great
book if you haven't read it that might
be sometimes it's my favorite of all the
gar Thanos books too people don't talk
about it as much anymore yeah it's one
you would imagine that like in a world
when the streaming wars were going on
when it was HBO Max before it was Max
you could have seen that being a show
and maybe under uh James Gunn and his
new DC Universe it could still wind up
being a show yeah and it would be
greater on though if I remember
correctly I think I think Anderson McRae
actually own it oh good for them I
remember correctly what I love about
these Lots is that you had the
preliminary and then the regular and
then the ink part that's really cool how
you got both there you know um I gotta
ask you this man like so do you take all
of tomorrow off from talking now we have
another sale tomorrow are you serious
yes but then after that I I I yeah but
after this I I smoke a cigar after this
so that's it all right yeah that is oh
my God I smoke like three cigars a day
if I was you I wouldn't [__] with that
instrument and you know what I haven't
smoked all day today so I'm you know I'm
ready for it I'll be ready for it there
you go all right uh where are we at
we're at 2400 bit twenty five twenty
four hundred about 2500 by 25 get about
2500 2500 2500 2500 2400 about 2500
about 2500 by 24 good about 2500 24 good
about 25 24 good about 25 2400 about
2500 by 25 2600 2600 2600 2600 2600 2600
2600 2600 one more time 2600 25
going once come on one more time you
know you're thinking about it 26 27 do
it again 27 2700
27.27 by 2800 2800 1800 1800 1800 2700
by 2800 2700 by 2800 2700 by 2800 by
twenty eight hundred twenty seven
hundred by twenty eight hundred twenty
seven hundred by twenty eight hundred by
twenty seven hundred by twenty eight
hundred going once twenty seven hundred
and twenty eight hundred dollars going
twice last call
sold twenty seven hundred dollars buyer
number one hundred buyer number one
hundred Lot number nineteen two pieces
of original comic book art from Hitman
issue number two page 19 the preliminary
pencils and the final Inked art by John
McRae multiple images of Hitman one
image two-faced and Mr zaz Mr zaz you're
the guy who every time he makes a kill
yeah you get another Stars himself Cuts
himself he's a cutter kids don't do that
two thousand twenty one hundred two
talking about twenty one hundred number
twenty one hundred about twenty one
hundred twenty one hundred two talking
about twenty one hundred twenty one
hundred twenty one hundred twenty one
hundred two thousand about twenty one
hundred about twenty one hundred of my
2000 because about twenty one hundred
twenty one hundred twenty one hundred
you're about 200 by Twenty One hundred
twenty one hundred by twenty two hundred
twenty two hundred twenty two hundred
twenty two hundred twenty one hundred by
twenty three hundred twenty three
hundred twenty three hundred twenty
three hundred twenty three hundred
twenty three hundred twenty two hundred
about twenty three hundred about twenty
three gonna buy twenty two by twenty
three twenty two good about twenty three
hundred twenty three hundred twenty
three hundred 2300 about 23 you get
about 2300 So what at 2300 is the Hitman
part of like Batman is that what the
deal is so basically he was um in the DC
Universe he's a uh super powered Hitman
he was a low-level Hitman who got
himself some superpowers so he could
take out super individuals if he had to
okay so he was an anti-hero to say the
least and then as the book progressed it
became less and less about the
superheroes and more about like
friendship between him and his other
like Hitman friends and stuff okay it
was really really a great book but the
Two-Face that's in there yeah so is he
basically they were able to use
characters liberally across the DC
Universe for this book okay and blend
them in uh together and these Pages come
like with a pencil page and an app page
which is rare generally speaking pencils
became inks people would ink on top of
the pencils but the way McRae worked is
he kept his pencils separate from his
ink so you wind up getting two pages two
for the price of one two for the price
of one indeed
2600 2600 2600 2500 by 2600
2500 2700 2700 2700 2700 2700 by 2600 by
twenty seven hundred twenty six hundred
by twenty seven hundred twenty six
hundred by twenty seven hundred what do
you think about 27 seconds about 2700
going once twenty six hundred by twenty
seven hundred dollars going twice last
call
sold twenty six hundred dollars buyer
number one hundred Lot number twenty two
more pieces of uh oh we have the demon
art this time issue number zero page ten
art by John McRae we have the
preliminary pencils and the final Inked
art statiton dialogue or two-thirds
splash page featuring The Demon etragon
and Jason blood
um that gorgeous McRae artwork and look
at the two stunning images of Glorious
DC Comics characters both Jason blood
and his alter ego the demonetric I got
400 four and a quarter four and a half
475 500 five and a quarter five and a
half five seventy five six hundred six
and a quarter six and a half six seventy
five seven hundred seven quarters seven
and a half seven seventy five eight
hundred eight and a quarter eight and a
half eight seventy five nine hundred
nine and a quarter nine and a half nine
seventy five a thousand dollars thousand
I'm not gonna be talking about talking
about eleven hundred thousand hundred of
Eleven Hundred by twelve hundred by
twelve hundred by twelve hundred by
twelve hundred by Thirteen hundred
thirteen hundred fourteen hundred
fourteen hundred fourteen hundred
thirteen hundred about fourteen hundred
about four tickets about thirteen
hundred about fourteen hundred thirteen
hundred about fourteen hundred going
once don't miss out now thirteen hundred
about fourteen hundred dollars going
twice last call
two pieces of original comic book art
Hitman issue number four page 12
preliminary pencils and final Inked art
by John McRae includes multiple images
of Hitman and Wendy in bed
Wendy in bed but this is this was a
comic set in the DC Universe so it's not
it's not as uh it's not a preacher
wedding event preacher preacher got away
with a lot more of these cats they
actually had to keep it kind of covered
up yeah this is like a PG-13 all right
no nip slip whatsoever got it I got 1112
1100 by 12 100 by 12 100 by 12. well I'm
gonna get about 1200.
1200 they're talking about twelve
hundred they're talking about 1200. 1300
1300 1300 1200 1300 oh I'm gonna get
about 13. I'm gonna get about 1300 get
about 1300 by 12 13. come on hit it
again 13. 1300. 1300 1300 12 1300. 1300
about 1300 by 12. 1300 coming once 12
I'm gonna get about thirteen hundred
dollars going twice last call
22 two pieces of original comic book art
DC Batman Legend Through The Dark Knight
issue 83 page nine preliminary pencils
and final Inked art by John McRae
multiple images of Batman one dead body
and a two-thirds splash page of the
Batmobile look at that look at that
stage this is the pencils let's see them
inks let's see what happens
oh look at that yeah that's gorgeous
that's a gorgeous shot of the Batmobile
you're getting your main character up
there this is from when McRae did an
issue of Legends of the Dark Knight so
you're getting a Batman page with a
Batmobile for heaven's sakes in the low
low price of right now
325 pretty good man three and a quarter
chance to jump in there tell them how
they can win a Joe three and a quarter
three and a half three and a half 375
400 about 400.375 400 four and a quarter
four record about four and a quarter
four and a half four and a half four and
a half what a quarter been four fifty
one according to Mid four and a half
nothing to think about let's go guys
four and a half four seventy five more
somebody pocket about four seventy
pocket about four pick it up four
seventy five four seventy five now five
hundred five [__] number five okay
five and a quarter five and a quarter
five and a quarter five and a half five
and a half by 75.75 70 pocket number
five seventy five do it again five
seventy five five
nothing to think about buying 75 600.
find somebody pocketed by 600. find
somebody pocketed by 600 600 six and a
quarter six and a quarter six twenty
five six twenty five six twenty five six
hundred by six twenty five six seconds
Now's the Time the buy we're in lot 22.
it ain't gonna get much cheaper than
this this is the sleeper guys pay
attention now 625 625 650 650 650 620
pocket about 650. come on back
invaluable 650 675 got a couple of you
out there 675 do it again 675. next
video about six seventy five six five to
get about six seventy five six minutes
six seventy five going once don't miss
out
now 700 700 700 on The Dark Knight guy
700 700 700 seven a quarter I was
actually watching The Dark Knight last
night it was on TV last night the movie
works well man this is an excellent
price uh for this page man if you were
ever thinking about getting into comic
book art collecting doing it for under a
ground in this day and age is pretty
sweet yeah no I don't disagree with you
stop and a quarter seven hundred by
seven twenty five gonna buy seven
hundred by seven twenty five into my
seven hundred by seven twenty five seven
hundred by seven twenty five going what
yep and a half seven halves
everybody
750 going what
720 pocketed by
750.775 775 you're making me work guys
you guys who want to listen to me all
day let's go
7.75.75
75 going once seven fifty bit 775 going
twice last call
775 now 800 800 to 800 1175 800 800
sneaky sneaky sneaky don't let them
sneak in like that 800 800 or 800 800 to
800.75 800.75 800.75
775 bid 800 going once 775 800 going
twice last call
sold 775 buyer number 200 thank you all
for bidding Lot 23 two pieces of
original comic book card from Batman
Chronicles issue for page one Community
pencils and final and start by John Gray
full splash page of Batman in the rain
with a gun in his mouth it's uh it's
hitman's gun cool spoiler alert yeah
look at this page it was pretty damn
impressive it is impressive right if
you're a Batman fan come on Batman with
a gun in his mouth Evans yeah right if
you're how bad at us is the Hitman that
he got to do that to Batman to Batman
that's uh something like a lot of people
generally fans will complain about if
you create a character bring him into an
established universe and then make them
overpowered over their their characters
allowed the audience will to get turned
off by it but everyone loved Garth anus
nobody yeah crunched in that one it's a
great book if you haven't read Hitman
read the whole thing it's super
underrated it really might be his best
book really is
this is a great place look at that man
Batman with a gun in his mouth in the
Rain the most emo piece of artwork will
be auctioning off today kids Take it
Away Joe 850 8.75 85
875.75
85. hey 75
75.99
a quarter nine a quarter nine a quarter
nine a quarter uh nine twenty five not
talking about 9.25
number 900 number nine twenty five not
talking about nine twenty five number
nine twenty five number nine hundred
number nine twenty five I think you
could I think you should do it again 925
number
9.25.925 number nine twenty five number
nine twenty five number nine hundred
number nine twenty five doesn't get much
darker than that for Batman guys come on
guys 925
925 going once this is a page one issue
four ladies and gentlemen Batman with a
gun in his mouth come on now 900 nine
and a quarter I'm talking about nine
twenty pocket number nine hundred number
nine twenty five going one
going once 950 been 975 going twice last
call
sold 950 here buyer number 100.
Lot 24 two pieces of original comic book
art Batman Chronicles issue for page two
includes the preliminary pencils and the
final Inked art uh we have multiple
images of Batman and Martin Eckstein
it's got that gun in his mouth again
there on the bottom right I guess maybe
it was Martin putting the gun in the
mouth and then Hitman showed up I might
have misremembered let's see the ink
page again
there you go
yeah cause that's not Tommy Flanagan I
don't know yeah I could be I could have
misremembered that either way either way
we still got gun in his mouth yeah his
mouth and there's also the big ass
uh panel up top see all that cape look
at all that Cape very cool four and a
quarter wanted some Cape kids this is
your this is your page right here four
and a quarter four and a half four and a
half four picking it about four picking
about four picking up a four twenty
pocket about 450. what's 25 about 450.4
pick it up four picking it about four
picking number four twenty five four
fifty four seventy five or somebody
talking about 475. we'll forget about
four somebody [__] about four pick it
up four seven five four seven pocket
about four make it about four seventy
five or if I get above 475 475 now 500
500 500 or somebody talking about 500.
watch everybody
[__] number five hundred five and a
quarter five and a quarter five and a
quarter five hundred about five twenty
five five [__] number five twenty
pocket about five [__] number five
twenty pocket about five hundred number
five twenty five five twenty five five
twenty five five hundred about five
twenty pocket about five hundred about
five twenty pocket about five hundred
number five twenty five five [__]
about five twenty five hundred about
five twenty pocket about five hundred
about five twenty five about five
hundred about five twenty five I forget
about five twenty [__] number five
hundred number five
you're missing the boat ladies and
gentlemen last call this is a great Buy
and I sold it for 500 here by our number
100 buyer number 100. 25 two pieces of
original comic book are DC's Batman
Chronicles Issue four page six
preliminary pencils and final Inked art
by John McRae multiple images of the
Hitman and Martin xdean and there's also
one of the Batman yeah
650 and inks yet again okay let's see
that mix oh so impressive that is 650
but 675 650 gonna buy Six seventy pocket
to buy six seven pocket number six by
six seventy five six feet again about
675 650 gonna buy Six seventy five six
seven five six figures about six seventy
five now seven hundred seven hundred
seven hundred six seventy pocketed by
700.75
700.6 70 pocket about 700.7500 by 700
670 pocketed by 700. somebody [__]
Divine seven hundred five seven hundred
by six seventy pocketed by 700. 70
pocketed by 700.75 700 by 700 by six
seventy pocketed by 700 700 1100 675 700
by 700 by six seventy five bits seven
hundred going once
675 made seven hundred dollars going
twice last call
sold 675 dollars the buyer number uh 100
buyer number 100 Lot number 26 two
pieces of original comic book art DC's
Batman Chronicles issue for page 12
preliminating pencils and final inks art
by John McRae multiple images of Batman
The Hitman and Martin nextstein
six and a quarter six and a half six and
a quarter but six and a half six and a
half six and a quarter but six and a
half six in the quarter mid six and a
half next time to get about six we get
about six
six fifty six seventy five six seventy
five six seven five six figures about
six seventy five six make it by 675 65
675 675 65 675
going once nothing to think about ladies
and gentlemen another two page with the
preliminary and the actual Inked Batman
in action there 675 650
675 going once 650 bid 675 going twice
last call in time 700 700 by 700 seven
and a quarter seven hundred by seven and
a quarter seven twenty five hundred by
seven twenty five hundred by seven
twenty five seven hundred by seven
twenty Pockets about seven fifty Seven
fifty Seven seventy five seven seventy
five never thinking about seven seventy
pocket about seven figures
seven seventy five going once seven
50-bit 775 going twice last call
sold 750 dollars here buyer number 100
buyer number 100 Lot Number 27 the
preliminary pencil cover art to DC's
Hitman number four
by John McRae of course yeah this
includes a Hitman and Nat the Hat the
hitman's best friend so Kevin with the
all these that are like the preliminary
in the thing and it's from the same
comic did you buy them all at the same
time or was this something you collected
like you had to get it from different
places I'm just curious uh a lot of the
Hitman pages I got on the same day at
San Diego Comic Con years ago uh God
we're going back to when the book was
being published
um and then some other pages I chased
down after that right so I was always
you know I was not the guy my friend
Dave Mandel has a massive collection
where he has Frank Miller Dark Knight
pages and stuff like that wow I was
never that guy he's he's donated pieces
that were was that like the Rock and
Roll Hall of Fame where they did like a
Marvel exhibit so he's got like serious
pages I just collected stuff that I was
a fan of that was affordable right so
back in the day anytime I saw McRae
stuff pop up Steve Dylan stuff pop up
that's when I jumped in so I I bought I
imagine with this piece since there's no
inks to it all I could get were the
pencils of the cover got it yeah it's
still really cool though and I mean you
got you got the Hitman and you got Nat
that's that's the two dude man that was
his buddy six and a quarter six and a
half 600 but six and a quarter rather
600 by 625 600 by 620 pocket about six
twenty of my six twenty pocket about 650
650 675 675 the only way to combat that
is a different microphone but that mic
is the same problem at the church
going once 650 bid 675 going twice last
call
sold 650 dollars here buyer number uh to
100 buyer number one hundred Lot number
28 original comic book art Batman
Legends of the Dark Knight issue 30 page
13 art by Matt Wagner with multiple
images of Batman these are great one of
my favorite artists on the planet uh
Matt Wagner did Mage back in the day the
entire Mage series uh but whenever he
[__] with Batman I was right there in
line for it cool and if you like Mage we
have a spectacular Mage piece coming up
later in the sale we do look at this
page man it's great his Batman is kind
of like a magic Kelly's year one Batman
look how gorgeous that is oh my God he's
Matt Wagner is just absolutely one of
the best I got 1700 with 1800 1700 with
1800 1800 1800 17 11800 number 1900 1900
1900 1900 1900 1800 by 1900 1800 1900 by
two thousand dollars two thousand
dollars two thousand
going once
what do you want talking about 2200
hours going 29 23 23. Matt Wagner guys
let's go 2300 2300 22 get about 2300
2200 about 2300 2200 by 2300 going once
2200 about twenty three hundred dollars
going twice last call
sold twenty two hundred dollars the
buyer number 100 buyer number two
hundred rather 200. what 29 original
comic book art Batman Grendel 2 Devil's
bones page two great art of course by
Mark uh sorry Matt Wagner and signed by
him full splash page image of Batman and
the Gotham City scale this is sexy man
look at that look at that piece oh it's
so great isn't it it's I mean if you
ever wanted to own a Batman piece of
original artwork look at Matt Wagner's
Batman glorious over the top of the
Gotham City Sky oh it's fantastic you
even got it looks like the Chrysler type
building there and he's hanging over to
size it's fantastic it hits on all
levels right there 2100 by 2200 2200
2300 2300 2300 2300 2300 2400 2400 2400
it hits on all levels if you're a Batman
fan here it is working about 2500 2500
2500 2500 2500 2500 2500 600 2600 2600
2600 2600 2600 2600 2600 nothing to
think about twenty six hundred do it
again twenty seven hundred twenty seven
hundred twenty seven hundred twenty
seven hundred twenty seven hundred one
more time twenty seven hundred twenty
seven hundred twenty seven hundred
twenty seven hundred twenty seven
hundred twenty seven hundred what do you
think about twenty seven twenty second
about twenty seven hundred twenty six
hundred about twenty seven hundred what
do you say talking about twenty seven
hundred going once yeah twenty eight
hundred twenty eight hundred twenty
eight hundred by twenty eight hundred
twenty seven hundred by twenty eight
hundred do it again twenty eight hundred
twenty one hundred twenty eight hundred
twenty eight hundred twenty nine hundred
twenty nine hundred twenty nine hundred
twenty nine hundred twenty eight number
twenty nine Twenty Eight about twenty
nine hundred twenty nine hundred twenty
eight hundred by twenty nine hundred
twenty eight hundred by twenty nine
hundred going once once again Batman
just holding over to bridge there over
the the top of the building you got the
uh like you said Gotham City in there
man when I when I quoted before in in
the articles I wrote this is a keeper
guys this one is a keyword is I put in
my house but I'm too cheap twenty nine
hundred three thousand but thirty two
fifty I think I'll just photocopy and
put it I'll nft that's what I'll do
that's what all the kids are doing these
days I just read an article about how
popular nfts are yeah there you go it's
happening by 3250 3250 3250 3250 39
about 32.50 nothing to think about 32.50
32.50 are you talking about 32 picking
about 3250 one more time are you talking
about 32.50 are you talking about 32.50
are you talking about 32.50 going once
three thousand about 32.50 going twice
last call
sold three thousand dollars buyer number
200 buyer number 200. that's gonna make
somebody so happy that pizza
Lot number 30 original comic book nice
to me Batman Grendel 2 Devil's bones
page 12 art by Matt Wagner signed by him
full splash page image of Batman
crashing through a skylight man let's
see that artwork there it is oh come on
I don't get much better than that man oh
my good God look at the glory that is
Batman just batmaning the [__] out of
that window there you go 2100 2200 2300
2300 2400 2400 2400 2500 2500 2500 2500
24 25
2600 2600 2600 2700 2700 2700 2700 27
I'm gonna buy twenty seconds about 2700
what do you say cricket about 2700 what
do you say talking about twenty seven
hundred what do you say talking about
twenty seven hundred twenty seven
hundred twenty seven this is just as
nice if not entered in the last one
twenty eight hundred twenty eight
hundred twenty eight hundred twenty
eight hundred twenty eight hundred
twenty eight hundred one oh one twenty
twenty eight hundred twenty eight
hundred twenty seven hundred by twenty
eight hundred two hundred or something I
don't know 2800 why it doesn't post that
twenty eight hundred twenty seven
hundred by twenty eight hundred by
hundred by twenty eight hundred twenty
seven hundred by twenty eight hundred
going once don't miss out for a hundred
bucks 2 800 of my 2900 going twice last
call
sold twenty eight hundred dollars 200
buys two hundred buys lot 31 Batman
Grendel Two Devil's bones page 31 signed
by Matt Wagner full Supply page image of
Batman investigating with a microscope
and there's a large stat
let's look at this this is a piece uh
that features Batman doing but he's
known for doing Beyond just punching
muggers in the face yeah man is a
detective yeah
look at him detectiving and scienting
look at that Matt Wagner giving Batman
his do and this glorious splash page
nine and a quarter nine and a half nine
seventy five yeah five thousand dollars
Eleven Hundred Eleven Hundred eleven I'm
not gonna get about 1200 by 12.00 about
thirteen hundred thirteen hundred
thirteen hundred fourteen hundred
fourteen hundred fourteen hundred
thirteen hundred about fourteen hundred
about fifteen hundred fifteen hundred
fifteen hundred by sixteen hundred
sixteen hundred sixteen hundred fifteen
hundred about sixteen hundred fifteen
hundred by sixteen hundred sixteen
hundred Seventeen hundred Seventeen
hundred Seventeen hundred thirteen
hundred Seventeen hundred eighteen
hundred eighteen hundred eighteen
hundred fifteen hundred of eighteen
hundred eighteen hundred about Nineteen
Hundred Nineteen Hundred Nineteen
Hundred Nineteen Hundred eighteen
hundred about 1900 1800 1900 by two
thousand dollars two thousand dollars
two thousand dollars two thousand I'll
get about 19 about two thousand dollars
1900 two thousand dollars Nineteen
Hundred about you talking about 1900
1900 by two thousand dollars going once
Nineteen Hundred bit two thousand
dollars going twice I think you're
missing the boat last call
sold for nineteen hundred dollars to buy
our number one hundred buyer number one
hundred lot thirty two original comic
book art Batman Grendel 2 Devil's bones
page 48 Son by Matt Wagner full splash
page of Grendel Prime Holding a bloody
Batman yeah there's got to be a thrill
for any uh Creator character creator uh
Matt Wagner created Grendel way back in
the day the hunter Rose Grendel of
course but then later on he did this
Grendel Prime and look at it Grendel
Prime just holding a bloody beat up
Batman and what who is he's a he's a bad
guy I guess yeah he's he's definitely a
bad guy he's on the on the bad like a
bane almost yeah a little bit Yeah he
was a Relentless killer okay twenty two
hundred twenty three hundred twenty four
hundred twenty five hundred twenty six
hundred twenty six hundred twenty six
hundred twenty seven hundred twenty
seven hundred twenty seven hundred come
on be relentless and keep bidding twenty
seven hundred twenty eight hundred
twenty eight hundred twenty nine hundred
twenty nine hundred twenty nine hundred
twenty 800 by 2 900 2800 by 2900 2900
2900 about three thousand dollars three
thousand dollars three knocking about
thirty two fifty thirty two fifty thirty
two fifty three Target about thirty two
fifty thirty two bit about thirty five
hundred thirty five hundred thirty five
hundred about thirty seven fifty thirty
seven fifty thirty seven picking about
four thousand dollars four thousand
dollars for a second about forty two
fifty forty two fifty forty two fifty
forty two fifty forty two fifty forty
two fifty I think you could I think you
should one more time forty two fifty
forty two about forty two we get about
four thousand get about forty two fifty
or talking about forty two fifty we're
talking about forty two minutes about
forty two make it about forty five
hundred forty five hundred forty five
hundred forty five hundred forty seven
fifty forty seven fifty forty seven
fifty forty five hundred above forty
seven fifty forty five hundred about
forty seven fifty forty five [__]
about forty seven fifty forty five
hundred about forty seven fifty do it
again one more time forty seven fifty
forty five hundred about forty seven
fifty going once
forty five hundred forty seven fifty
going twice last call
sold for four thousand seven hundred and
fifty or forty five hundred dollars
rather than buyer number 200 buyer two
hundred thirty three Grendel Batman 2
Devil's dance page nine are signed by
Matt Wagner includes the image of the
Batman logo two images of Batman and
multiple Batmobiles love it just like I
have that logo behind it it's not really
a logo I don't even think that's a logo
but look at that Montage piece that's a
beauty guys that back I love that Batman
there it is 1500 left-hand corner you
can see there's an image of Batman close
up on his face lots of the Batmobile
lots of Cape action but of course Matt
Wagner's rendition of the symbol dead
center there you go
don't miss out you got a great page
there with a with a logo right in the
middle it's fantastic guys 2100 by 2200
going twice last call
yep just in time 2300 what did you get
about 23 get about twenty three hundred
twenty three hundred twenty three
hundred twenty four hundred twenty four
hundred
come on bid now 2400 2300 about 2400
2300 about 2400 2300 about twenty four
hundred twenty four hundred twenty three
hundred by twenty four hundred what is
300 about 2400 going once it's the wrong
error of Batman but it's in there do
anything talking about twenty four
hundred going twice last call 24 25
2500 2400 about 2500 2400 by 2500 2400
by 2500 going once twenty four hundred
about twenty five hundred dollars going
twice last call
sold for twenty four hundred dollars
buyer number two hundred about 34
original comic book art Grendel Batman 2
Devil's dance page 13 art by Matt Wagner
signed by him who's multiple images
Batman and there's also an image of
Crystal Prime
that's nice I'm happy for that image it
was probably more for the beat up Batman
than the Grendel Prime yeah the world's
biggest Kindle Prime fan just made out
of like a bandit before either way you
got more grindel Prime action here and
Batman Matt Wagner action I'll tell you
seeing the pages these Matt Wagner Pages
go for over the estimates like number
one makes me happy of course because I'm
like I'm rich but number two
um it makes me happy to see people have
respect and appreciation for uh somebody
who is absolutely one of the best and
still is at the craft
um and draws a hell of a Batman so I'm
happy to see the Matt Wagner Pages go
for a premium 575 600. somebody [__]
device
six and a quarter six and a quarter six
and a quarter six and a half six and a
half six and a half 675 675 700 700 700
675 700 by six seventy five seven
hundred by six seventy pocket about
700.75
sold 725 the buyer number 200 200 buys
lot 35 Grendel Batman 2 Devil's dance
page 14 original comic cards signed by
Matt Wagner includes a large image
Grendel Prime and two images of Batman
twenty one hundred twenty two hundred
twenty two hundred about twenty two
hundred by Twenty One twenty two Twenty
One Hundred by twenty two hundred twenty
two hundred twenty one hundred about
twenty two hundred twenty one hundred by
twenty two hundred by twenty two hundred
by Twenty One Hundred by twenty two
hundred twenty two hundred twenty two
hundred twenty two hundred another great
image of what's what's
of Gotham if I remember correct yeah no
that that Grendel Prime that's cool man
twenty two hundred about twenty three
twenty three hundred about twenty four
hundred twenty four hundred twenty four
hundred twenty three hundred about
twenty four hundred twenty three hundred
about twenty four hundred twenty three
hundred about twenty four good about
twenty five hundred twenty five hundred
twenty five hundred twenty six hundred
twenty six hundred twenty six hundred
come on now back down twenty six hundred
don't miss out 2600 I can see it next to
the other one you probably just bought
9600 2600 or you missed the other one
and now you need this one 2600 2500 by
2600 2500 by 2600 25
200 going once now seven twenty seven
hundred twenty seven hundred twenty
seven hundred twenty seven hundred
twenty eight hundred twenty eight
hundred twenty eight hundred It's Only
Money it's only a hundred dollars more
twenty eight hundred twenty eight
hundred twenty eight hundred twenty
seven hundred about twenty eight hundred
twenty seven hundred by twenty eight
hundred twenty seven hundred about
twenty eight hundred going once twenty
seven hundred about twenty eight hundred
dollars going twice last call
sold for 2 700 the buyer number 200 200
buys Lot 36 Grendel Batman 2 Devil's
dance Double splash page so this is
Pages 22 and 23 designed by Matt Wagner
large depiction of the bat cave and the
Batmobile and two images of Batman like
this is like absolute like show stopper
look at the glory of this piece look at
that that's a framer if ever there was
oh yeah man Batman just standing there
looking at it he's looking at the brain
of Grendel Prime that's fantastic
Stewart is one of his trophies cool yeah
this is a fantastic piece by Matt Wagner
look at the detail in the bat cave and
of course he's got the giant dinosaur
the giant playing card the giant penny
in there if you ever wanted the bat cave
on your wall you could do a lot worse
than Matt Wagner's gorgeous stunning
representation from Grendel Batman to
Devil's dance 2300 number 2400 2300
about 2400 about 2400 2400 23 are you
talking
let's call
sold twenty three hundred dollars nice
buy buyer number uh 200 buyer 200. Lot
37 Grendel Batman 2 Devil's dance page
45 signed by Matt Wagner includes the
large image of Batman the large image
Robin and the Grendel logo uh look at
this Matt Wagner's depiction of uh Robin
yeah right you rarely get that and down
below of course as mentioned is the
Grendel logo uh but man he's holding a
skull or something right he is and he's
also wearing this is uh I think the
Jason no not the Jason Todd the Tim
Drake Robin yeah Drake with the black
cape and stuff
um gorgeous piece which features uh two
of comics most beloved characters Batman
and Robin together batmaning and Robin
together there you go 13 in about 14 13
about 1400 1400 1400 1500 1500 1500 1500
1500 1500 1600 1700 1700 17 gigabyte
17900 1700 1600 about 1700 1500 by 1700
1600 by 17. 1800 1800 1800 1800 1800
1700 1800 1700 1800 1800 1800 about 1700
1800 1700 by 1800 1700 1800 1800 1900
1900 1900 1900 them have it now 1900 one
more time Nineteen Hundred Nineteen
Hundred Nineteen Hundred eighteen
hundred about Nineteen Hundred eighteen
hundred over Nineteen Hundred eighteen
hundred about Nineteen Hundred going
once
eighteen hundred and nineteen hundred
dollars going twice last call
eighteen hundred dollars buyer number
200 200 buys Lot number 38 Grendel
Batman Two Devil's dance page 47 art
signed by Matt Wagner includes an
interior of the bat cave multiple images
of Batman and Robin
450. if I remember correctly yes this is
the page Matt Wagner told me a story
about this um he had a Batman refer to
Robin as Chum which is what he Batman
used to call Robin on the Adam West TV
show right right
um and Matt Wagner's first Batman like
for a lot of people our age was the Adam
West Batman and stuff so in this panel
up above the item call Rob and his Chum
and then DC editorial kicked it back and
said you can't do that oh that's too
much like the other show so what does it
say right now he calls him something
else maybe he just calls him Robin he
uses his name it's in that top big panel
yeah just as Robin so he wanted it to
say Chum but then DC editorial was like
just call him Robin we're trying to
leave that stuff behind cool a little
bit of History yeah no that's really
cool seven and a quarter 700 about 7 25.
I'm gonna buy seven twenty pocket of my
seven twenty five into my 700 by 720
talking about seven fifty Seven 25
divide 7 57 57 57 25 757 75 775 775 775
775. never thinking about 775
775 going once
sounds like you're gonna get a good deal
here right in the middle of the estimate
this is a good deal this is a very rare
piece and as much as you uh Batman has a
bunch of trophies in the Batcave but
rarely did they depict them going in
this is the depiction of a trophy going
into the bat cave I got the yepper yep
and eight and a quarter a and a half
eight and a quarter of an eight and a
half eight and a half eight and a half
eight according
75 875 875 85
875.75
I think you could think you should let's
do it again 875
New Blood 900 900 900 come on back now
909 a quarter nine and a quarter nine
and a quarter nine a quarter nine
hundred number nine twenty five number
nine hundred number nine twenty five
hundred number nine twenty five hundred
number nine twenty [__] number nine
number nine twenty five going once 900
about 925 going twice last call
in time 9 50. 9 50 9 50 9 59 59 59 59
259 25
number nine fifty going once nine twenty
five number nine hundred and fifty nine
seventy five nine seventy five nine
seventy five don't let them have it it's
25 more dollars and you guys are
stalling me out let's go 975 you're
gonna miss out 9.75 now I'm gonna get
about 9.75 number nine seventy five
going once nine fifty mid 975 going
twice last call
sold 950 dollars by our number 200 200
buys Lot number 39 Batman Legends of the
Dark Knight Halloween special number one
page seven art by the great Tim sales
signed by Tim to Kevin pretty darn cool
includes one image of the Batman looking
for scarecrow look at that man the late
great Tim sale
um half of the party responsible for
those Batman books uh with uh the long
Halloween Dark Victory all those books
man with Jeff
um
this is a rare chance to own artwork uh
drawn by a legend who sadly won't be
drawing any more artwork we lost him
sail not too long ago such a nice guy
and God I loved his Batman I loved his
entire style yeah yeah his art was was
really great I love how he's holding the
head of who's that the Joker or somebody
that he's holding the head in the head
it's a random Thug random Thug I like
that random Thug funny pocket about 2600
2500 by 2600 by 2600 25 [__] about
2600 2600 2600 he came all this way 2600
2700 2700 2700 2700 2700 2700 2600 by
2700 by 20 seconds by 2700 what do you
think I'm gonna buy 2700 there's two of
you out there in a valuable don't lose
out for a hundred bucks guys I got 2600
on live auctioneers but 2700. what do
you think I'm going to buy 2700 by 22nd
about 2700 going once now 28 2800 2800
2700 by 2800 about 2827
I get my 2800 going once 2900 2900 2900
2900 2800 by 2900 2800 by 2900 by 2900
by 28 by 29 2800 by 2900 by 2900 by 29
2900 going once
2829 now three thousand dollars three
thousand dollars what are you talking
about three talking about three times
about 32.50 3250 3250 3250 32 video
about 32 but you get about three
thousand get about 32.50 three times
about thirty two fifty thirty two fifty
three thinking about 32 putting about
three talking about 32 minutes about
three talking about thirty two fifty
going once three thousand dollars with
thirty two fifty going twice last call
sold three thousand dollars buyer number
100 buyer number one hundred by the way
if you're watching us on Facebook right
now if you want to participate you have
to embed you got to go to
bognersauction.com go to
www.bodnersauction.com or just keep on
viewing and have a great evening
watching us sell a bunch of comic card
what do we got next Lot number 40 Batman
Legends of the Dark Knight Halloween
special number two page 41 again art by
Tim sale several images of the Batman
and there's a Cheshire Cat reference
nice all right here we go I got
2400.25. this is great look at that was
there a cat looking in the window or
something yep it's got to be him at
Arkham I would imagine right and there's
like some cat looking through the window
there that's really cool 2500 about 2600
2600 2600 2600 2600 2700 2700 2700 2800
2800 2800 2800 2800 a great image there
twenty eight hundred twenty nine hundred
twenty nine hundred 900 2900 2900 2800
by twenty nine hundred twenty eight
hundred about twenty nine hundred wait
nine hundred about two thousand dollars
three thousand now we're gonna buy three
times three thousand dollars wait not
talking about three thousand I'm gonna
come on back that three thousand what do
you know about three times we're talking
about three thousand what not 100 by
three thousand wait nine hundred about
three talking about three talking about
twenty three thousand dollars thirty two
fifty thirty two fifty thirty two fifty
thirty five hundred thirty five hundred
thirty five hundred thirty two fifty
thirty two but again about thirty five
hundred thirty two but you get about
thirty five working about thirty two but
get about thirty five hundred thirty two
million about thirty five hundred about
thirty two billion about thirty five
hundred going once thirty two thinking
about thirty five hundred going twice
don't miss out this is absolutely
phenomenal you got Batman in his full
Cape going up the stairs you got some
freaky cat looking through the window
yeah right it's Chaser the cat right
that's what it looks like yeah yeah and
then you got something else happening up
on top it looks like there's uh I don't
know like a bunch of freaky stuff
happened up top right now I'm not sure
anyway I know you guys think it was like
a hallucination it is that's what it is
right like from that hallucination
person in Batman right scarecrow yeah
like the Scarecrow thank you see I don't
know all the character names
that was the second name for the
Scarecrow I just narrowly lost out there
you go there you go 32 feet to get about
3 500. 32 picking about 3500 about 32.35
I'm gonna buy 3250 about 3500 going once
32 but you get about 3 500 going twice
last call
I know the person on there is saying
just sell it I want it sell it sold 30
to 15 buyer number 100. lot 41 DC
Showcase 94. issue number four is Arkham
page 16 pencil art by Tim sale and Inked
by Jimmy pagliati so that's a pretty
great two for one that you're getting
here right there Jimmy Palmer audio
writer now but back in the day I worked
at the mom Daredevil he was already 41.
several images of two-faced and some
small images of scarecrow amygdala and
the Mad Hatter two thousand but 2200
2300 2200 by 2300 about 23.23 you know
about 22.23 2200 to my twenty three
hundred twenty three hundred twenty two
hundred by twenty three hundred twenty
two hundred about twenty three hundred
twenty three hundred twenty two hundred
about twenty three hundred twenty two
hundred about twenty three hundred
twenty three hundred twenty four hundred
twenty four hundred twenty four hundred
twenty four hundred twenty five hundred
twenty five hundred twenty five hundred
I think you could think you should 2500
by 2600 20 600 2600 2600 2600 2600 2600
2700 2700 2700 twenty seven hundred
twenty seven hundred twenty seven
hundred twenty seven hundred twenty
eight hundred twenty eight hundred
twenty eight hundred twenty eight
hundred twenty eight hundred twenty
seven hundred by twenty eight hundred
twenty eight hundred come on back now
twenty eight hundred twenty eight
hundred twenty eight hundred hundred
dollars more Twenty Eight twenty nine
hundred twenty nine hundred twenty nine
hundred twenty nine hundred three
thousand dollars three thousand dollars
three times thirty two fifty thirty two
fifty thirty two fifty thirty two fifty
Thirty talking about thirty two fifty
three talking about thirty two fifty are
you talking about thirty two fifty are
you talking about thirty two big enough
about thirty two big number three
knocking about thirty two fifty going
once
three talking about thirty two fifty
going twice
thirty five hundred thirty five we're
gonna buy thirty five thirty two we get
about thirty five hundred thirty two
making about thirty five hundred thirty
two weeks about thirty five hundred
thirty two minutes about thirty five I
think about thirty two picking about
thirty five hundred going once don't
miss out it's only two hundred and fifty
dollars more 3250 about thirty five
hundred going twice last call
sold for thirty two hundred and fifty
dollars buyer number 100 buyer number
one hundred what forty two Batman
Detective Comics 748 original art from
Dave Johnson just another great artist
Johnson Batman yeah you've only got all
the good ones includes one image Batman
we have a C4 bomb and we have an
explosion that's a cover it was a cover
to detective beautiful piece let's see
what that was oh yeah I'm sorry I missed
that part yeah this is the cover Dave
Johnson he did all those great covers
for 100 bullets and uh Punisher
cool 808 and a quarter eight and a half
900.995
975 a thousand dollars
1100 1200. thirteen hundred thirteen
hundred thirteen hundred thirteen
hundred about thirteen hundred about
thirteen hundred by twelve hundred about
thirteen hundred thirteen hundred
thirteen hundred about fourteen hundred
fourteen hundred fourteen hundred hurt
about fourteen hundred about fifteen
hundred fifteen hundred fifteen hundred
fourteen hundred by fifteen hundred
fourteen hundred about fifteen hundred
fifteen hundred sixteen hundred sixteen
hundred sixteen hundred fifteen hundred
by sixteen hundred by Seventeen hundred
Seventeen hundred Seventeen hundred
Seventeen hundred thirteen hundred nine
seventeen hundred sixteen hundred by
Seventeen hundred thirteen hundred by
Seventeen hundred fifteen hundred by
Seventeen hundred it's just cover art
ladies and gentlemen eighteen hundred
eighteen hundred eighteen hundred
Seventeen hundred and eighteen hundred
thirteen hundred eighteen hundred
Nineteen Hundred Nineteen Hundred
Nineteen Hundred eighteen hundred
Nineteen Hundred eighteen hundred over
Nineteen Hundred eighteen hundred about
Nineteen Hundred two thousand dollars
two
going what
Nineteen Hundred by two thousand dollars
going twice don't miss out it's only a
hundred dollar more bid guy don't miss
out for a hundred dollars two thousand
dollar bid Nineteen Hundred by two
thousand dollars going twice last call
nineteen hundred dollars higher number
200 lot 43 Batman shadow of the bat
issue three page eight artist Norm
brayford Norm rifogle page
signed by the artist multiple images of
Batman and Nightwing it's got disco
Nightwing in that outfit oh with the
chest yes the chest uh we lost Norm
rifle fairly recently it was one of my
favorite Batman artists of all time can
you do Batman with expressive eyes most
people draw the triangles he made them
circles he would use them like the way
that you would draw eyeballs or or a
brow expression he was a an absolute
treasure
um and this page is gorgeous
nine and a quarter or 900 but nine and a
quarter nine and a quarter nine and a
half now I'm thinking about
just the AC for like 10 minutes to drink
it down two degrees in here fourteen
hundred fifteen hundred thank you hun
fifteen hundred about fifteen hundred
fourteen hundred fifteen hundred I know
you girls are gonna freeze but I I just
I just need the air conditioning just
just for 10 minutes to cool me off here
1400 by 1500. fifteen hundred fifteen
hundred fourteen hundred fifteen hundred
fourteen hundred about fifteen hundred
about fifteen hundred about fourteen
hundred about fifteen hundred about
fourteen hundred about fifteen hundred
going what I mean Darren and Kevin look
like they're sweating over there too I
know I'm sweating what's 800 about 1500
going once this is just my Italian skin
yeah
what do you have them in 1500 going
twice last call
sold 1400 entire number uh 200 buyer
number 200. lot 44. Batman issue 476
page three again our Norm bryfogle
signed by him multiple images of Batman
and Vicky Vale also include Batman
revealing his identity to Vicky in a
dream and kissing her in a dream and
this was the final issue of Norm
Bradfield was run as a regular Batman
artist
um look at that so you get him taking
his cowl who was played by Kim bathroom
movies and the character that goes deep
in DC Comics
um so you got a normal Batman and you
get a normal Bruce Wayne as well this is
great 1700 and 1800 1700 and 1800 1800
about 1700 by 1800 1800 1700 and 1800
1700 1800 1700 1800 1800 about 179 1800
1700 with 1800 1700 1800s
going once eighteen hundred and nineteen
hundred dollars going twice last call
sold eighteen hundred dollars buyer
number uh 200 buyer number two hundred
lot 45 Mage the hero discovered issue
six page 19 art of course by Matt Wagner
signed by him includes images of Kevin
Sean and mirth now we've seen a lot of
Matt Wagner action thus far with those
Grendel Prime pages this is classic
Wagner and look at this man you're
talking about issue six of Mage a
seminal classic in the world of comic
book uh storytelling uh page 19 with the
Kevin character Sean and mirth this was
a retelling of the Arthurian Legend with
Kevin Matchstick uh standing in for King
Arthur and mirth was his Merlin so this
is a gorgeous piece of comic book
history right here two thousand twenty
one hundred twenty two hundred twenty
three hundred twenty three hundred about
twenty three hundred by twenty two about
twenty three hundred twenty two hundred
about twenty three hundred twenty two
hundred about twenty three hundred
twenty two hundred about twenty three
hundred about twenty three hundred about
twenty two hundred by twenty three
twenty four hundred twenty four hundred
twenty five hundred twenty five hundred
twenty four hundred about twenty five
hundred twenty four hundred about twenty
five hundred twenty five hundred twenty
four hundred about twenty five hundred
twenty four hundred about twenty five
hundred twenty five hundred twenty four
hundred about twenty five hundred about
twenty five hundred about twenty four
good about twenty five hundred twenty
five hundred twenty four hundred about
twenty five hundred twenty four hundred
about twenty five hundred going once
twenty four hundred about twenty five
hundred dollars going twice last call
sold twenty four hundred dollars
supplier number two hundred buyer number
two hundred lot forty six Superman
volume two issue 87 page eleven pens
sold by Stuart imminent and Inked by Joe
Rubinstein we have images of Lois Lane
Clark Kent and Superman take a look at
this artwork Stuart did a gorgeous
Superman and Clark Kent and look at his
lowest um Beautiful Lord I bought this
page just because I was such a fan of uh
Stewart's rendition of Superman did you
get it directly from Stuart or I think I
bought it from a dealer exactly from
Stewart it's not just yet yeah exactly
all right here we go 275 now 300 three
and a quarter three and a quarter gonna
buy three and according to about three
twenty [__] about three hundred
number three twenty four by three twenty
pocket about 350. we're thinking about
three picking about three making about
three making about three twenty pocket
about three fifty three fifty three
seventy five three seventy five three
seventy pocket about three seventy
pocket about three big enough three
seventy pocket about three five good
number three seventy five yeah four
hundred four hundred four hundred four
hundred about three somebody pocket
about four hundred about four hundred by
three seventy pocket about four hundred
three pocket about four hundred three
somebody talking about four hundred
about four hundred about three somebody
pocket about four hundred by three
somebody pocket about four hundred three
somebody pocket about 400 about 400 by
three seven pocket about four hundred by
three seventy five bit four hundred
going once
sounds cheap guys 375 bid 400 going
twice last call nice buy Here sold 355
buyer number uh 100 buyer number 200
rather a lot 47 Superman volume two
issue 88 page four pencil by Stuart
Eminem and Inked by Joe Wolfenstein
whose images of Superman and Lois Lane
there's a background stat by Lois's head
another chance of distort Eminem Page
look at that in the Superman and keeping
up Lois and flying with her
is that what I'm seeing that's what it
looks like yeah yeah classic rendition
of uh Superman flying with Lois in his
arms very thinking about a hell of a
valentine yeah a gift for anybody who
likes romance even if you don't like
Comics look at that Lois and Clark
together again there you go 350 375 370
pocket about 400. 375 about 400 about
400 about 400 about 375 about 400.
375400 about 404 and a quarter four and
a quarter four and a quarter four
hundred about four twenty five we're
talking about 425. we're talking about
420 pocket about 400 about four twenty
pocket about 400 20 pocket about 450.
we're picking about 454.75. what
somebody talking about four pick it up
four somebody pocket about four pick it
up four somebody pocket about four pick
it up four seventy five four words
five hundred four somebody [__] up a
500.50
[__] about 500. of course everybody
[__] about
500.4 75 and 500 going once watch
another 25 more dollars or somebody
pocket about 500 going twice last call
yeah
so 450 dollars player number uh 200
buyer number 200. excellent deal
48 original comic book art from Beastie
and vertigo Sandman issue 60 page four
penciled by Mark Hempel and Inc by
Disraeli signed by Mark Hempel we have
multiple images of Lucifer and remyel uh
I mean man art just it never ever shows
up yeah this is rare man yeah we got a
few Sandman Pages coming up yeah
and bought Pages back in the day and
they've been sitting in this binder so
this is the first time some of these are
seeing the light of day since I
purchased it yeah I actively like I've
been looking for Sandman art for years
it just never ever ever turns up yeah we
got some kindly one Pages coming up as
well but yeah this is a rare piece of
comic book artwork your kids get
yourself a piece of sand man 25 pocket
about 2600 25 I could buy 2600 2500 by
26 I could do about 26 I could have
about 20 pocket about 2600 25 I'm gonna
buy 2600 about 2600 by
2500 going once 2500 about 2600 going
twice now seven twenty seven hundred
twenty seven hundred twenty seven
hundred what do you think about 2700
2700 2600 about 2700 2600 by 2700 2600
by 2700 going once 2600 gonna buy twenty
seven hundred dollars going twice last
call
another Sandman page issue 64 page 12.
penciled and Inked by Teddy Christensen
signed by him as well includes images of
the Corinthian and Matthew The Raven
sixteen hundred Seventeen hundred
sixteen hundred and Seventeen hundred
Seventeen hundred eighteen hundred
eighteen hundred Nineteen Hundred
Nineteen Hundred Nineteen Hundred
eighteen hundred by Nineteen Hundred
eighteen hundred about Nineteen Hundred
by two thousand now we're gonna buy two
thousand Nineteen Hundred about two
thousand dollars twenty one hundred
twenty one hundred twenty one hundred
two thousand about twenty one hundred
about two thousand about twenty one
hundred twenty one hundred two thousand
by Twenty One Hundred I think you could
I think it should Twenty One Hundred two
thousand by Twenty One Hundred about two
thousand because about twenty one
hundred yep twenty two hundred twenty
two hundred by twenty two hundred twenty
one hundred by twenty two hundred twenty
one hundred about twenty two hundred
twenty one hundred about twenty two
hundred by twenty two hundred about
twenty one hundred by twenty two hundred
going once Twenty One Hundred about
twenty two hundred hours going twice
last call
sold twenty one hundred dollars prior
number one hundred two hundred lot fifty
another Sandman page into sixty four
page sixteen penciled and Inc by Teddy
Christensen signed by him includes an
image of Morpheus AKA a dream the furies
different phones the hippogriff and the
how's that pronounced Vern vervin
there you go once again from the Conley
ones storyline it was shortly before the
the furies destroy I guess what was it
the dragon uh yeah well they I mean they
just got the Griffin yeah they just got
the Griffin yeah
2000 by 2100 2100 2100 20 100 2200 about
2300 2300 2300 2300 2300 2400 2400 2400
2400 2400
2400.25
2600 2600 2600 2600 2600 2600 2600 2700
2700 2700 2700 2700 I think you could
think you should twenty seven hundred
twenty seven hundred twenty seven
hundred twenty second one twenty seven
hundred by twenty seven by twenty six
hundred by twenty seven hundred wait six
hundred by twenty seven hundred twenty
six hundred about twenty seven hundred
going once don't miss it for a hundred
bucks 2600 about 2700 going twice last
call
we have the Corinthian Matthew The Raven
and more field this one
three great characters from the sand
menu it was all created of course by the
the wonderful Neil Gaiman
um as drawn by Teddy Christensen look at
that beautiful
2200 by 2300 about 2300 2400 about 2400
2400 2400 2300 about 2400 2300 about
2400 23 talking about twenty four
hundred twenty three hundred about
twenty four get about twenty four
twenty four hundred twenty three hundred
working about twenty five hundred twenty
five hundred twenty five hundred about
twenty six hundred twenty six hundred
twenty five hundred about twenty six
hundred twenty five hundred by twenty
six hundred twenty five hundred by
twenty six hundred twenty five hundred
about twenty six hundred by twenty six
hundred by twenty seven hundred twenty
seven hundred twenty seven hundred
twenty seven hundred what do you think
about twenty seven hundred twenty six
hundred twenty twenty eight hundred
twenty eight hundred twenty eight
hundred twenty eight hundred twenty
eight hundred twenty eight hundred
twenty seven hundred by twenty eight
hundred twenty seven hundred about
twenty eight hundred twenty seven
hundred by twenty eight hundred going
once don't miss out for a hundred
dollars twenty seven hundred by Twenty
eight hundred dollars going twice last
call
so 2 700 hours higher number 200 buyer
number two hundred lot 52. Sandman
issues 64 page 24. penciled an Inked by
Teddy Christensen signed by him as well
with Morpheus we have Kane and Abel we
have Lucy and the librarian Rose Walker
and Murph pumpkin head all in this one
remember pumpkin had a character that I
uh wound up I grew up to voice in the uh
Sandman audible podcast series really
yeah I play Merv oh that's cool that's
awesome wild but yeah there he is it's a
big uh page because uh it's where they
uh funeral they bury their friend
there's more up top saying [__] but then
um I I think it's uh I think this is the
last pay what page is it 24 shows yeah
back when Comics were 24 pages yes
before they dropped to 22 then before
they dropped to 20.
forty five hundred eight forty seven
fifty I'm sorry forty five [__] about
47 I picked it about 47 I figured about
45 [__] about 47.50 45
come on come on back down about five
thousand dollars five thousand dollars
five thousand dollars fifty two fifty
fifty two fifty fifty two fifty fifty
two fifty fifty two fifty five I'm
talking about fifty two big number five
hacking about fifty two fifty five
packing about fifty two bit about five I
get about 52 bit about five I get about
fifty two bit about five I get about
fifty two fifty going once I would
assume that oh 52 but they they cut the
pages down to cost production could you
probably paid you less if you made less
Pages yeah and cheaper production that's
what happened eventually come the
carnival Guardian shranked to the point
where comic book publishers were like if
we take them down to 20 we're gonna save
a little bit of money right yeah wow
5500 been 57.50 5500 by 57 58 about 55
[__] about fifty Seven fifty fifty
five hiking about fifty Seven fifty
fifty five [__] about fifty Seven
figures about fifty Seven fifteen about
six thousand dollars six thousand
dollars six
sixty two fifty going once six thousand
gonna buy sixty two fifty going twice
last call he came all this way what's
another two hundred and fifty dollars
last call
so over six thousand dollars higher
number 100 buyer number one hundred lot
53 Sandman issue 69 page 16 art by Mark
Hempel and signed by him includes an
image of Lucifer Morningstar and mazakin
oh two of the stars of the Lucifer TV
show that's going on forever
um yeah look at him right there it's a
gorgeous piece by Mark Hempel all right
responsible for I Gregory back in the
day right I think yeah absolutely 29
hugging about three thousand dollars
bloody knocking about three talking
about three talking about three times
thank you thirty two fifty thirty two
fifty thirty two picking about 32 make
it about three thousand about 32 make it
about thirty two fifty thirty two fifty
are you talking about 32 picking about
three talking about 32 picking about 32
50 get about 32.50 I got a three
thousand dollar bid with 32.50 what are
you talking about 32.50 what are you
talking about 32.50 what are you talking
about 32 picking up about 35 we're gonna
buy 37.50 37.50 37.50 what are you
talking about thirty seven fifty thirty
two if you get about thirty five hundred
thirty five hundred by thirty seven
fifty there we go 37 37.50 I almost
forgot where I was 25 [__] about
37.50 35
37.50 35 [__] about 37.50 going once
3537.50 going twice last call
sold thirty five hundred dollars by her
number 100 buyer number one hundred lot
54. Kevin Smith's Green Arrow issue
number five pages 21 and 22 Arts by Phil
Hester we have a full splash page of
etrigan Green Arrow and Batman
professionally framed and matted that's
right this comes frame to Matt this hung
in my house for the longest time like 10
15 years outside of my office
um gorgeous uh couple pages from the
book look at that splash page a veteran
just beating ass with Batman and Green
Arrow down below
um gorgeous Pages kids
um especially if you're into the work of
uh Phil Hester and Andy Parks which I
have been uh because I did this book
with them I've done
um the quick stops book with them and
stuff they're two of my favorite artists
but uh this piece is uh framed as well
man so you can hang it right the [__] up
in your house as well tell people this
used to hang in silent Bill's house like
who's that you're like never mind
I got 2 800 but 2900 29 about 2900 by 28
about 2900 2900 2900 2800 by 2900 2800
by 29 gonna buy three thousand dollars
three thousand dollars thirty two fifty
thirty two fifty thirty two fifty three
thousand now we're gonna buy 3250
about thirty two fifty thirty two fifty
three thinking about 32 thinking about
32 make it about three thousand about
thirty two fifteen about thirty two
fifty three talking about 32.50 what are
you talking about 32.50 what are you
talking about 32 picking about thirty
five hundred thirty five hundred thirty
five hundred
going once don't miss out 35 talking
about 37.50 going twice last call
sold 3 500 buyer number buyer number uh
100 buyer number one hundred
lot 55. this is the cover art for the
trade paperback of Mage book two from
1985 art by Matt Wagner signed by him
this was the front and the back covers
it was like uh wrap around competition
for the trade paperback back in 1985.
this is glorious painting man it's
gorgeous as [__] yes yeah framed as [__]
as well this is cool look at that
fantastic piece so this is from a
paperback uh book is that the deal yeah
so they issued a comic book they did
Comics but then they issued it as one
big story in a trade paperback and this
was one of the covers they did multiple
volumes
all right here we go I got 6 500 but 67
50 67 57 000 by 72.50 72 fifty seventy
five hundred seventy seven fifty Seven
seventy fifty eight thousand eighty two
fifty eighty two fifty eighty five
hundred eighty five hundred eighty five
hundred eighty five hundred eighty seven
fifty eighty seven fifty eighty seven
fifty nine thousand dollars nine talking
about ninety two fifty ninety two fifty
ninety five hundred ninety five hundred
ninety seven fifty ninety seven fifty
ninety seven fifty get about ten
thousand dollars they're talking about
10 seconds of eleven thousand eleven
thousand they're talking about eleven
talking about twelve thousand dollars
twelve thousand I'm gonna buy thirteen
thousand thirteen thousand thirteen
thousand fourteen thousand fourteen
thousand fourteen get about 14 talking
about fifteen thousand dollars fifteen
thousand fifteen thousand fifteen
thousand sixteen thousand dollars
sixteen thousand sixteen thousand don't
miss out now sixteen thousand dollars
sixteen thousand sixteen not gonna buy
sixteen not gonna buy sixteen not gonna
buy 16 thinking about 15 thinking about
sixteen I got fifteen thousand but
sixteen thousand dollars I got fifteen
thousand dollars there but sixteen
thousand fifteen talking about sixteen
thousand going once you came all this
way very rare you're not gonna find
another one like it ladies and gentlemen
if this is what if you're the under
bidder I'm telling you now you're gonna
say you know what I should have went one
more time what's another thousand
dollars for something you're never gonna
see again I'm gonna tell you right now
the person buying it is never going to
sell it probably until I don't know 20
years from now 30 years from now let's
go seventeen thousand dollars hit it
again seventeen thousand seventeen
thousand he's out now seventeen thousand
seventeen thousand eighteen thousand
eighteen thousand eighteen thousand
eighteen thousand have a ticket about
eighteen giveaway ticket number 18 17 18
000.15 18 000 17
made eighteen thousand dollars going
once
seventeen thousand bit eighteen thousand
dollars going twice last call
sold seventeen thousand dollars buyer
number one six five on the phone one six
five congratulations you'll enjoy it's
beautiful peace
Lot number 56 this is a Frank Miller
Daredevil page issue 161 page 22 pencils
by Frank Miller anchor Klaus Johnson
includes stats multiple images of
Daredevil and Bullseye in a fight scene
black widow's name is mentioned this is
I've never seen a Frank Miller piece in
person it's a phenomenal piece man and
it's Frank Miller back when he was
cutting his teeth on Daredevil before he
jumped into the world of Batman uh it's
Daredevil and Bullseye fighting in Frank
Miller style Inked by the inimitable
cloth uh class Janssen look at this how
often look at look at the standard word
balloons man are so old yeah they've
turned gray you can still read the words
illegible but they went from white to
that brownish color what's great about
it so like you know when you look around
and look at the collection that one
stands out so like if you're walking
around and you're looking at everything
that one pops that's the one you know it
just pops out like wow you know it's
very rare that a Frank Miller piece
particularly an old Frank Miller piece
comes up for auction I rarely ever see
Frank Miller's stuff there you go What's
it gonna bring guys I got 26 000 now bid
27.27 by 28 get him by 28 get him about
29.30
000 31 000 32 000 33 000 33 000 34 000
000 30 pocketed by thirty six pack of my
thirty seven thousand thirty seven
thousand thirty eight thousand thirty
eight thousand thirty nine thousand
forty thousand dollar forty one thousand
forty one thousand forty two thousand
forty three thousand forty three zero
forty three you get about forty four
thousand forty five thousand forty five
thousand forty six thousand forty six
knocking about forty seven thousand
forty seven about forty eight forty
eight above 49 49 about fifty thousand
dollars fifty talking about fifty two
fifty fifty two fifty fifty five
thousand fifty five thousand fifty Seven
fifty fifty Seven fifty sixty thousand
dollars sixty thousand dollars sixty
thousand dollars he came all this way
sixty thousand sixty two fifty sixty two
fifty sixty two fifty sixty five hundred
sixty five thousand right sixty five
thousand sixty five thousand sixty five
thousand I think you could think you
should you came all this way sixty five
thousand dollars sixty [__] about
sixty five sixty two forget about sixty
five thousand fifty two minutes gonna
buy sixty five thousand fifty two
minutes about sixty five thousand six
two but you can buy sixty five not gonna
buy sixty five not gonna buy sixty five
thousand come on ladies a job sixty five
sixty seven fifty sixty seven fifty
seventy thousand dollars seventy
thousand dollars seventy thousand
dollars seventy thousand dollars seventy
thousand dollars it should be in a
museum ladies and gentlemen come on now
seventy thousand dollars seventy
thousand by seventy talking about
seventy talking about seventy thousand
sixty seven pretty good about seventy
thousand dollars sixty seven thousand
five hundred bit seventy thousand
dollars sixty seven fifty eight about
seven thousand dollars seventy thousand
dollars don't miss out ladies and
gentlemen this is it you got sixty seven
thousand five hundred bid bid seventy
there's no reserves this is it it is
absolutely going to sell these owners no
reserves in this auction it's here it's
selling let's go and you're gonna be
able to sell the certificate for twenty
bucks so you're gonna get that back real
quick absolutely
67 570
000 going once
you are gonna regret it if you popped
already this High what's another twenty
five hundred dollars and you'll be known
that you're the one who bought it 67.50
000 going twice last call
sold 67 500 buyer number 100 buyer
number one hundred
congratulations
lot
57. I was sitting in my I couldn't
believe it I did I actually paid 75
grand for it so you made out like a bit
no not at all not at all I assure you
there you go
lot 57 original comic book cover art
it's a daredevil issue 8 from the Marvel
Knights Series this was also the cover
to the Marvel Knights Omnibus so you
know that they appreciated it pencils by
Joe quesada Inked by Jimmy palmiati
double signed by the artist then you get
an image of Daredevil and Spider-Man and
this is professionally framed and matted
so it's all ready to hang I got 15
000 bit 16 15 pocket about 16.16 by
seventeen thousand seventeen thousand
eighteen thousand eighteen thousand
eighteen thousand Seventeen talking
about 18 talking about 18 talking about
18 talking about nineteen thousand
dollars nineteen thousand dollars 19 19
000 now we're gonna buy twenty thousand
dollars twenty thousand dollars what are
you talking about 20 talking about 20
talking about 20 talking about nineteen
thousand about twenty thousand look at
about twenty one twenty one thousand
twenty one thousand twenty one thousand
twenty one twenty one second about
twenty one second about twenty thousand
about twenty one thousand twenty one
good about twenty one thousand about
twenty one talking about twenty one
thousand 21 I got a 20 000 bid bid 21.
what do you want to get my Twenty One
what's great about this piece is the
action that's going in there if you're
looking at that I guess it's a rope or
something going around like that this is
It's Daredevil's billy club that he's
throwing in Spider-Man's web but the
detail on the building and on the and on
the bridge
um that's the bridge of course in comics
where green uh Goblin through Gwen Stacy
off and she snapped her neck okay that's
why Joe quesada wanted spoilers kids
spoilers that's why Joe quasada wanted
to set that scene on top of that bridge
but um you got two iconic portraits of
characters drawn by Joe quesada
Daredevil who he redefined with this run
that we did uh and a classic uh
Spider-Man it's a fantastic cover that
hung in my house outside my office for
the better part of 15 years every day I
saw that artwork now you could see it
every day there you go 22 000 about 23
22 you get about 23 000 get about 23 22
give me my 23. what did you thinking
about 23 000 23 000 22 talking about
twenty three thousand twenty two by
twenty three targeted by twenty three
good about twenty four thousand twenty
four thousand twenty four good about
twenty four get about 24 get about
twenty three get about twenty four
thousand twenty four thousand twenty
three about twenty four thousand what
are you talking about twenty four
thousand what are you thinking about
twenty four thousand get about twenty
four get about twenty taken about twenty
four thousand going once once again
something you'll never see and whoever's
gonna buy it they're not gonna resell it
it's going in their collection this is
it this is your opportunity invest this
is the way to go guys what are you
thinking about twenty four thousand what
are you thinking about twenty four
thousand dollars going once twenty three
get about twenty four thousand dollars
going twice last call
sold twenty three thousand dollars buyer
number two hundred buyer number two
hundred congratulations buyer well it's
Exquisite piece plot Number 58 Saga the
Swamp Thing original comic book art
issue number 21 page twenty this is the
anatomy Lesson by Alan Moore pencils by
Steven bazette Inked by John toddle Ben
and this is by far
I guess the most important Swamp Thing
issue I guess maybe you could say the
House of Secrets where it first appears
is the most important and then the
second most is when Alan Moore changes
everything not just of uh this may be
one of the 10 most important Comics ever
published yeah Alan Moore took a
character like the Swamp Thing
um and redefined it made it an
intelligent read a literary read with
this issue the anatomy lesson one of the
greatest comic books ever written uh
Bessette and total Ben who did like most
of the run with him uh particularly when
he came in and kind of took over because
this was a book that was already up and
running for a few issues when When Alan
Moore jumped in there but absolutely uh
one of my favorite comic books uh ever
written the Alan Moore Swamp Thing run
these pages are very tough to find I've
had this in my collection for the better
part of 20 years I bought it two decades
back and it was the prize of my
collection because I love this book so
much yeah yeah you're not going to find
much
Swamp Thing artwork from this era out
there in the world kids so enjoy and
from this specific issue where the Swamp
Thing finds out oh I'm not Alec Hall
Holland in the swamp I'm actually the
swamp I think yeah that was his secret
origin it became very scientific it went
from being you know comic book fun and
Goofy to like something like he was a
guy that was he blew up in the lab one
of the lake and came out for the Swamp
Thing but Alan Moore took it and made it
something far more scientific it was
when comic books started making that
turn Circa like what I want to say 86 or
something like that yeah right it became
far more literate yes and people you
know Alan Moore one of the first people
was like What if this [__] played like
in the real world to approach it that
way anyway back to you yeah thank you 97
50-bit 10 000 bit 11 but 12. well
talking about 12. 12 13 000 13 000 13
000 13 000. well talking about 13 months
I think about fourteen thousand hour 14
000 hours 1400 about fourteen about four
tickets
about fourteen thousand dollars we're
thinking about four to get about four to
get about fifteen thousand dollars
fifteen thousand fifteen thousand by
sixteen thousand sixteen thousand
fifteen thousand about sixteen thousand
fifteen's not gonna buy sixteen talking
about fifteen by sixteen talking about
sixteen fifteen thousand by sixteen
talking about fifteen by sixteen talking
about sixteen thousand fifteen thacking
about sixteen thousand seventeen
thousand seventeen thousand seventeen
thousand eighteen thousand eighteen
thousand Seventeen talking about
eighteen talking to eighteen pocket of
eighteen thousand what's another bid
eighteen thousand dollars fifteen get
about eighteen eleven thinking about
eighteen of eighteen eighteen hundred
eighteen times eighteen by Seventeen
about eighteen thousand dollars going
once on the Swamp Thing nineteen
thousand dollars come on back now twenty
thousand dollars let's go let me get
number twenty one twenty one twenty get
about twenty thousand dollars I can't
talk about twenty thousand dollars I
thinking about twenty I thinking about
twenty thousand about twenty thousand
twenty thousand dollars I take it about
twenty thousand by Twenty Thousand
nineteen about twenty thousand dollars I
think about twenty thousand hours going
once twenty one thousand twenty one
twenty two twenty two twenty two I think
you could think you should let's go
twenty two what are you working about
twenty two all right welcome to my 22
gigabyte 22 gigabyte 22 000. 21 I'm
talking about twenty two thousand twenty
one talking about twenty two target
about twenty one about twenty two
thousand dollars going once yep twenty
three thousand dollars twenty three
twenty four twenty four get about twenty
four what are you thinking about twenty
four get about twenty five thousand
twenty five thousand twenty five
thousand twenty five thousand what if I
get about twenty five twenty [__]
about twenty pocket about twenty four
good about twenty five thousand what are
you talking about twenty five thousand
what a [__] about twenty five twenty
six thousand twenty six thousand twenty
six thousand what are you thinking about
twenty thinking about twenty getting
about twenty seven thousand dollars
twenty seven thousand twenty seven
thousand twenty seven by twenty seven by
Twenty second number twenty seven
thousand what do you thinking about
twenty seven
don't miss out another thousand bucks
What's it gonna bring let's go what are
you thinking about twenty seven thousand
going twice last call
sold for 26 000 congratulations buyer
number 200 buyer number 200. that he's
gonna make somebody very happy well done
buddy yeah pretty amazing lot 59 JLA
original comic art issue two page 19
pencils by Howard Porter Acres John Dell
signed by Howard Porter we have images
of the Batman bat plane and a mortal
again this is professionally framed and
matted what I love about uh this page is
number two of the uh JLA redo with Grant
Morrison so it's an early page Howard
Porter uh defined this group uh I loved
his artwork on the JLA run that he did
with graham Morrison uh and this is a
wonderful page of Batman going one on
one uh in the Batwing uh against the bad
guys in this case a mortal beautiful
piece 1800 number 1900 1800 over 1900
1900 of 1800 number 1900 1900 of 1800
out of a 1900 it excuse me 1800 about
1900 1800 by 1900 about 1900 1800 by
1900 1800 to 1900 1900 1900 1800 1900
going once 1800 mid 1900 hours going
twice last call
sold oh no
hold on that sounded like they got it in
time they did get in in time 1900 bid
two thousand dollars two thousand
dollars yeah no it didn't close two
thousand dollars two thousand dollars I
know you're really mad at me right now
but it didn't close out two thousand
dollars come on back down 1900 get about
two thousand dollars 1900 about you
talking about you talking about 1900 by
two thousand dollars nineteen I'm gonna
buy two thousand dollars Nineteen
Hundred by two thousand dollars going
once Nineteen Hundred about two thousand
dollars going twice last call
this is why you can't wait for the last
minute the bid ladies and gentlemen
because stuff like that happens and then
you know everyone gets on a tizzy but
the bottom line is if it doesn't proceed
forward we continue to go on you gotta
remember we're on Sixth platform I'm
watching six computer screens in front
of me so if you think my auctioneering
skills are good I'm actually watching
six screens here as well I know you're
like Batman himself yeah all those
monitors I see you oh there you go I
appreciate that I only want the
Batmobile that's what I wish
you and me yeah right 19 I'll get about
2000 the closest thing that I would have
to go to Great Adventure and get the one
that they had in the show there right
yeah exactly next you're talking about
two thousand hey see I talked long
enough thank you you're talking about
2100 2100 no one of them have it now
2100 I got a two thousand dollar bid bid
2100. who's talking about 2100 who's
talking about 2100 number two thousand
dollar 2100 by 2200 2200 2200 2200 2100
about 2200 2100 about 2200 2100 about
2200 going once 2100 about 2200 going
twice last call oh
sold 2100 buyer number 100 buyer number
one hundred thank you both forbidding
it's a beautiful piece lot 60 Green
Arrow original comic art double splash
page for issue number three
uh page 20 and 21 Arts by Phil Hester
includes the back Black Manta and green
arrow professionally framed and matted
all ready to hang yeah I love these
pages so much that I had them uh framed
uh Mount uh matted and framed look at
that there's a lot of action going on
there yeah it's Black Manta showing up
in uh Star City with uh the manta ray
his ship calling out Oliver Queen's uh
green arrow for a fight that's cool yeah
it's a beautiful piece if you're a fan
of black manta's I always have been now
they do them in the movies he was pretty
amazing in Aquaman's in that trailer for
Aquaman too but this is uh Black Manta
and Oliver Queen Green Arrow facing off
in a double page spread eight and a
quarter eight and a half 8.75 900 no I'm
talking about 900 over 900.9 and a
quarter nine a quarter nine and a half
nine and a half nine and a half
thousand dollars thousand dollars
thousand dollar come on nine somebody
talking about that happens
about thirteen hundred thirteen hundred
thirteen hundred by Thirteen hundred
well if I get about thirteen hundred
fourteen hundred fourteen hundred
fifteen hundred fifteen hundred fifteen
hundred fifteen hundred fifteen hundred
fifteen hundred fifteen hundred fourteen
hundred about fifteen hundred what do
you think about 1500 1400 1500 about
1500 about 1400 about 1500 1400 1500
sounds reasonable for it guys you got
double page here twenty and twenty one
mounted and ready to go all framed up
Fantastic action scene let's go 1600 and
1700 going once sixteen hundred
Seventeen hundred going twice last call
sold sixteen hundred dollars buyer
number one hundred two Meyer number one
hundred Lot number 61 Daredevil original
comic book art issue number five page
four this is from the Marvel Knights
series pencil by Joe quesada and by
Jimmy palmiotti signed by Kevin Jimmy
and Joe we have images of Daredevil and
Bullseye uh this is one of the things
I'm most proud of ever having been
involved in in any media uh the
Daredevil storyline that I did with the
great Joe Casada and the great Jimmy
palmiati
um look at this page put that page up
oh come on yeah man that's really nice
come on you can you not without even
touching it that's so good
it's fantastic and look at his rendition
of Bullseye and it's got all the
lettering all over it as well I remember
when they were giving me pages when you
know at the end of The Run of a book you
can ask to buy Pages sometimes the
artists give you Pages as well but I
bought a lot of pages but um you can ask
specifically to have the dialogue stated
on with the word balloons and natural
lab did because my contribution to the
book is the words right so you're
getting not just the images here kids
but you're getting the story and the
dialogue as well that's cool yeah I got
52.50 bit 5500 5500 about 55 I could
about 5500 about 5750 57 50 57 50 57 50
about six thousand dollars six thousand
dollars six thousand dollars six
thousand by sixty two fifty sixty two
fifty sixty two fifty sixty five hundred
sixty five hundred sixty five hundred
sixty seven fifty sixty seven fifty
sixty seven five seven targeted by
seventy two fifty seventy two fifty
seventy five hundred seventy five
hundred seventy five hundred seventy
seven fifty 77.50 eight thousand dollars
eight thousand dollars eight thousand
eighty two fifty eighty two fifty eighty
two fifty eighty two fifty eighty two
fifty eighty two fifty eighty two fifty
eight thousand eighty two fifty eight
thousand eighty two fifty eighty two
fifty eight thousand eighty two fifty
eighty five hundred eighty five hundred
eighty seven fifty eighty seven fifty
eighty five hundred by eighty seven
fifty eighty five hundred about eighty
seven five eighty seven about nine
thousand dollars nine thousand dollars
ninety two fifty ninety two fifty ninety
two fifty ninety two fifty ninety two
fifty nothing about ninety two pretty
good number ninety two point ninety two
fifty nine attacking number ninety two
but he came all this way come on do it
again ninety two fifty ninety two fifty
nine talking about ninety two pretty
good about nine pocket about ninety two
pretty ninety two fifty going once like
you heard very rare he asked him to put
the stats in there with the writing and
everything else something you don't see
every day guys this is really really
nice hit it again nine thousand
going twice last call
sold nine thousand dollars by your
number one uh 200 buyer number two
hundred thank you all for bidding lot 62
original comic book cover art Daredevil
issue number seven Marvel Night series
pencils by Joe quesada Inc by Jimmy
palmiati signed Again by Kevin Jimmy and
Joe we have a nice large image of
Mysterio here and it is professionally
framed and matted look at that that was
the cover to issue seven
um what a great idea Casada had to draw
Mysterio and have a daredevil trapped
inside the bubble naturally the comic
book cover uh to any the comic book
artwork cover uh doesn't show you what's
going on in the book it's a teaser right
oh and sometimes the hype image this
obviously doesn't happen in the story
but it was such a striking compelling
image that no doubt had helped us sell
the hell out of the book made a gorgeous
piece that hung outside my office for
the better part of 15 years man I might
have to get in on the bidding on this
because I love love this piece I really
do I'm sitting here looking at going
like why am I letting this go but anyway
over to you Joe let's see what kind of
magic we can make six thousand sixty two
fifty sixty five hundred sixty seven
fifty seven thousand seventy two fifty
seventy five hundred seventy seven fifty
eight thousand eighty two fifty eighty
five hundred eighty seven fifty eighty
seven pick it up by 87 I think about
eighty five hundred by eighty seven
fifty eighty five eighty seven fifty
number nine thousand dollars nice
talking about ninety two fifty ninety
two fifty ninety two fifty ninety five
hundred get about 97.50 97 we get about
ten thousand eleven thousand I've been
talking about twelve thousand about
thirteen thousand thirteen thousand
thirteen talking about thirteen about
thirteen about thirteen he came all this
way well thinking about thirteen well
thinking about 13 talking about 13
talking about thirteen about thirteen
about twelve thousand about thirteen
thousand we're talking about thirteen
thousand well it's not good about
thirteen talking about 12 not gonna buy
thirteen thousand dollars going once
twelve thousand about thirteen thousand
dollars going twice now fourteen
thousand dollars fourteen thousand don't
lose out for another thousand dollars
fourteen thousand dollars thirteen
talking about fourteen thousand thirteen
talking about fourteen talking about
thirteen talking about fourteen talking
about fifteen thousand dollars fifteen
thousand fourteen talking about fifteen
thousand dollars going once sixteen
thousand dollars sixteen talking about
sixteen fifteen get about sixteen
they're thinking about six again
about sixteen thousand dollars going
once
you don't want to lose it for a thousand
dollars great image here 15's not gonna
buy sixteen thousand dollars going twice
last call
plus I don't want him to have uh
seller's remorse over there that's what
I don't want 60 now 17
000 17 by 70. I've been there and done
that and I've had buyers remorse and I
wished I've been more so I've had all
those all those combinations of things
17 pounding about eighteen thousand
dollars eighteen talking about 18 17 18
000 have a ticket about 18 about
seventeen thousand of eighteen thousand
dollars never taken about 18 kilometer
by eighteen thousand dollars going once
don't miss out 17 about eighteen
thousand dollars going twice last call
this is it you want it one more time
last call
sold 17
000 he does not have the seller's
remorse buyer number one hundred lot 63
original comic book art double splash
page Batman Legends of the Dark Knight
Madness Halloween special issue number
two pages two and three are by Tim sale
and we have images of the Mad Hatter
Batman Barbara Gordon and commissioner
Jim Gordon professionally framed and
matted all ready to hang in your bat
cave yeah this song at the secret stash
Jane saw Bob Stephen stash my comic book
store of 26 years in Red Bank New Jersey
for years and years and years let's get
an image up of that look at that it's
great Lord the great the late great Tim
sale uh did this double page spread and
um it's it's got Batman coming through a
glass window uh falling after uh the Mad
Hatter is scrumptious piece of art if I
do say so myself I didn't draw but but I
bought it because I loved it so much and
Tim sale artwork pretty tough to come by
these days
I got
67.57
000.72.50 72.50 7500 70 577 fifty Seven
seventy fifty eight thousand dollars
eighty two fifty eighty five hundred
eighty seven fifty nine thousand ninety
two fifty ninety five hundred ninety
five hundred ninety seven fifty ninety
seven fifty get about ten packet of
eleven thousand seven thousand and
talking about eleven seconds eleven
talking about ten thousand now we've
been eleven thousand eleven thousand
dollars eleven thousand twelve thousand
dollars twelve thousand dollars twelve
thousand dollars well talking about 1200
by 1200 eleven thousand about twelve
thousand dollars I've been talking about
twelve thousand now we're getting about
thirteen thousand dollars thirteen
thousand thirteen thousand well talking
about thirteen thousand well talking
about thirteen talking about thirteen
talking about twelve talking about
thirteen thousand dollars going once
you're gonna wish you bid one more time
come tomorrow once again this is a
fantastic piece guys double page super
framed up ready to go on the Dark Knight
Halloween special
thirteen thousand dollars now fourteen
thousand dollars come on back don't let
them have it fourteen thousand now
fifteen thousand dollars I could see it
on your wall every day you'll wake up
and you'll go get your cup of coffee and
you'll look at it ladies and gentlemen
come on fifteen thousand dollars we're
taking about fifteen thousand dollars
we're thinking about fifteen thousand an
hour we're thinking about 15 about
fourteen thousand but fifteen thousand
dollars going what's
14 talking about fifteen thousand
dollars going twice last call
sold fourteen thousand dollars buyer
number two hundred buyer number two
hundred and boy are we moving on to some
special stuff coming up here here we go
now we are into the Green Arrow original
cover portion of the sale so this is
issue number one cover art by Matt
Wagner professionally framed and matted
all these covers that you're gonna see
uh are from my green arrow run uh that I
did with uh Phil Hester and Andy Parks
and Matt Wagner was kind enough to do
our covers so I bought the Run of covers
these are fully painted stunning pieces
of artwork uh especially if you're into
any of the characters of the DC Universe
this particular image became a United
States postal stamp did it really it did
yeah wow I didn't know that yeah Matt
Wagner was honored by the United States
Post Office when they chose for Green
Arrow this very image so uh it's a
legendary piece it's an app actually a
legendary cover I've I've found over the
years I was always partial to it because
it was our book but it became something
of an iconic cover particularly
following the run of the arrow you know
on CW when the character became popular
more popular in the mainstream but look
at those Matt Wagner cover colors man is
stunning painting oh they are stunning
uh there it is I got 42.50 bit 4500 45
we're gonna buy 47 picking about 47
picking about five thousand dollars five
thousand dollars five thousand get about
500 about 5250 get about 5250 get about
fifty two fifty fifty two fifty get
about 5500 5500 5500 5500 I think you
could think you should 5500 55 get about
50 pocket about 57.50 57 50 57.50 57 get
about six thousand dollars six thousand
dollars six talking about sixty two
fifty sixty two bit again about sixty
five hundred sixty five hundred sixty
seven fifty sixty seven thinking about
seven thousand dollars seven thousand
dollars never been talking about seven
by seventy two fifty seventy two fifty
get about seventy five hundred seventy
five hundred seventy five hundred
seventy five hundred seventy five
hundred about seventy seven fifty
seventy seven fifty eight thousand
dollars eight thousand dollars eight
thousand dollars I think you should
eight thousand eight talking about
you're talking about he's talking about
seventy seven fifty eight thousand
dollars full cover art ladies and
gentlemen absolutely beautiful guys
these are all original I know somebody
asked me I put mixed media in there I
put mixed media in there because I
couldn't tell if it was pencil or or
paint or what the case was and I think
it might be a combination of all those
particular things but these are original
this is not a print this is no bologna
this is the real gig yeah this is how
Matt Wagner did it
775 in eight thousand dollars hey Tom
gonna be talking to me talking to my 770
000 I'm gonna be talking to me talking
about 70 75 and eight thousand dollars
going once seven thousand seven hundred
and fifty dollars but eight thousand
dollars going twice last call
sold seven thousand seven hundred and
fifty dollars buyer number one hundred
and I'm not telling anybody how to run
their own business but it seems to me
like if you wanted to make counterfeit
stamps that guy just took a great step
in the right direction yeah absolutely
US Postal Service man never mind Louis
de Joy this guy's taking over there you
go
65. Kevin Smith's Green Arrow original
comic book this is issue number two
cover by Matt Wagner again
professionally framed and matted let's
take a peek of that cover oh
stunning there's our hobo version of
Oliver Queen when he came back from the
dead that's kind of what the story of
quiver which is uh what this run of the
book was called uh was all about the
character revolver Queen have been
killed off and have been replaced by his
son Connor Hawk and TC brought me in and
Phil and Andy to bring Oliver Queen back
and restore the character so this
rendition of them on the cover is meant
to be the the one who's been disheveled
and lost for a few months before he
starts the adventure
cool I got 2728 2077
2800 2800 2900 2900 by 3 000. you're
talking about three you're not gonna buy
three talking about three talking about
three talking about 29 talking about
three thousand dollars 2900 about three
thousand dollars what are you not gonna
buy three jacket about thirty two fifty
thirty two fifty thirty two fifty thirty
two fifty thirty two fifty three
thousand now we get about 32 make it
about thirty two make it about three
thousand I'm talking about thirty two
fifty thirty two fifty three talking
about thirty two minutes about three
times you're gonna buy 32 picking about
three talking about thirty two fifty
three talking about 32.50 going once
this is a great deal for what it is guys
three talking about 32.50 going twice
last call
sold three thousand dollars here buyer
number two high 100 buyer number one
hundred Lot number 66 Kevin Smith's
Green Arrow original comic cover art for
issue number three by Matt Wagner who's
featured on that cover let's take a peek
oh there he is Black Manta this black
matcha pages one for a few bucks a few
minutes back here's Green Arrow and
black man's all over that cover Oliver's
your face neck and chest kids there you
go that black man to cover here's your
chance 21 get up 22 get about 23 get
about 24 working about twenty four
twenty three hundred about twenty four
hundred twenty four hundred about twenty
five hundred twenty five hundred by
twenty six hundred what do you say
talking about 22nd about 2700 2700 2800
2800 2900 2900 by 3 000.32.50 3250 32.32
picking up about thirty five hundred
thirty five hundred thirty five hundred
about 37.50 37 picking about four
thousand dollars we're talking about
forty two fifty forty two fifty forty
two fifty forty two fifty forty five
hundred
going once
4500 by 47.50 going twice last call
sold 4 500 buyer number 100 buyer number
one hundred lot 67 the original cover to
Green Arrow issue number four by Matt
Wagner what does that look like
oh look at that it's got the Justice
League all over kids so not only do you
get uh the bow the Longbow in the
foreground uh you got Superman there
Wonder Woman uh Batman
um I think Jon Jones I think oh yeah you
know what I didn't even notice that yeah
kind of in the background wow of the
image yes you know I didn't even notice
that you know I looked at all this stuff
so many times that you just mentioned
that now I see it in the background
that's really nice Matt Wagner's Justice
League kids yeah that's
that's wow I got 3500 by 37.37 picking
about four thousand dollar four knocking
about 42.50 42.50 we're talking about 42
we get about fourth hacking about 42 54
knocking about 42.50 I got four thousand
dollars on live auctioneers been forty
two fifty forty two fifty four thousand
about 42.50 we're talking about 42
picking about 42 picking about four
times I get about 42 picking about four
times you get about 42 make it about
fourth I got about 42.50 going once four
thousand dollars but forty two fifty
going twice last call
very nice cover
sold four thousand dollars by our number
one hundred buyer number one hundred Lot
number 68 Kevin Smith's Green Arrow
original comic cover art issue number
five by Matt Wagner now if I remember
Craig this is Batman on the cover this
is somebody getting uh he's being
examined by Batman so you see Batman's
glove ah in the top right corner with
the gauntlet yeah yeah yeah yeah I see
that so he's doing an uh like uh sort of
autopsy on this Oliver Queen to see if
he's the real Oliver Queen in the bat
cave so this is a rendition of Oliver
Queen on Batman's operating table in the
bat cave with Batman's glove and
evidence two thousand about 2100 about
2200 2200 2200 2200 2300 2400 2400 2500
2500 2600 2600 2600 2700 2700 2800 2800
2900 2900 get about three thousand now
we're gonna buy three thousand about
three seconds about three thousand
dollars what are you not talking about
three thousand dollars wait no I'm
talking about three talking about 3
going once
about thirty five hundred going once
thirty two fifty can about thirty five
hundred dollars going twice last call
sold for 32.50 the buyer number 100
buyer number one hundred lot 69. we have
the Kevin Smith's Green Arrow original
comic art cover issue number six uh by
Matt Wagner uh take it away Kevin what
which one is it there also painted
there's uh etch again the demon right
there on the cover you've got Oliver
Queen in the foreground and you've got
uh Matt Wagner's return to the character
of the demon he did a mini series for DC
years prior to us doing this uh Green
Arrow book so for him to draw etch again
for the cover he didn't do the Interiors
remember that was Hester and Parks but
for him to be able to draw etrigan again
for the cover I think was a huge thing
for for Matt and a big thing in the in
the world of comics DC Comics
particularly cool I got 23 you get about
24. 24 working about 25. 25 25
32.50 3250 3500 thirty five hundred
thirty five hundred thirty five hundred
thirty five [__] about thirty seven
fifty thirty seven fifty thirty seven
making about four thousand dollars four
thousand dollars fourth knocking about
forty two fifty forty two fifty forty
five hundred forty five hundred forty
five hundred about forty seven about
forty seven get about five thousand
dollars five thousand dollars forty
seven five thousand get about forty
seven about forty seven I forget about
five thousand dollars forty seven people
about five packing about forty seven I
forget about five packing about forty
seven pick it up a five second about
five second about five thousand dollars
going once what's another bid what's
another two hundred and fifty dollars
come on hit it again
and you got a nice demon in there as
well five talking about fifty two fifty
fifty two fifty fifty two fifty five
talking about fifty two about fifty five
hundred fifty five hundred fifty five
hundred fifty five hundred fifty two
video about fifty five hundred fifty two
videos about fifty five hundred trust me
guys whoever is buying all these they're
keeping them they you ain't ever gonna
see these come back on the market
anytime soon ladies and gentlemen Now's
the Time to buy it Now's the Time to Get
It guys 52 make it about 55 I could
about 52 minutes
about fifty five hundred going once 52
but again about fifty five hundred going
twice last call
sold five thousand two hundred and fifty
dollars the buyer number one hundred
buyer number one hundred lot 70 the
original comic book cover for Kevin
Smith's Green Arrow issue number seven
by Matt Wagner so I remember correctly
this is the Hal Jordan Specter cover yes
there you go man Hal Jordan took over as
the Specter for a while in the DC comic
books and uh this is the issue where uh
the Hal Jordan who Oliver Queen had
traveled across the country with always
hard traveling Heroes re-encounters his
friend who's now Beyond godhood at this
point so it's gorgeous
pure Hal Jordan fan a parallax fan or
green or uh Lantern fan or green arrow
yeah I agree with that sorry 5000 52.50
5500 5500 57 50 gonna buy six thousand
six knocking about 62.50 62.50
6500 6500 about 6750 6750 67 50 by 67
making it about 65
going once
sixty five hundred don't miss out ladies
and gentlemen this is a very very
beautiful piece ladies and gentlemen
once again you're not going to see these
come up ever again it's going to be
years before and you're going to go
every time you're gonna think about it
you're like you know I was the
underbinner I just did that I was
bidding on some Elvis Presley jewelry
all right and I I I was the under bitter
well we under bidded about nine pieces
nine items and I didn't get any of them
and I still kicked myself this was last
year we were sitting in Cape May uh and
we're literally having dinner we're
bidding on Elvis Presley rings and
cufflinks and [__] and uh I didn't get
one and I'm still mad to this day that I
go one more bit look at you man you
would imagine as a pro you're like I
don't fall for those games I would never
enter the auction game and you're like I
was the under bidder on Elvis oh man it
really ticked me off and it was really
cool stuff you know I know I told you I
had to why well because you know why you
know you get to that point you know
you're like why you know but it would
have been cool anyway 65 I'm gonna buy
60. don't do that here keep bidding
you're gonna wish you a bit again 65 I'm
gonna buy 67.50 because I see obviously
I'm still talking about a year and a
half ago saying I wish I still want you
it haunts me to this day 65 I'm gonna
buy 67 I think about 65 I get about
67.50 going once 6500 about 67 50 going
twice last call
sold 6 500 buyer number 100 buyer number
one hundred lot 71's the original comic
book cover art Kevin Smith's Green Arrow
issue number eight by Matt Wagner
professionally framed and matted uh this
features Oliver Queen uh looking at a
different rendition of Oliver Queen the
one that actually died in comes like the
year prior so it's them facing himself
in the afternoon that's actually pretty
cool we're getting two green arrows for
the first one wow two thousand twenty
one hundred twenty two hundred twenty
two hundred twenty one hundred about
twenty two hundred by twenty two hundred
by twenty three hundred twenty three
hundred twenty four hundred twenty four
hundred twenty four hundred twenty five
hundred twenty five hundred twenty six
hundred twenty six hundred twenty six
hundred twenty seven hundred twenty
seven hundred twenty eight hundred
twenty eight hundred twenty eight
hundred twenty eight hundred twenty nine
hundred twenty nine hundred by three
thousand dollars three thousand dollars
three thousand dollars are you talking
about three talking about three talking
about three talking about three thousand
dollars are you talking about thirty two
fifty thirty two fifty thirty five
hundred thirty five hundred thirty five
hundred I think you could I think you
should thirty five hundred
they're facing each other in the
afterlife and the life ladies and
gentlemen of great reflection of
yourself guys right there 3 500 32
thinking about 35 we're gonna buy 32
picking about 3 500 going once don't
miss out 3500 by 37 50 get about four
thousand dollars we're talking about
we're talking about four thousand thirty
seven picking about four thousand 37
picking up about four talking about four
second about four thinking about four
thousand dollars once again these were
Staples at your secret stash because
they were going right across the wall
yeah in the back there I remember seeing
them there every time now they just got
this Decor
um in the secrets yes yes it was it was
Decor in the secret stash ladies and
gentlemen here we go 37 picking about
four talking about 37 picking up my
fourth hacking about 37 picking about
four thousand dollars going once 37
picking about four thousand dollars
going twice last call
sold three thousand seven hundred and
fifty dollars higher number one hundred
lot 72 Kevin Smith's Green Arrow
original comic book art issue number
eleven by Matt Wagner professionally
framed and matted now this month in DC
Comics they featured the titles
prominently
um on the books say will Eisner yeah
very much yeah very well Eisner in the
mirror across the boards uh that month
on all the books they had them do these
kind of graphic covers where the title
was kind of everything uh and so this is
it so you know if you're a green arrow
fan this is a stunning image to hang on
your wall just says it all doesn't even
matter what the story was inside the
book it's just a classic image of the
Oliver Queen uh Green Green Arrow
sitting there on a rooftop with the
title right under his feet
sixty five hundred sixty five hundred
sixty five hundred don't whip out now
bid one more time sir six thousand
negative by sixty two fifty sixty two
minutes sixty five hundred sixty two
minutes he hung up already
62.6500. he said screw that quick sixty
two minutes sixty five hundred two
million sixty five we're gonna buy sixty
two forget about sixty five hundred
going once 62 billion about sixty five
hundred dollars going twice last call
sold six thousand two hundred and fifty
dollars buyer number one hundred buyer
number one hundred congratulations buyer
one hundred lot 73 Kevin Smith's Green
Arrow cover for issue number 12 by Matt
Wagner professionally framed and matted
uh is this the cover that has yes
Hawkman oh man look at that are you a
cater Hall fan kids do you like to see
somebody holding a mace well there you
go this covers for you Green Arrow and
Hawkman in their never-ending uh battle
against one another they're both Heroes
but they kind of come to blows
periodically over uh their style and
their ethos gorgeous cover another
gorgeous covered by Matt Wagner drawn
Hawkman adding Hawkman to his resume
2900 about three thousand now we're
gonna buy three packets about three
seconds
don't miss out ladies and gentlemen this
is absolutely stunning God you got
Hawkeye in it Hawkeye right is that what
it is Hawk man guys Hawkman in there 37
picking about fourth hour get about 37 I
get about four thousand dollars going
what thirty seven if you get about four
thousand dollars going twice last call
four thousand I got it four thousand but
forty two fifty forty two fifty get in
there forty two fifty forty five hundred
forty five hundred forty five hundred
come on back now forty five hundred I
didn't mean to try to take you out sorry
about that forty five hundred forty
seven get about 45 it's dangerous around
here you know I'm all over the place 27
picking about five thousand dollars five
thousand dollars five thousand now we're
about five talking about fifty two fifty
fifty two fifty fifty two fifty fifty
five hundred fifty five hundred fifty
five hundred fifty five hundred about
fifty five good about fifty Seven fifty
fifty Seven about six thousand dollars
six thousand dollars six thousand
dollars six thousand now we're gonna buy
fifty Seven I forget about six ounces
we're gonna buy six thousand dollars
going once you came all this way guys
you almost doubled in price six thousand
by sixty two fifty sixty five hundred
sixty five hundred sixty five hundred
sixty two but you're gonna buy sixty
five hundred by sixty two we're gonna
buy sixty five hundred going once
62 bringing about sixty five hundred
dollars going twice last call
sold six thousand two hundred and fifty
dollars higher number one hundred buyer
number one hundred lot 74 Kevin Smith's
Green Arrow original Wizard magazine the
cover art here again done by Wagner
professionally framed and matted so in
the midst of our Green Arrow runs
another uh wizard magazine which was the
greatest comic book magazine at all time
um they uh did a Green Arrow cover so
that Matt Wagner painted this was that
very cover you're looking at right here
I love this one if I was gonna own any
of them this would be the one I hang up
I love this one this was very tricky for
Erica and I to figure out what it was
yeah this this took up a long time
yeah yeah we were like can't we just ask
Kevin I should I could have made it easy
yeah yeah sorry
you're like testing us to make sure that
we yeah let's see if they know their
[__] over but
how you guys did it yeah it's like I'm
the Lord of the Rings like we could have
just had the Eagles Fly us right yeah
[Laughter]
3500 by 37.50 35 37 forget about four
thousand now forget about four talking
about four talking about four knocking
about four knocking about four second
about four seconds about thirty seven
thinking about four thousand now we're
talking about forty two fifty forty two
fifty forty five hundred forty five
hundred forty five hundred forty five
hundred forty five hundred forty seven
pick it up 42 make it about forty five
hundred what did you forget about forty
five hundred forty two picking about
forty five hundred about forty two make
it about 45.50 47 I forget about forty
seven I forget about forty five [__]
about forty seven fifty forty five forty
forty seven figures about five thousand
dollars five thousand dollars about
forty seven forget about five packing
about forty seven I forget about five
pack it about forty seven figures about
five thousand forty seven I forget about
five thousand forty seven [__] number
five talking about forty seven fifty bit
five thousand dollars going once 47
thinking about five thousand dollars
going twice last call
sold four thousand seven hundred and
fifty dollars buyer number 100 buyer
number one hundred you're gonna talk
about your comic book drill here I'll be
back in two seconds but you guys go on
go ahead and move on all right happily
man we are going to be switching over
um in the next part of the sale over to
Kevin Smith's quick stops portion of the
sale so Kevin you want to explain more
to us what quick software this is the
artwork I'm actually on the fence about
letting go because I've held on to all
of the view SKU or Jay and Silent Bob or
clerks oriented comic book artwork I
still have all that framed or at the
secret stash
um so this was from a book we did fairly
recently
um quick stops uh a book that I do for
secret stash press and for Dark Horse
Comics and um this was issue number two
and
um it's a story about Brody from
Mallrats and Randall from Clinton to
your cousins meeting at the funeral of
their cousin Walter who we reference in
the movie A few different ways so it's
the only viewsk Universe artwork that
I've kind of let get out there and I'm
looking at the auction list right now we
are at 102 of
176. so we're not even at the halfway
mark now I might
pull this stuff which would be this
cover and those pages well I mean we are
slightly more than halfway not to be a
are we having math nerd yeah we're 102
of oh wait no not 102 of 176. yes
here we go let's see let's see what it
goes for yeah let's start with the cover
and see what happens this is a gorgeous
cover up quick stops number two
parks uh it features uh Randall from
clerks holding a dead Brody from uh it's
done uh after George Perez's cover to uh
crisis on it Senator it's number seven
seven is that where we're good yeah he's
super girl yeah just the mock-up of the
Supergirl cover you got a bunch of music
Universe characters behind them so
there's Dante there's Randall I mean
there's Dante there's Jay and Silent Bob
uh a couple other cats Gwen from
Mallrats so uh yeah yeah all right I got
1300 and 1400 1300 about 1400 about 1400
about 1300 about 1400. 1300 1400 about
1400 about 1300 about 1400 1400 about
1500 1500 1600 1600 1500 by 16.60
500 1500 by 1600 1600 1700 1700 but
eighteen hundred eighteen hundred
Seventeen hundred by eighteen hundred or
eighteen hundred by Seventeen hundred by
eighteen hundred eighteen hundred about
Nineteen Hundred by two thousand dollars
two thousand dollars two thousand
dollars two thousand dollars two
thousand now we're gonna buy two tickets
about twenty one hundred twenty one
hundred twenty one hundred twenty one
hundred two talking about twenty one
hundred about twenty one hundred by two
thousand about twenty one hundred by two
thousand about twenty one hundred going
once two thousand now we're gonna buy
twenty one hundred dollars going twice
last call
in time twenty two hundred twenty two
hundred about twenty two good about
twenty one by twenty two hundred wait
one hundred by twenty two hundred by
Twenty One by twenty two by Twenty One
by twenty two by Twenty One by twenty
two hundred dollars going once twenty
one gigabyte twenty two hundred hours
going twice last call
sold twenty one hundred dollars in the
fire number one hundred buyer number one
hundred nice yes here we go all right
sorry Kevin for trying to correct you
there uh if I was I should have realized
if I was good at math I wouldn't be here
it doesn't matter there's no such thing
as him
halfway this way we just go and go and
go till it's over there you go
176. there you go
so we have 101 left to go yes 101 great
shots here we go all right this is the
original comic book art for Kevin Smith
quick stops issue number two page number
one you also get the preliminary pencils
and inks penciled by Phil Hester anchor
is Andy Parks and Kevin has done other
work with these guys I did I did my
group my entire green arrow run was with
those kids
um I became big fans of Hester and Parks
when they did a run on Swamp Thing years
ago with uh Mark Miller
um gorgeous stuff they did so when I got
a chance to to work with them over on
Green Arrow it was absolutely lovely and
so we did this book we also did a book a
long time ago
um a One-Shot uh Tales from the quick
Clerk's comic book so I've known these
cats for years man I love their artwork
so much 25 by 275 250 by two seventy
five two minutes
275 going twice last call
sold 250 here buyer number 200 buyer
number two hundred and again
doesn't let this stuff get out into the
wild so this stuff it's all rare is hens
teeth as
[Laughter]
this is page number two number two from
quick stops number two kids more Hester
and Parks action and it uh features uh
Brody
um I mean Randall from clerks uh talking
to Gwen from Mallrats in this quick
stops book I like to mix up my universe
characters that never met each other in
the movies can meet each other in a much
less expensive comic book 140 good about
150 140 151 51 51.50
one somebody one somebody one somebody
one second one somebody one technique
171 71 81 81 81 81 91 91 91 81 91 91 91
81 90 181 99
200. two and a quarter two and a quarter
by two twenties
now 300 300 300 by 300 somebody talking
about 300 who's somebody talking about
300 dude somebody pocket about 300 by
275 with 300 going once two seventy
pocket about 300 hours going twice last
call in a quarter right in the corner
get about three and a quarter three
hundred about three twenty five three
talking about three twenty five three
hundred by three twenty pocket about
three hundred number three twenty
[__] number three hundred number
three twenty five going once 300 about
three twenty five going twice last call
three hundred dollars buyer number one
hundred buyer number one hundred nice
these are the affordable Pages exactly
this is why we brought you know we were
debating do we sell it as one as a full
comic or do we break it apart so fans
could get a piece of the action of your
stuff and that that's why we decided to
break it apart and sell it one at a time
good call man because it makes a bunch
of pages uh affordable Pages available
to people that would really want it
exactly some of the pages earlier stuff
bigger comic books from the big two from
Marvel and DC go for ridiculous amounts
of money nice to see these Pages go into
the hands of Hardcore fans exactly
so not 78 go ahead it's uh issue number
two page three from Kevin Smith's quick
stops I got a hundred and I'm sorry 110
but 120 120 130 130 140 148
30.50 one fifty one fifty one fifty one
fifty one sixty one sixty one sixty one
sixty one sixty one sixty one sixty one
seventy one seventy one seventy one
eighty one eighty one eighty one eighty
one eighty one eighty one eighty one
seventy one eighty one eighty one ninety
one ninety one ninety nine two wanna get
about two and a quarter note according
to my two and a quarter two and a
quarter two and a half do it according
to my two and a half two and a half two
and a half two seventy five two seven
five two somebody [__] about two
minutes
300 275 300 by 300 by 300 about three
and a quarter three and a quarter three
hundred by three twenty pocket about
three fifty return we're gonna buy three
fix it by three Fifteen by three seventy
five three picking about three somebody
pocketed by three picking up by three
seventy pocket about three weekend
number three seventy five now four
hundred three seventy [__] about 400
400 about four and a quarter four
hundred about four and a quarter four
hundred and four and a quarter four
hundred once
what if I get above 475 going twice last
call
sold 450 here by our number 200 buyer
number 200 you gotta remember you know
back in the day when we actually ran at
the building we would start at eight in
the morning and run till 3 30 in the
morning the next day that's how long the
auctions were and people man they were
there constantly when they were one time
three o'clock in the morning we had this
big comic book collection and some other
stuff and at two o'clock we actually
split it up into two sales because it
was getting two in the morning and we
still had 150 people bidding like nuts
at two o'clock in the morning auction
people are tough people
you're not bidding exactly you know it's
like one of the greatest shows on Earth
even if you're not necessarily engaging
financially that's just fun to watch
that is absolutely true
that I prefer it like this because I
never have to yell on anybody to stop
farting
you mean back at the building yeah
you were like don't [__] fart I got
one
back at the building when we were at the
building it would be like it was like
five people deep maybe like 80 people at
the toy sale maybe 100 people and
sometimes people would just fart and
it's a bidding strategy I guess it does
and uh it really was just people out of
the room yeah it would clear the room
man I swear to God but everybody back
then yeah we would all group around
tables and it was like real insane it
was intense tense situations
please don't say is that uh they keep
plying us with sugar here
like eat some eat some sugar we got
hours to go yeah yeah yeah that's I
didn't want to say anything when you
guys were like oh this is going to be a
four hour sale I was like there's no way
it's going to be well if it's bidding
like this it does take a little bit
longer that's true anyway lot 79 but
it's fun hey it's fun exactly as it goes
this is a double page spread correct
this is a double page spread Pages four
and five from issue number two Kevin
Smith's Quick Stop man this is the title
page double page spread so you get a
full image of Brody uh you get a full
image of Randall both at the funeral for
their cousin Walter and to the right you
got their cousin Walter descending in
that hero pose is this set in uh
poston's funeral it is it's set posten's
funeral in Atlantic Highlands New Jersey
wow 475 now 500.75
and a quarter five and a quarter five
hundred five and a quarter five and a
half five minutes
going twice last call
sold 775 dollars the buyer number two
hundred buyer number two hundred number
eighty Page Six from issue number two
Kevin Smith's quick stops let's see who
we got pictured on this image uh we got
some more Randall and Brody in
conversation about their dead cousin
Walter uh at the funeral parlor as the
wake is going on two and a quarter by
two and a half two and a quarter two and
a half there's two characters I've never
met in the movies Randall was in clerks
Brody was in Mall Rats they're cousins
but they never met in the movies this is
the first time they ever met was in this
comic real really yeah wow 275
300.300 about 300 about three and a
quarter three and a quarter three and a
quarter three and a half three and a
quarter number three and a half gonna
buy three make it about three picking
about three fifty three seventy five
three seventy five three seventy five
now four hundred three seven [__]
about 400 about 400 about three seventy
pocket about four hundred about four
hundred about four hundred by three
seventy pocket about 400. reach
everybody talking about 400.75 about 400
about four hundred four and a quarter
four quarter four and a quarter four and
a quarter four and a quarter four
hundred about four twenty pocket about
450.
pocket about
450.50 454 75 475 we're thinking about
25 going twice last call
um the meanings between these characters
these canonical or are these like
elseworld stories what a great question
um they are canonical as far as I'm
concerned this happened once I don't
even know what that means that means did
it actually happen yes all of the movies
does this story count okay absolutely
like if we were to make a movie we could
reference these issues of the comic book
and it would stand so it's absolutely uh
Canon all right cool excellent nerdy
question
so this is
um Kevin stops quick stops original
comic art to page seven Lot number 81.
more Randall more Brody talking about
their dead cousin that they share that
they both reference works in Mall Rats
the movies 180 191 91
99. now three hundred three hundred
about three hundred by three hundred
about three and a quarter three and a
quarter three and a quarter three
hundred about three twenty five three
hundred by three twenty pocket about 300
by three twenty pocket about three
hundred by three twenty five going once
talking about 325 going twice glass call
three hundred dollars buyer number 200
buyer number two hundred lot 82 Kevin
Smith's quick stops original comic book
art ish two page eight
uh I guarantee you there's more Brody
and Randall happening on this page there
you go let's take a peek there it is
yep there they are if you ever liked
either of those characters from clerks
or Mallrats this is
rendition not only to get the inks page
but you get the pencil Pages as well two
pages for the price of one and it's
realistically it's your only way to ever
own anything like this that's very true
I usually hold on to all the views
Universe artwork uh this features the
debut of the character it was only
referenced uh in the movies referenced
uh in in the flicks we never saw them
before but in the comics he's played by
a friend of mine Chris Davis who used
his image for the cousin Walter I
wouldn't be surprised if he was the one
bidding on some of these Pages 375 about
400.4 and a quarter four and a quarter
four and a quarter four hundred and a
four twenty five we're talking about
four twenty [__] about 400 number
four twenty [__] about 400 about four
twenty five four hundred number four
twenty pocket about 400 number four
twenty five double four hundred number
four 25
going once
400.50 45
lot 83 Kevin Smith's quick stops
original comic art issue two page nine
um
more Brody more Randall
flashing back to an Adventure that they
had when they were younger
um so uh this is them when they're out
at night and trying to be vigilantes in
Leonardo New Jersey all right I love it
this is great this is fantastic 180 190.
191.99
two and a quarter two and a quarter two
and a quarter two and a quarter two and
a quarter two and a half two and a half
300.75.75 reach everybody
375 going once 350 but 375 hours going
twice last call
sold 350 dollars higher number 200 buyer
number two hundred lot eighty four Kevin
Smith's quick stops original comic art
issue two page 10.
page 10 kids were halfway through the
issue uh this affordable run of pages
right here uh there's more flashback of
them driving around trying to be
Vigilantes wearing sunglasses
that's cool 250 but 275 to 300.30
and a quarter three and a quarter three
hundred about three twenty five three
hundred dollars
three seventy five three seven [__]
number three seventy [__] number
three somebody pocket number three
seventy five three picking up three
somebody pocket about three figures
about three seventy pocketed by three
big number three seventy pocketed by
three pick number three seventy five
going once
400.35
bid 400 going what reach everybody
pocket about four hundred dollars going
twice last call
I love when that gavel hits there you go
oh that sweet sound of the gavel
striking
lot 85 Kevin Smith's quick stops
Original start issue two page eleven
uh look at this uh there this is them
getting paint dumped on their car if I
remember correctly absolutely 140.
they're they're actually dumping paint
on the car yeah there's a guy the cousin
Walter who dumps paint on their car and
makes it look like a giant dick
275 hours going twice last call
sold two hundred and fifty dollars here
buyer number 200 buyer number 200. lot
86 Kevin Smith's quick stops original
comic art issue two page 12. page 12
kids the story continues uh let's see
what that looks like
yep that's them looking at the hood of
their car and seeing the damage that's
been done only in Jersey 170 180 170 180
181 81 71 81 81 81 81 91 91 91 91 91 81
995 200 about 220 pocket about two I
think about two twenty pocket about 2005
250.50 225
going what 220 pocket about 252.75 275
275 going once 250 but 275 not 300 about
300 300 by 275 300.
let's call
sold 275 dollars to buy our number 100
buyer number one hundred lot eighty
seven Kevin Smith's quick stops original
art issue two page 13.
and let's see what we got here there it
is it's a splash page of sorts with the
car with a giant dick literally if
you've ever wanted to own a PCR work
like this kids and have a classy reason
to hang it up in your house here you go
three and a quarter three and a half
three big and about three we get about
three weekend about
350.35
number three picking about 353.75 35
400.4 and a quarter four and a quarter
four and a quarter four hundred about
four twenty five welcome to my four
twenty [__] number four picking about
four figures about four make it about
450. we're picking them up four pick it
up four twenty pocket about four pick it
up four twenty pocket about 450. we'll
get about four pick it up four twenty
five bid 450 going once four twenty
about 415 going twice last call
425 dollars a buyer number 100 buyer
number 200 buyer number 200. Lot 88
Kevin Smith's quick stops original comic
cart issue two page 14. and kids this is
the official halfway mark right here 88.
half of 176. we are halfway through the
auction ladies and gentlemen there you
go nobody's going to pick up now yes 140
150 140 160 161 61 71 71 7171 somebody
want somebody 171 60 170 171.81 81 81 91
91 91 91 81 91
99.75 275 300 about three and a quarter
three and a quarter three and a quarter
three and a half three and a half get
them by three Wicket about three forget
about three Wicket about three twenty
three seventy five 375 375 375 400 400
400 400 you came all this way 400 104
and a quarter four and a quarter four
and a quarter four hundred and four and
a quarter welcome to my four twenty
pocket number four fifty four twenty
[__] about 450 which one
let's call
sold 450 a year by our number 100 buyer
number 200 200 buys
Lot 89 Kevin Smith's quick stops
original comic cart issue two page 15.
page 15 features the uh continue A
continuing adventure of uh Dante uh not
Dante Randall Brody and uh cousin Walter
who is dressed in a count cockula
costume
that'd be their their super villain
that's great 250 275. if we get about
275. 300. here's somebody [__] about
300 300 in about three and a quarter
three and a quarter three and a quarter
three hundred and about three twenty
five three hundred about three twenty
pocket about 300 about three twenty
pocket about
350.3 253 25
350 going once three twenty [__]
about 350 going twice last call
sold 325 over 200 buyer number two
hundred buys lot 90 Dark Horse Kevin
Smith quick stops issue two page 16.
almost at the end of this kids not many
more pages to get there's counter
cockula at the top of the page
150 160. what a name 160 170 180
181.81.81 81 71 81 81 91
995 275
275 300 275 about 300.75
330 and a quarter 300 about three twenty
five hundred by three fifty three fifty
three fifty three twenty pocket about
350.
350 375 370 pocket about three seventy
pocket about three pick it up three
somebody pocket about three picking up
by three seventy pocket about three
picking up three seventy five going once
pretty good about three seventy five
going twice last call
three hundred and fifty dollars buyer
number two hundred buyer number two
hundred lot ninety one Kevin Smith quick
stops original comic card issue two page
17. let's see what image we got this
time kids
it may be the page where uh yes yeah
there's uh there's in this page uh Brody
and Randall catch cousin Walter trying
to fellate himself
trying to suck his own dick that's what
that top panel is right there so if
you've ever wanted to own a piece of
artwork where a person is trying to suck
their own dick kids this is the page for
you
four and a quarter been four and a half
two page 17. yes that's what's happening
in the story ladies Florida Court have
been pouring a ham get them up before we
get about four pick it up four pick it
up four twenty pocket about 454 54 20
pocket number four fifty which
is pocket about four pick it up four
twenty pocket about 450. everyone's
tried it once I think four 25
[Music]
kids don't listen to that okay
just for the record not everyone
or 25
84 50 going what's what's welcome to my
450 going twice last call
so 425 buyer number uh 200 buyer number
200. it's not too much he wasn't here
lot 92 Kevin Smith's quick stops
original comic art issue two page 18.
well the last page you're going to be
able to get lots of count cocktail on
this page if I had to guess Chris Davis
is totally bidding for this page right
now I got 150 160 170 180 180 180 180
170 180 191 99
200. you want to get my two and a
quarter two and a half two and a half
two and a half two are going to be two
and a half two and a half two seventy
five two somebody [__] about two
somebody [__] divide two seventy five
now three hundred about 300 about 300 by
300 by 300.75 300 275 about 300 about
three and a quarter three and a quarter
three hundred about three twenty five
three hundred about three twenty [__]
about three fifty three twenty five
three fifty three twenty we're gonna buy
three make it about three weekend by
three Wicket by three twenty pocket
about three picking up by three twenty
five big three fifty three twenty five
three fifty three seventy five who's
picking up at 375. we're picking number
three somebody pocket about three
picking up by three somebody pocketed by
three picking up by three seventy five
going once 350 bit 375 dollars going
twice last call
sold 350 dollars a year buyer number two
hundred buyer number two hundred lot 93
Kevin Smith quick stop the original
comic art issue two page 19.
I got 110 but 120 130 140 140 141 41.50
one fifty one sixty one sixty one sixty
one seventy one seventy one eighty one
eighty one eighty one eighty one ninety
one ninety one ninety not two hundred
two and a quarter two and a half three
quarters 275 275
three and a quarter three and a quarter
three hundred about three and a quarter
three and a half 375 375 375 400 get
about 400 about 400 about three seventy
pocket about 400 about four and a
quarter four and a quarter get about
four and a quarter four and a half four
and a half four and a half four and a
quarter before and a half four seventy
five four somebody [__] about 500
500.
five and a quarter five and a quarter
five and a half five and a half five and
it could have been five and a half I
could have been five and a half half and
a quarter five and a half five seventy
five seventy five not six hundred six
hundred gonna buy six hundred number
five six and a quarter six and a quarter
six twenty five six hundred about six
twenty five six hundred by six twenty
five six hundred by six twenty five
going once six hundred by six twenty
five going twice last call oh
600 hours here buyer number 200 buyer
number two hundred plot number 94 Kevin
Smith's quick stops original comic art
issue two page 20. this is the last page
kids last page you can get of quick
stops number two or mostly any of usq
comic book that I've done there you go
there it is Audie and Randall leaving
the funeral and leaving cousin Walter
behind in the Box 160 170 180 180 190
190 190 190 1992 and a quarter two and a
quarter two and a quarter two and a half
275 275 300 three and a quarter three
and a quarter three and a half three and
I'm gonna buy three picking up by three
big enough by three big enough three
make it about three twenty pocket about
350. 375. three somebody [__] about
three somebody pocketed by three 75
400.3 400 four and a quarter four and a
quarter four and a half what a quarter
but four and a half half half and a coat
of four and a half or the quarter been
four and a half four and a half 175 475
475 475 I think you could think it
should have came all this way this is
the last one of the Kevin Smith ones
525 hours going twice last call
500 to 200 500 to 200 lot 95 back to
green arrow here Green Arrow issue
number 13 page number one pencil by Phil
Hester ain't by Andy Park Kevin this is
uh you wrote this right I did uh I'm
still writing Green Arrow at this point
for issue 13. uh Hester and Park's doing
artwork let's see that Black Canary page
um can we push in on that or we can we
bring a little closer to the camera
because if I remember correctly this is
a [__] sex page kids
like I believe in the top what's going
on in that top panel right there
yeah it kind of looks that way to me
I think so do you got Erica just pull it
off the thing and give it to him so you
can see can I take a peek real quick
yeah really quick
um let's see this is a green arrow paid
by Heston parks and
it is uh Black Canary in bed listening
to an argument
uh from the other room between Green
Arrow Oliver Queen Green Arrow and um
cater Hall uh Hawkman there it is it was
not a sex page but she is in bed naked
do you want to get about two and a
quarter two liking about two twenty
pocketed by 200.25
200 about 2 25
25. 225 250 225
252.75 275
75 going once 250 but 275 dollars going
twice last call
sold 250 dollars nice buy buyer number
200 buyer number 200. lot 96 Green Arrow
Issue 13 Pages two and three this might
be a bit more compelling for folks uh
it's a double splash page let me put
that up look at that it's beautiful guys
there's uh Oliver Queen Green Arrow
who's out of his outfit about to be
attacked by uh Hawkman in the Justice
Society mansion and then there's uh
Black Canary right beside it 400.4 and a
half and 475 or somebody [__] above
475 Ford somebody talking about four
picking up a 475. we'll pick it up
forward somebody talking about four
picking number four seventy five fours
everybody find out
500.7500.755
and a quarter five and a quarter five
and a quarter five hundred number five
twenty five five twenty pocket about
five [__] about five twenty five five
pick it up five pick it up five fifty
five fifty five fifty five fifty five
twenty pocket about five fifty five
twenty [__] about five fifty double
splash page guys five fifty five seventy
five five
pick it up five seventy five five
seven five six hundred yeah
six hundred all right somebody [__]
about 600.75
75 bid 600 going once
can you show that layover thing again
with the stat oh look how cool this is
this is cool guys this is all the
letters oh I see what you're saying
because it's a layover yeah yeah the
artwork remains artwork and then the
letters come on top and this layover two
pages yeah look at that 575 and 600.75
75 beat 600 coming what 75 600 going
twice last call
575 buyer number uh 200 buyer number
200.97 Green Arrow original comic art
Issue 13 page four
more Black Canary Hawkman and green
arrow uh action five and a quarter five
and a half by 75 5755
75 going once
550 bid 575 going twice last call
sold 515 supplier number 200 buyer
number 200. lot 98 Green Arrow original
comic art Issue 13 page five I got 275
and 300 275 300 about 300 about three
and a quarter three and a quarter three
and a quarter three hundred about three
twenty [__] about 350.
350.3 picking about three but get about
three picking about three twenty [__]
about three pick it up three twenty
[__] about three fifty three twenty
one about three weekend about three we
get about three weekend about three
twenty pocket about three picking about
three twenty [__] about three making
about three twenty three seventy five
three seventy five three seventy five
three picking about three seventy pocket
about 350 by three seventy pocket about
three weekend about three seventy five
going once this is nice guys you got
Hawk man you got green arrow but you
also have Mr terrific down there in that
bottom panel yeah that's cool yeah Mia
deardon us who uh who later becomes
Speedy yeah there's this good collection
of characters here three 50 minutes 35
375 going once who are you thinking
about 375 going twice that's cool
350 here buyer number 200 buyer number
two hundred lot 99 Green Arrow issue
number 13 Page Six Original art
conversation from the same issue
featuring all your favorite characters
from The Green Arab number of kids two
and a half 275 275
300 275 300 275
300 by two somebody pocket about three
hundred by three seventy five bid 300
going what two somebody pocket about
three hundred dollars going twice last
call
so for 275 dollars the buyer number 200
buyer number two hundred Lot number 100.
it could be kind of interesting this is
uh this is always a learning every time
you have a live auction and you you what
you think will bring money does it
sometimes and what you uh think would
bring nothing brings the most it's just
quite interesting that's how all sales
are it's crazy this uh page has Black
Canary with balls on her
all right Mr terrific has those balls
that he floats around so uh they come in
hand in this panel covering up her
nudity I got four and a quarter been
four and a half four and a quarter been
four and a half four seventy five
hundred about five hundred about five I
get about four seventy five [__]
about five and a quarter five and a
quarter five and a half I'm gonna be
five and a half five and a half five
seventy five that's six hundred five six
hundred minutes
and a quarter six and a half six and a
half six and a quarter but six and a
half six and a quarter been six and a
half six and a half six seventy five six
seventy pocket to five six seven eight
pocket about six seventy five six five
six seventy five now seven hundred seven
hundred seven hundred six seventy pocket
about 700 by 700 by six seventy five
hundred by seven hundred so you spoke
too soon here 675 by
700.756 75 being 700 going what six
seventy five it's seven hundred dollars
going twice last call
sold six hundred and seventy five
dollars the buyer number two hundred
buyer number two hundred because that
was Lot 100 man we only got 76 more left
all right lot 101 Green Arrow original
comic art Issue 13 page eight all right
200 two and a quarter two and a quarter
two and a half two and a half two
seventy five three hundred about three
hundred about three hundred about three
hundred by two seventy [__] about 300
275 300 275 300 275 303 and a quarter
three and a quarter three and a quarter
three and a quarter three hundred about
three twenty five three hundred about
three twenty pocket about three hundred
about three twenty pocket about three
hundred about three twenty five three
packing about three twenty pocket about
three hundred about three twenty five
going once Thirty hundred about three
hundred and twenty five dollars going
twice in time 350. 350. we're gonna buy
three make it about three weekend by
three twenty pocket about three picking
up three twenty pocket about three fifty
going once three twenty [__] about
three hundred and fifty dollars going
twice last call
325 to 200 325 the buyer number two
hundred one oh two green arrow original
comic art Issue 13 page nine
let's take a peek at this oh yes this
features a character I created for this
story called Buckeye
um he's a vigilante uh obviously with
Ohio leanings but uh he gets killed in
this very issue so he makes his first
and last appearance in this issue
spoiler alert yeah Brothers yeah 110 120
140 141 31 40. we're talking about
fifty one sixty one sixty one sixty one
sixty one sixty one sixty one sixty one
sixty one somebody one somebody one
somebody one somebody one eighty one
eighty one eighty one eighty one seventy
one eighty one eighty one eighty one
eighty one eighty one seventy one eighty
one eighty one seventy one eighty one
seventy one eighty one seventy one
eighty going once pay attention ladies
and gentlemen you know you want to get
in here
1790 thank you 191.90 191.90 181 ninety
one ninety one ninety one eighty one
ninety 181 91 91 81 91 91 81 91 81 91 81
90 going once 180 119 hours going twice
last call
sold 180 to 200 180 to
200.103 Green Arrow original comic are
ish 13 page 10.
last call
104 Green Arrow comic art Issue 13 page
eleven
those gauge features onomatopoeia who is
the villain that I created uh for Green
Arrow I love that yeah they used that
character recently when uh Superman and
Lois that you know oh really yeah they
brought onomatopoeia into the CW
universe and uh this is uh his meeting
with uh Buckeye as you can see Buckeye's
wife's already did and Buckeyes not in
this world either but uh there's very
little onomatopoeia artwork that ever
got out there I have most of this is one
of the rare pieces you can pick up 500
mid five and a quarter 500 about five
and a quarter five and a quarter five
and a quarter five hundred of a five
twenty pocket about five twenty pocket
about five twenty five five pocket about
five twenty five [__] number five
twenty five going once and a half five
and a half five and a half five and a
half High 25
20 pocket about five fifty five twenty
[__] about five pick it up by five
twenty pocket number five pick it up
five twenty five bit five fifty going
once 525 and 550 going twice last call
sold 525 to 100 buyer number one hundred
all right now Kevin I have another
question
since you created onomatopoeia
did DC give you like any heads up that
they were going to use him or are you
just like you're watching TV and then
you're like oh wow there's my guy it was
that they basically when you create a
character for them there's an agreement
that like you both have access to it
they own it but you know you have
creation you Creator rights that are
very minimal like I reached out to Phil
Hester and I was like oh my God they
used on a metapia we're going to be rich
and Phil was like they've used a couple
of my characters from the comics in the
shows he's gone it's worth about five
hundred dollars that's about it so yeah
it's uh it's you're never gonna get rich
unless you created Harley Quinn yeah and
even then I bet you pauldini would tell
you like well could have done better
it's worked for hire right you're
creating characters within their
Universe on their playground so even if
you create a character like onomatopoeia
it's their character he can't I can't
take them with me or anything yeah right
does that make sense
in comics that's like when it says pow
or or
um Splash or something a word that means
a sound snicked snicked of course for
Wolverine so I create onomatopoeia is
what it's called and it has always been
called that in literature and in comics
and so for the Green Arrow comics I took
that character I created that character
based on a premise that I thought only
really worked on the page because it's
basically the character never says
anything except except on a metapoetic
words however they found a way to make
them work in in Superman and Lois cool I
got two and a quarter of a two and a
half two and a quarter get about two and
a half getting about two weekend about
two weeks
three and a half going what
three and a quarter but three and a half
going twice last call
sold 325 dollars the buyer number two
100 buyer number 100. La one of six
Green Arrow issue number 13 page
thirteen original art
this is nice because it's got all the
different uh almost like a film strip
going there it's pretty cool yeah I
can't quite see uh it's also is this
still the death of Buckeye yes it's uh
onomatopoeia like working the body and
he's listening yeah and he's listening
to a TV report about it that's what all
the word balloons are
[Laughter]
so the hundred and ninety dollars why
your number 100 buyer number one hundred
wow 107 Green Arrow Issue 13 page 14.
and this I believe has Connor Hawk
Oliver Queen's uh son in it as well as
Mia beard in a character that I created
uh and there's an onomatopoeia in the
top left corner as well so you get a
bevy of characters right there once
including two green arrows there you go
160 170 180 180 181 81 71 81 81 81 91 91
91 91 91 91 81 91 91 91 81 90.19
by two and a quarter two and a quarter
two and a quarter two hundred by two
twenty five two hundred by two twenty
five two hundred by two twenty five two
hundred by two twenty pocket about 200
about 2 25 going once 200 about 225
dollars going twice last call
200 200 200 200 well number 108 Green
Arrow issue 13 page 15. this one has
images of Connor Hawk Oliver Queen and
Mia Darden
150 160 170 170 170 170 180 180 180 190
190 190 190 190 1999
200. don't miss out two and a quarter
two and a quarter about two and a
quarter two and a quarter two hundred
about two twenty five two hundred by two
twenty five two hundred by two twenty
pocket about 200 about 225 going once
200 about 225 going twice last call
200 200 200 to
200.109 Green Arrow original comic R
issue 13 page 16.
once again more Conor Hawk action if
you're a fan of the Conor hawk green
arrow here's him talking to his dad
Oliver Queen I got 160 171 81 81 81 81
71 81 81 81 seventy one eighty one
seventy one eighty one eighty one
seventy one eighty this one does have
like a weird floating stat Bubble at the
bottom of the page kind of under the
artwork in the Border there's an extra
stat down there
um probably fell off of one of the top
brands yeah it might have fell off one
of the frames of that one or right there
yeah 170 171.80 180 180 171 81 81 81 71
81 80 171 81 81 71 81 71 81 71.80 going
once hundred and somebody been 180
dollars going twice last call
hundred and seventy dollars at 234 170
at 234. La once and green arrow original
comic art Issue 13 page 17.
uh more Connor Hawk and Oliver Queen
talking action I got 100 110 110 121
Twenty One Thirty One Thirty One Thirty
One Thirty One Thirty One Thirty One
Thirty One forty one forty one fifty one
fifty one fifty one fifty one fifty one
sixty one sixty one sixty one seventy
one seventy one seventy one seventy one
seventy one eighty one eighty one eighty
one ninety one ninety one ninety one
nineties
well not gonna buy 2009 200
going once 190 but 200 hours going twice
last call
so the hundred and ninety dollars here
buyer number uh 100 buyer number one
hundred lot 111 Green Arrow original
comic art Issue 13 page 18. let's take a
peek at this page
oh it's somebody's about to get mugged
in Star City
um is there anybody on the page any
Heroes
Jesus
I don't know that's how you sell it
let's just say it's comic book page and
let it go with that [__] got very real
for a moment kids
140 150 140 151 50
150. before you get a moment again
115 hours going twice last call
so the 140 to 200 buyer number 200.
112 Green Arrow original comic R Issue
13 page 19. continuation of that
previous page we do have Green Arrow
coming in here yeah so the rescue
375 dollars going twice last call
lot 113 Green Arrow original comic art
Issue 13 page 20.
this is cool too because it's like on
the strip
160 170 170 180 181 81 81 81 81 81 91 91
901.99
about two and a half two and a half two
and a half two and a quarter two and a
half two seventy five two seventy five
two we get about two seventy five two
seventy five two seventy five not three
hundred three hundred about three
hundred about three hundred but three
and a quarter three and a quarter three
and a quarter three hundred about three
twenty five three hundred about three
twenty pocket about three hundred number
three twenty pocket about three hundred
number three twenty pocket about three
hundred number three twenty five now
fifty are you thinking about three
picking about three picking about three
fifty three seventy five we're picking
it about three seventy pocket about
three picking up by three seventy pocket
about three Fifteen by three seventy
five going one now four hundred four
hundred about four hundred about three
somebody [__] number four hundred
about three seventy pocket about 400
going once reach 70 pocket about four
hundred dollars in a quarter four and a
quarter four and a quarter four and a
quarter four hundred about four twenty
pocket about four pocket about four
fifty pocket about four hundred number
four twenty five going once 400 about
420 pockets
last call
sold 425 buyer number 200 200 buys wow
114 Green Arrow Issue 13 page 21. this
is a nice image on top I like that it's
nice I can't see what is it we do have
uh we have Connor Hawk
yeah Connor Hawk and onomatopoeia are
both on this page nice it's got some
real green arrow action all over there
yeah no that's great two and a quarter
but two and a half two and a quarter got
about two minutes about two weeks
about two twenty five and about
250.25
252 25
and about 250. who
going once 220 pocketed by 215 going
twice last call
sold 225 buyer number 200 buyer number
two hundred Lot number 115 Green Arrow
original comic art Issue 13 page 22.
this is nice too guys nice image on
there
it's got the layover as well and there's
onomatopoeia with onomatopoetics is blam
says to be continued on the bottom right
this is the last page of that issue 22
we're down to 22 pages
by six and a quarter six and a quarter
six and a half six and a half six and a
half 675 700 700 700.75 700 by 700 by
six seventy pocket about seven hundred
by seven hundred by six seventy pocketed
by 700.75 700 by six seventy pocket
about 700 by 6 75 bid 700 going once six
seventy pocketed by seven hundred
dollars going twice last call
Green Arrow issue 14 page number one
nice big green arrow on this page doing
what Green Arrow should be doing saving
lives and whatnot in Star City two and a
quarter two and a half two and a quarter
get about two minutes
300 275 300 275 300 about 300 by 275
three and a quarter three and a quarter
get about three and a quarter three
hundred about three twenty pocket about
three hundred by three twenty five three
three hundred by three twenty pocket
about three hundred about three twenty
five three hundred by three twenty
pocket about three hundred by three
twenty five going once three hundred
about 325 dollars going twice last call
300 200 300 to 200. 117 we have a double
page spread here
Green Arrow issue 14 pages two and three
uh we got Oliver Queen Green Arrow
carrying Connor Green Arrow into the
hospital after he's been shot uh so it's
a pretty action-oriented page and it's
the title page so it's got the title and
the credit box all over it this is nice
three and a quarter three and a half
three and a quarter get about three and
a half gonna buy three we get about
three weekend about three weekend about
three fifty three seventy five now four
hundred three seventy pocket about 400.
read somebody [__] about 400 about
400 about 400 four and a quarter four
and a quarter four and a half four and a
quarter been four and a half what a
quarter about four and a half four seven
five four seventy five moving into my
four somebody pocket about four pick it
up four five I get about five
[__] about five and a quarter five
and a quarter I've been five and a
quarter five and a quarter five hundred
about five twenty five five twenty
pocket about five hundred number five
twenty five five twenty [__] number
five twenty pocket about five [__]
about five twenty [__] number five
twenty five
55 75 I-75 behind 75 perfect everybody
75 going what
600.60
and a quarter six and a quarter gonna
buy six and a quarter 600 gonna buy six
twenty pocket about six hundred by six
twenty five six hundred by six twenty
five going one and a half six and a half
six and a half come on back now six and
a half six and a half six fifty six make
it about six fifty six twenty five six
fifty six seventy five six seventy five
six seventy five six seventy five see
when they bid a lot it takes longer but
that's okay 6.75 now
700.75
700.75 700.75
75 bit 700 going once six seventy five
bit seven hundred dollars going twice
last call
going what
720 pocket about 750 dollars going twice
last call
sold 725 to 200 buyer number two hundred
lot 118 Green Arrow original comic art
issue 14 page four this is an all Mia
dearden page character I created for the
book and uh they did a version of her
character in The Arrow TV show
his sister if I remember correctly 150
160 150 161 161 51.60
going once
150 bit 160 dollars going twice last
call
sold 150 to buyer number 234 234. Lot
number 119 Green Arrow original comic
cart issue 14 page five and this depicts
black carry uh Black Canary just kicking
ass look at that yeah that's a wonderful
piece great big old action image right
there that's a classic comic book page
there kids if you're ever looking for
the best you do worse reminds me of uh
Dynamic page like in Watchmen when Ozzy
mandia helping that guy in the head yes
very much so three and a quarter I've
been three and a half three and a
quarter been three and a half gonna buy
three by three forget about three twenty
pocket about three picking about three
twenty [__] about 350. hey turn up in
about three picking about three weekend
about three twenty pocket about three
picking number three twenty pocket about
three picking about three twenty five
bit three fifty going once
315 going twice last call in time just
in time 375. 375 come on back now 375
now 400. reach everybody about 400.75
400 by 370 pocket about 400.75 400.75
375 bid 400 going what reach everybody
pocket about 400 going twice last call
so for 375 the 100 buyer number 100.
yeah 120 Green Arrow original Mark issue
14 page six
uh look at that there's more Black
Canary action as she beats ass and then
she uses her Sonic scree right there she
uses her crop that canary
yeah so so the middle panel in there is
her doing her discreet which is awesome
oh cool yeah that's cool 180 190 180 191
91 81 91 91 91 90 181
995 200 about two twenty pocket about
200 about two twenty Pockets
about 250 275 275 25
300. 300 about 300 300 pocket about 300
three and a quarter three and a quarter
get about three and a quarter three and
a quarter three and a quarter three
hundred by three twenty five three
hundred about three twenty pocket about
three hundred about three twenty five
three hundred number three twenty pocket
about 300 about three twenty five three
fifty three twenty three fifty three
times three we get about three twenty
[__] about three weeks about three
twenty [__] about three fifty going
once 320 pocket about 315 going twice
last call
sold 355 dollars a buyer number 100
buyer number 100. Lot number 121 Green
Arrow original art issue 14 page seven
Kevin what do we have Happening Here uh
you got Black Canary uh finishing
beating ass and the bottom uh right hand
panel you got Oliver Queen uh the Green
Arrow watching his son uh as as the
doctors are trying to save his life
180 190 180 1999
two and a quarter two and a quarter two
and a quarter two and a quarter two and
a half two and a half 275 275 275
going once 250 bit 275 dollars going
twice last call
250 dollars here buyer number 100 buyer
number one hundred lot 122 Green Arrow
original art issue 14 page eight
this is a full Splash yeah it's a full
splash page of uh Oliver Queen watching
the doctors work on his son Connor
I got 150 160 170 180 181 91 91 91 91 91
81 91 91 91 81 90 full Splash guys 190.
18 19
by 200. We're not gonna buy 200 by 200
about 200 one I think about two and a
quarter two and a quarter two and a
quarter two and a quarter 200 about 225.
200 about 220 pocket about 200 about two
twenty pocket about 200 about 225 200
about two twenty pocket about 200 about
two twenty pocket about 200 about 225.
sounds cheap for a full Splash guys pay
attention now 225
250.50
2252 25 bid 250 going once two twenty
[__] about 215 going twice last call
275 275 pick it up guys we'll get done
quicker if you keep picking up the speed
I've been in nice 250 bit 275 250 good
about two and somebody pocket about two
making about two seven pocket about two
make it about two seventy five going
what two particular about 275 going
twice last call
sold 250 here buyer number 200 buyer
number 200. what 123 Green Arrow
original comic art issue 14 page nine
uh this uh features I believe that's
green arrow or Olive Queen Green Arrow
talking to is that Mia dearden who
showed up at the hospital if not Black
Canary but I'm pretty sure it's Black
Canary so it's Black Canary huge company
300 275
300 about 300 by 275 bid 300 going what
275 about 300 and a quarter and a
quarter and a half and a half and a half
quarter and a half or a quarter three
and a half three and a half three
they're gonna be three and a half three
and a quarter but three and a half three
and a quarter but three and a half going
once three and a quarter but three and a
half going twice last call
sold 325 buyer number 10200 buyer number
200. uh number 124 really nice looking
page here issue 14 page 10 of Green
Arrow this is Oliver Queen getting
frustrated and thinking about beating
ass to find out what happened to his
kids so there's an image of him still in
the hospital but then there's all these
images of him green arrowing
199 200. we're not going to buy 2005
or two and a quarter two and a quarter
two and a quarter two and a quarter two
and a quarter two and a half two
recording about two minutes about two
fifty two twenty five two we're gonna
buy two twenty five two Fifteen by two
seventy five two if I get about two
seventy five two making about two
seventy five now three hundred about
three hundred about three hundred number
two seventy [__] about 300.75 300 275
300 about three hundred by two seventy
five and three hundred by two seventy
five bid 300 going what two seventy
pocket about three hundred dollars going
twice last call three and a quarter
three the corner about three twenty five
three fifty three twenty three picking
up three Wicket about three weekend
about three twenty pocket about three
picking number three twenty [__]
number three picking number three twenty
five bit three fifty going once
350 dollars going twice last call
325 buyer number 200 buyer number 100
100 buys lot 125 Green Arrow original R
issue 14 page 11. features the Green
Arrow family at least at that point in
the books of uh Oliver Queen Dina Lance
Black Canary and Mia deardon two and a
quarter two and a half two and a half
two and a half two and a quarter but two
and a half 275 275 number 275 to 300
about 300 about 300 by 300 by 300 275
about 300 275 about 300 275 300 about
300 by 300 by 300 by 300 by 302 75 and
300 275 300 275 300 by 300 by two seven
pocketed by three hundred by two seventy
five and three hundred two seventy
pocket about 300 275 300 by 300 by two
seventy five bid 300 275 bid 300 going
once 270 pocket about three hundred
dollars going twice last call
sold it for 275 dollars buyer number uh
let's see who bought that 200 buyer
number two hundred well 126 Green Arrow
issue 14 page 12.
uh features Ollie getting frustrated
after he talks to the doctor and decided
to do something still takes place the
hospital has Black Canary and Mia deer
didn't in it as well 199 200 two and a
quarter do it according to about two and
a quarter get about two and a quarter
two and a quarter two and a half two and
a half two and a half two and a half two
and a quarter of a two and a half what a
great image there on the left two and a
half two and a quarter get about two
minutes about two twenty five two by two
twenty five two making it up by two
twenty five two fifty two twenty we're
gonna buy two videos
two 25 by 250 dollars going twice last
call
two hundred and twenty five dollars to
buy our number 200 buyer number two
hundred one twenty seven Green Arrow
comic art issue 14 page 13. this
features onomatopoeia out of his costume
uh listening to a news report while it
gets ready in a hotel room uh so you can
kind of see the character a little bit
uh outside of his mask I got one Thirty
One forty one forty one fifty one fifty
one fifty one sixty one sixty one
seventy one seventy one eighty one
eighty one ninety one 91 99
225. 200 about two twenty pocket about
200 by two twenty pocket about 2002 25
going once 200 about 225 dollars going
twice last call
sold 200 wire number 200 buyer number
200. La 128 Green Arrow original art
issue 14 page 14.
uh this features Oliver Queen laying
down to donate blood to his kid uh
Connor Hawk who's still in surgery we're
still in the hospital on this issue as
well 181 91 91 91 81 91 91 90 180 190
191 90 180 190
18191 91 91 81 90. 108
91 81 91 91 81 91 81 91 81 90 going once
come on guys pay attention now hundred
and negative 119 going twice last call
so the hundred and eighty dollars a
buyer number 234 234
129 Green Arrow issue 14 page 15.
uh this is uh takes place at the
hospital and the last page is a very
creep image of onomatopoeia like just
walking around the hospital like Michael
Myers in Halloween too yeah it is very
creepy 171.81 91 91 91 91 81 91 91 91
81.90 180
1990 going once 100 negative a hundred
and ninety dollars going twice last call
sold 180 to 234 180 to 234. wow 130
Green Arrow issue 14 page 16. still in
the hospital I'll Ollie giving up blood
for his kid and in the final panel uh
final few panels you see Ollie taking a
sip from a juice box and he makes the
Sip noise and then onomatopoeia makes
the Sip noise as well because that's
onomatopoeia an example of onomatopoeia
right there so you got Oliver Queen and
you got an automatic p on your page as
well well fifty one sixty one sixty one
sixty one sixty one sixty one point
again one sixty hundred infinity
going once 100 Infinity dollars going
twice last call
150 a year buyer number 200 buyer number
200. La 131 Green Arrow issue 14 page
17. president leaving the hospital he's
strapping on his arrows he's going out
hunting for onomatopoeia
171.81 81 91 91
992 and a quarter two and a quarter two
and a quarter 200 about 225. 200 about
two twenty pocket about 2 25
2 25
250 250 275 two thinking about two
somebody [__] about two weeks about
two somebody [__] about two weeks
about two 75 going once 250 to get about
275 dollars going twice last call
so 250 dollars by our number 100 buyer
number 100. La 132 Green Arrow issue 14
page 18. more Hospital action you got a
page that has green arrow Black Canary
and there's uh onomatopoeia on the
bottom panel leaving after he's made
another kill 140 150 151 451 sixty one
sixty one sixty one sixty one sixty one
seventy one seventy one seventy one
seventy one seventy one eighty one
eighty one eighty one eighty one eighty
one ninety one ninety one ninety one
ninety one ninety one eighty one ninety
one ninety one ninety one eighty one
90.991 81 91 81 90 going once and you
get to see the aftermath of that kill
180 190 dollars going twice last call
180 200 180 200 not 133 Green Arrow
original comic guard issue 14 page 19.
uh this is onomatopoeia entering the
operating theater shooting a doctor and
then Black Canary who's watching from
the viewing window upstairs uses her uh
Sonic screw to break the glass and
onomatopoeia repeats it 130 141 41 41 31
forty one forty one fifty one fifty one
fifty one fifty one fifty one fifty one
fifty one forty one fifty one sixty one
sixty one sixty one sixty one sixty one
sixty one seventy one seventy one
seventy one seventy one seventy one
seventy one eighty one eighty one eighty
one eighty one seventy one eighty one
eighty one eighty one seventy one eighty
one eighty one eighty one seventy one
eighty one seventy one eighty one eighty
one seventy one eighty one eighty one
seventy one eighty one seventy one
eighty one seventy one eighty one
eighty going what's 190 19191 ninety one
eighty one ninety one ninety one ninety
one eighty one ninety one ninety ninety
one about 200 by 200. We're not gonna
buy 2005
going once hundred and ninety but 200
hours going twice last call
hundred and ninety dollars to two
hundred a hundred and ninety dollars to
two hundred uh 134 Green Arrow issue 14
page twenty lot going on here lots of
Black Canary and onomatopoeia fighting
action uh a gorgeous page featuring uh
beautiful shots to the characters from
The
storyline's Costume like all the blacks
on it just it really pops off it's Inked
really nicely so that you could the
blacks are really deep rich blacks I got
300 and three and a quarter three
hundred by three twenty pocket about 300
about three twenty [__] about three
hundred about three twenty [__]
number three hundred about three twenty
five three hacking about three twenty
pocket about three hundred about three
twenty [__] about three hundred about
three twenty [__] about three hundred
about three twenty five going once 300
about 325 going twice last call
sold 300 wire number 200 buyer number
two hundred lot 135 more action here
with green arrow issue 14 page 21. uh
and this is uh him about to shoot Conor
hawk in the head but instead he gets
shot in the arm with an arrow from an
off uh page uh Oliver Queen Green Arrow
uh and of course you've got Black Canary
in there as well lots of action in this
page 275 not 300 275 300 about 300 about
three hundred about three and a quarter
three and a quarter three and a quarter
three hundred about three twenty five
three fifty are you picking about 300
about 35
350 375. read somebody [__] number
three somebody [__] by three picking
number three somebody pocket about three
weekend about three seventy five we're
picking about three seventy pocket about
three weeks about three seventy pocket
about 35
going once 350 but 375 going twice last
call
sold 350 buyer number 100 buyer number
one hundred very cool Cliffhanger face
off on this page lot 136 Green Arrow
issue 14 page 22. here's the last page
in the issue and just a splash page uh
there's an inset uh panel of uh
onomatopoeia close-up then the rest of
it is Green Arrow shirtless coming
through that door with arrows in his
hand ready to knock another uh uh arrow
in his from his quiver into his bow and
uh over onomatopoeia is a shocked
onomatopoeia's shoulders beautiful page
five hiking about five and a quarter
five I get about five and a quarter five
and a quarter five and a quarter five I
get about five twenty pocket about five
twenty pocket about 550. pick it up a
five seventy five five
double fines
about 600.75 600.75 600 600 six and a
quarter six and a quarter six and a
quarter
going once 600 by 625 hours in time 650.
next 25 minutes
six twenty five bid 650 going once 6 25
656.75 650 by 675 650
pocket about six make it about six
seventy five building what's now 700 700
700 700 pocket about 700 by 700 by six
seventy five seven hundred by six
seventy five bid 700 going what six
seventy five bit seven hundred dollars
going twice last call seven and a
quarter seven twenty five seven twenty
pocket about seven twenty pocket about
700.7 2500 by 725 going once seven
twenty pocket about seven fifty seven
twenty [__] about seven fifty do it
again seven fifty Seven fifty Seven
fifty seven twenty five and seven fifty
seven twenty seven I'm gonna buy seven
thirty seven seventy five don't let them
have it now 775 come on back now seven
seventy five seven fifty Seven seventy
five do it again 775
going once 7 75 and about 800 hours
going twice if we learned anything the
last page of the of each uh thing does
better that's true yeah that last page
800 eight and a quarter eight a quarter
by eight a quarter eight a quarter eight
hundred and eight twenty pocket of eight
hundred away twenty five eight hundred
away twenty five eight hundred away
twenty five going once 850 850 8 25
gonna make it away twenty five bit eight
fifty going once eight twenty bucket of
eight hundred and fifty dollars going
twice last call oh boy 875 875 making me
work now 8.75 I'm in overtime 875. he's
thinking about 8.75 75
going once 858 75 now 900 900 don't let
them have it 900 900 900 875 number 900
number 9008 7500 number nine a quarter
nine a quarter nine a quarter nine a
quarter nine twenty five nine twenty
[__] number nine twenty five nine
hundred number nine twenty five number
nine hundred number nine twenty five
going once
900 about 9 25 going twice don't miss
out for 25 more dollars you started the
whole thing let's go let's go
900 thank you both permitting Meyer
number 200 buyer number 200.
137 the first issue first page rather of
the next issue issue 15 page one uh
picks up just where we left off with uh
Oliver holding a knocked Arrow at
onomatopoeia and uh as he looked ask the
dog if the doctor's still alive in the
room I got 140.50
170 170.160 180 180 180 180 190 190 190
190 180
190.99
about 225 200 about two twenty pocket
about 200 about two twenty pocket about
200 about two twenty Pockets about
250.50 by two twenty pocket about 250.50
let's call
225 200 buyer number 200.
138 Green Arrow original art issue 15
page two insinuation of the same scene
Oliver Queen holding his knocked arrow
on onomatopoeia talking to the doctors
about his son's condition in this uh
standoff 450 bit 475 what if I get about
forward somebody talking about four
Vegas about 475. we'll forget about four
everybody talking about forget about
Ford somebody pocket about before we get
about four somebody pocket about four
picking about 475. we'll get them up
forward somebody talking about four
freaking about four somebody pocket
about four freaking about 475 going once
pay attention now who are picking about
475 going twice last call
415 Meyer number 100 buyer number 200
buyer number two hundred uh 139 issue 15
page three of Kevin Smith's Green Arrow
you got green arrow you got Black Canary
you got onomatopoeia and a continuation
of the same scene a lot of dialogue
bubbles kids if you're into chemical
dialogue this is an ideal page to have
very inexpensive 150 160 170 170 170 170
one somebody one two one somebody one
somebody one six me one something one
eighty one eighty one eighty one eighty
one eighty one seventy one eighty one
eighty one seventy one eighty one eighty
one seventy one eighty one seventy one
eighty one eighty one seventy one eighty
eighty going what's 100 and somebody
been 180 dollars going twice last call
sold 170 buyer number uh 200 buyer
number 200.
140 Green Arrow issue 15 page four
it is
um you've got lots of Green Arrow and
onomatopoeia action lots of close-up
shots of all the two of them yeah this
is a really classy looking kind of page
right yeah really symmetrical yes four
and a quarter four and a half 475 or
somebody talking about four somebody
pocket about five [__] about five
hundred bucks a quarter five and a
quarter five and a quarter five and a
quarter wow
255 75 575 575
600.60
and a quarter six and a quarter six and
a quarter six and a half six and a half
I'm gonna buy six and a half I'm gonna
buy six figures about six fifty six
twenty five into my six fifty
going once six seventy five but seven
hundred dollars going twice in a quarter
seven and a quarter seven and a quarter
seven a quarter seven a quarter seven a
quarter seven a quarter seven a quarter
seven a quarter seven and a half another
quarter with seven and a half seven and
a quarter seven a hand seven hands up in
the corner and some of the hands up in a
quarter mid seven and a half going what
seven and a quarter mid seven and a half
going twice seven seventy five seven
seventy five seven seventy five seven
seventy five seven fifteen about seven
seventy five now 800 800 800 800
77500 going what seven seventy five
gonna be eight hundred dollars going
twice last call
sold 775 buyer number 200 buyer number
100 buyer number 100. yeah Kevin I can
definitely see why they used
onomatopoeia it's like that's such a
great design the mask too they actually
they met they nailed the mask in the
Superman aloha show I thought it'll look
pretty cool yeah it's really something
141 Green Arrow issues 15 page five uh
so this is Green Arrow uh threatening
onomatopoeia tell him he doesn't give a
[__] what he's there for he tells him to
lift his mask up to his nose because
he's gonna put the arrow right in his
mouth and hold but not while they
operate on his son all right 270
pocketed by 300 three and a quarter
three and a quarter about three and a
quarter three and a quarter three and a
half three and a quarter to three and a
half three the quarter been three and a
half good about three we get about three
weekend about three making about three
make it about three fifty get about
three seventy five three seven three
seventy five we're picking it about
three seventy pocket about 350 by three
75375 375 going once 350 375
going twice last call
sold 375 dollars buyer number 100 buyer
number 100.
142. Green Arrow issue 15 page six uh
Green Arrow sticks this arrow and
onomatopoeia's mouth very homoerotic
page kids
delightful uh to look at and uh it's uh
pretty cool move of Green Arrow to stick
his arrow and some dude's mouth
it's really like a badass it's kind of
just like he just takes it yeah yeah
very stoic yeah three hundred by three
and a quarter three and a quarter three
how to get about three twenty five are
you talking about three twenty [__]
about 350.25
350. three pick it up three twenty
[__] number three picking number
three twenty [__] number three
picking number three twenty pocket about
three figures about three twenty five
three fifty going once reach 21 about
350 dollars going twice last call
sold 325 buyer number 100 buyer number
100 200 rather
143 Green Arrow 15. this is Page seven
uh this is the title page to the issue
uh so you've got uh green arrow and a
hospital bed in the background the Conor
Hall Career great you got the uh Oliver
Queen green arrow on the foreground uh
with his shaft in the mouth of
onomatopoeia which is exactly as dirty
as I meant to kids
is a splash pitch that's a splash page
and a half right there splashing dirty
650 675 650 get about 675
675 now
700.75 700 something like a quarter
seven a quarter seven a quarter seven a
quarter seven and a quarter no I'm gonna
buy seven twenty pocketed by
750.75
75 775 775 75 75 now 800 800 800 775 and
800.75 and a quarter in a quarter eight
a quarter eight a quarter eight a
quarter eight a quarter eight according
to eight hundred eight and a half eight
a quarter of an eight and a half eight a
quarter million
eight fifty going once this is a great
page guys don't miss out 8.75 8.75. hey
pick it up by
875.75. you're thinking about eight
seventy five eight seventy five not nine
hundred now I hook it up at 900 number
900 75 900 875
a quarter nine a quarter nine a quarter
nine a quarter number nine twenty five
hundred number nine twenty five hundred
number nine twenty five number nine
hundred number nine twenty five going
once 900 about 925 going twice last call
900 wire number 200 buyer number 200.
144 Green Arrow issue 15 page eight uh
this show uh page shows the past time
and uh Oliver Queen keeps uh on the
mouth of onomatopoeia and the operation
goes on until the bottle the bottom the
doctor says that Conor's gonna be fine
two and a half 275 two we get about two
75 in about two weeks about two 75
275. you're making it 25.300 about 300
by 275 300. 300 three and a quarter
three and a quarter three and a quarter
either one of you come on back now three
and a quarter three hundred about three
and a quarter three and a half three and
a half three and a half three and a half
come on back on three fifty get about
three good about three big about three
twenty pocket about three fifty three
knocking about three fifty three twenty
pocket about three pick it up three
twenty pocket number three picking up by
three twenty five three fifty three
seventy five three seventy five three
three seventy five now four hundred four
hundred for each other pocket about 400
400 going once 400 yeah four and a
quarter welcome to my four twenty five
we're talking about four twenty five
we're talking about four twenty [__]
about four hundred about four twenty
pocket about four hundred about four
twenty five going once we're talking
about four twenty five going twice last
call
400 200 400 200 Lot number 145 Green
Arrow issue 15 page nine what was the
image oh there we go so here's the what
happens uh automatically appoints the
arrow and rips it away rips it away from
Green Arrow and then flips backwards uh
to a speed so a lot of action going yeah
there's a lot of action on that page
it's great 353.75 400. we're talking
about 400 about 400 about three seventy
five four hundred number four and a
quarter four and a quarter four and a
quarter four and a quarter four hundred
and four and a quarter we'll hook it up
on four twenty pocket about 400 number
four twenty pocket about four hundred
about four twenty five we're talking
about four twenty pocket about four
twenty [__] about four fifty four
twenty about 450. we're gonna buy four
pick it up four pick it up four pick it
up four fifty four seventy five four
seventy five four seventy five four
picking it about 475. we'll pick it up
four seven four we get about four seven
five to five hundred
number four seven [__] about five
[__] number four seven [__] about
five I get about four seventy [__]
about 500. what's everybody [__]
number five [__] number four somebody
[__] number five
going twice last call
sold 555 buyer number to 100 buyer
number 100. so Kevin do we ever learn
these secret origin of onomatopoeia we
never did I never did that story yet so
you haven't do you have it written in
your head or
cool um but I've not brought it to the
comics yet but uh yeah he's he's a uh of
non-super powered uh Vigilantes so he
goes after the Batmans and the green
arrows of this world okay cool uh this
is uh lot 146 kids that means there's
only 30 Lots yeah we're getting there
man that's it we're almost there yeah
we're almost there if they bid fast
I'm gonna tell you right now if they bid
fast I can get it done in about 40
minutes otherwise it might be out kids
been fast that's right
this is green irresponsibly kids yeah
sir I like it bid in responsibly that's
right I'm gonna use that I like it Green
Arrow issue 15 page 10. four and a
quarter four and a half four and a
quarter get about four and a half you
know about four we get about four fifty
number four forget about four picking
about four twenty pocket about 450.
we're trying to look at about 450. we're
getting about four making about four
making about four make it about four
twenty five four five four twenty pocket
number four picking number four twenty
five bid 450 going once we're trying to
get about 450 dollars going twice last
call
so 425 buyer number uh 200 buyer number
200. La 147 Green Arrow issue 15 page
11. more Green Arrow versus onomatopoeia
action lots of fight action in this page
three and a quarter three and a half
three according to get about three and a
half good about three and a half 375 375
375 35
400. reach over to [__] about 400.75
400.75 400 about four and a quarter four
and a quarter four and a half four and a
half four and a quarter been four and a
half four and a half quarter could have
been four and a half half half four and
a quarter before and a half four and a
half four seventy five four seven pocket
up a 500
47500.75
500.75 475 made 500 going once horse
everybody talking about 500 going twice
last call
sold 450 dollars a year by our number
one 200 200 buys and there really are
lots of great onomatopoeias all over
these Pages
a lot of fun uh here you got another
page uh lot uh 148 man this is issue 15
page 12. more green arrow fighting
onomatopoeia action so if you're an
action junkie if you like your comic
books with less words on the pages this
is the page for you look at that look at
that action that was me yeah the words
are sounds that's it right three and a
quarter of a three and a half three
quarter good about three and a half good
about three million three making about
three somebody pocket about three
somebody pocket about 375. we're
thinking about three seventy five now
four hundred three somebody pocket about
400 number four and a quarter four and a
quarter four and a quarter four and a
quarter four hundred about four and a
quarter four hundred about four twenty
pocket about four pocket about four
twenty five we're talking about four
twenty pocket number four that's
probably why I like comic books so much
because it was less reading you know
yeah that's how I liked it four and a
quarter of it four and a quarter four
hundred about four and a quarter a real
book no I don't
25 going twice last call
sold for 400 the buyer number 100 buyer
number 100. La 149 Green Arrow issue 15
page 13. guess what's Happening Here
green arrows fighting onomatopoeia man
the whole issue is getting lit up he's
getting killed man uh Green Arrow shoots
him with a bunch of [__] arrows man
so if you ever wanted to own some
artwork where some [__] getting
pin cushioned by another guy with a long
bow this is the page for you kids three
hundred about three and a quarter three
and a half half three and a half three
seventy five three seven to five now
400.375 400 about 400 about three
seventy pocket about
400.753 70 pocket about 400. reach
everybody
pocket about 400. read somebody pocket
about 400. read somebody [__] about
400 about 375 bid 400 going once read
somebody pocket about 400 going twice
last call
375 200 375 to 200. another fun action
page here lot 150 Green Arrow issue 15
page 14. uh this is some rooftop action
kids comic book characters always wind
up fighting on rooftops and uh here's
onomatopoeia and green arrow going out
on rooftop including an action shot a
continuation of motion shot of uh Green
Arrow dive and tucking and rolling and
jumping off the roof of a building yeah
that's really great that's what that's
called the continuation of motion shot
yeah yeah it's really cool 404 and a
quarter four and a quarter four and a
quarter four and a half and a half 475.
what's up everybody [__] about four
picking up forward somebody talking
about four picking up 475. we'll pick it
up on four somebody pocket about four
pick it up four somebody pocket about
four pick it up four everybody get about
four seventy five going once 450 bid 475
not 500 not five and a quarter five and
a quarter five and a quarter five and a
quarter five and a quarter five hundred
about five twenty five five twenty
pocket about five pocket about five
twenty pocket about five [__] about
five twenty five going once five [__]
about 525 going twice last call
so 500 wire number 200 buyer number two
hundred lot 151 even more action Green
Arrow issue 15 page 15. Green Arrow
leaps off the roof to escape
Proof of Life
spoilers he lives two and a half two
seventy five three hundred three hundred
number three hundred by three hundred by
three hundred about three hundred by
three hundred by three hundred by two
seventy pocket about 300. 303 and a
quarter three and a quarter three and a
quarter three and a half three the
quarterback three and a half three fifty
three fifty three seventy five you're
picking about three seventy pocket about
three seventy five four hundred about
four hundred number three seventy
[__] about 400.75
400.30 about four hundred by three
seventy five bid 400 going once reach
everybody pocket about four hundred
dollars going twice last call
sold 375 to 200 375 200.
152 issue 15 Green Arrow page 16 some
more violence yeah Green Arrow you
didn't die when he jumped off that
building he was clinging on to the side
like they do an action movie and then he
comes over the top and stabs on a
metapia's foot in the narrow to get some
ground 200 about two and a quarter two
and a half two and a half two and a half
two and a half two and it would have
been two and a half
275 275
250 25
300.75 300.75 300 three and a quarter
three and a quarter three and a quarter
three hundred about three twenty five
three hundred about three twenty [__]
about three hundred about three twenty
[__] number three hundred number
three twenty five going once three
hundred about three Johnny pocket number
three picking number three picking about
three twenty pocket about 350.
350.3 picking about three picking about
three twenty five twenty five three
twenty five bit three fifty going once
75 going twice last call
sold 315 higher number 200 buyer number
two hundred lot 153 continuing the
action and green arrow issue 15 page 17.
more fighty fight kids lots of it look
at that look at all that action more
action you could shake a stick at what
we're getting down to the end ladies and
gentlemen there's not much left so if
you didn't buy one yet and you wanted
one Now's the Time to get in don't miss
out 300 three and a quarter 300 by three
twenty pocket about 300 about three
twenty pocket about three hundred number
three twenty [__] about 350. are you
picking about three we get about three
pick it up three picking about three
make it about three make it about three
twenty pocket about three fifty three
twenty five three thinking about three
make it about three twenty five bid
three fifty going once return okay about
315 going twice last call
sold 325 a buyer number 1200 buyer
number 200. uh 154 Green Arrow issue 15
page 18. uh this is automaticia getting
ready to make his Escape uh he's been uh
pinned in place by uh green arrows uh
everyone's foot but this guy's choosing
to uh push against the building and rip
his foot out of the arrow and uh in fall
on face Justice two and a quarter two
and a half yeah 275 275
300.30
by two seventy five bit three hundred
going once don't miss out there's only a
few left two 75 and 300 hours going
twice last call
275 buyer number 200 buyer number two
hundred now 155 Green Arrow issue 15
page 19. uh this is uh the fate of
onomatopoeia look at him
[Music]
uh rather than Facebook Green Arrow
maybe he dies oh man he showed up in
another Batman minifigure as I did years
later there you go two and a half 275.
too many pocket about two weeks
everybody
and a quarter three and a quarter three
hundred about three twenty [__] about
three hundred about three twenty [__]
about three hundred by three twenty five
three fifty three twenty [__] about
three make it about three make it about
three twenty [__] about three make it
about three twenty [__] about three
[__] about three twenty five bit
three fifty three twenty five bit three
fifty going once three twenty [__]
about three hundred and fifteen dollars
going twice last call
sold 325 higher number 200 buyer number
200.156 is Page 20 of Green Arrow 15.
this is a great image only 20 Lots left
kids uh this is almost the end of the
comic book here
um it's the day new mop we go after math
for green arrows explaining to his son
Connor Hawk what happened with
onomatopoeia and we're seeing on I'm
going to be that's his body yeah he's
plummeting and kind of a rendition of
his mask yeah it looks like his own mask
really cool very cool art 202 and a
quarter two and a quarter two and a
quarter two and a quarter two and a half
two and a half two and a half two and a
quarter of a two and a half two weeks
about two seventy five two thinking
about two somebody [__] about too big
into my two somebody [__] about two
weeks about two seven five two million
about 275 now 300. who's somebody
talking about 300.75 300 about 300 about
300 by 270 pocket about 300 by 2 75 bid
300 going once
275 bit 300 hours going twice last call
sold 275 dollars to 200 buyer number
200. La 157 the next last page of Green
Arrow issue 15. this is Page 21. taking
the last page features Oliver Queen uh
Dinah Lance uh who's the Black Canary uh
Mia dearden and Connor Hawk all in the
hospital room no costumes 150 you want
to take you 170 170 170 170 170 170 170
170 181.80 181 81 81 81 81 91 91 91
995 200 about two twenty pocket about
200 about two twenty five two hundred
about two twenty pocket about 200 about
2 25 going once 200 about 225 hours
going twice last call in time 250 22
240. 225
bit 250 going once two 25 250 going
twice last call sold 225 to 200 buyer
number 200. here's the last page of the
book lot
158 Green Arrow 15 page 22. uh Paige the
book and this might be the final Green
Arrow piece of artwork I think so I
think there's one last piece at the end
but yes copy you here you go kids this
is your last chance by the final page of
the book page 22.
190 200 2 and a quarter yep two and a
half 275. 275 number two 75 300 300 300
300 come on back now 300 275 300. 300
about 300 three and a quarter three and
a quarter three and a quarter three and
a half three and a half three and a half
three they're going to be three and a
half three according to get about three
and a half get by three big enough about
three weekend about 350.3 pick it up by
three we get about three twenty pocket
about three fifty three seventy five
three seventy five 375 400 400 430 70
pocket about four hundred four and a
quarter four and a quarter four and a
half quarter could have been four and a
half four and a half four seventy five
four seventy five four seventy five not
five hundred five hundred five hundred
fourteen [__] about five [__]
about five hundred about five hundred
about five okay about five
[__] about four seventy five and five
hundred either five and a quarter five
and a quarter five hundred by five
twenty five five [__] about five
twenty [__] about five hundred number
five twenty five going once five [__]
number five twenty five glowing twice in
a quarter and a half quarter and a half
half seventy five
seventy five
about six twenty five going twice last
call
yep and a half
six and a half six and a half yep 675
will be 675 675
675 picking about 675
675 going once 650 bit 675 going twice
last call you came all this way one more
time yep of course 700 seven a quarter
seven and a quarter do it again 700
rather six seventy five now seven
hundred six seventy five and seven
hundred six seventy five it's 700 seven
and a quarter seven and a quarter
remember this is the last page it's been
historically in this sale every last
page does more money come on now this
was your last was this your last book
writing in the series too yeah this is
my last uh green arrow that I wrote
except uh when I put them into the
Batman books that I did but this is the
last issue of Green Arrow yes
page of Kevin's Run This is the End
right here guys this should bring ten
thousand let's go uh
seven twenty five going twice last call
in time 750. have a 25
7 25 and 750 going once seven twenty
[__] about seven fifty going twice
seven seventy five nice little bidding
war let's go 775 don't let them have it
now 775 he came all this way this is one
of those times you're gonna go you know
what I should have just went one more
time 775 7.7 70 pocket about seven
seventy pocket about seven five seven
seventy five going once seven fifty but
775 going twice last call
775 800 800 800 it didn't close out 800
eight and a quarter make them pay now
eight and a quarter hit it again eight
and a quarter eight and a quarter bit
faster guys eight and a quarter eight a
quarter gonna buy eight a quarter and a
quarter eight hundred by eight twenty
five eight hundred away twenty five
eight hundred away twenty five going
once 800 by 825 going twice last call
sold 800 thank you both forbidding Meyer
number 100 buyer number 100. Lot number
159 this was a another one of the pieces
that Eric and I really had trouble
locating exactly what this was and
figuring out
um exactly what it was it was from the
heroes poster uh book The pinup book
that Marvel did uh 911 tribute they did
a bunch of pieces inside that were more
focused on firefighters and First
Responders than superheroes so like you
could see in this panel in this page
um you know you got Spider-Man on the
wall you got Captain America on the wall
uh but there's kids are dressed like
firefighters and deep in the background
you could see the Flames from September
11th okay
nine and a quarter but nine and a half
nine a quarter of it nine I have number
nine minutes
thousand dollars thousand numbers
fourteen hundred fourteen hundred
thirteen hundred and fourteen hundred
thirteen hundred about fourteen hundred
about fourteen hundred about thirteen
hundred about fourteen hundred thirteen
I'll get about 1400 about 1400 about
thirteen hundred about fourteen hundred
by Thirteen hundred about fourteen
hundred going once thirteen hundred and
fourteen hundred dollars going twice
last call
thirteen hundred dollars by our number
two hundred buyer number two hundred
lot 160. here is two consecutive pages
of Superman original comic art nice from
a book called world's finest that DC did
years ago that Steve Rue did all the
Interiors for oh like though those like
else worlds The Prestige format it
wasn't it wasn't meant to be an
elsewhere though it took place I think
in the continuity okay but it was if I
remember correctly at least two books I
think but uh Steve Rood is an absolute
legend in the field and his rendition of
of Batman and Superman uh are
unparalleled and this these two pages is
mostly Superman and Lex Luthor yeah
Superman who's hanging outside Lex
Luthor's window at lexcorp Tower and Lex
Luthor throws a globe at the window that
shatters and Superman smiles and then
flies away really nice pair of pages
that I framed because I love them so
much back when I was working on the
Superman screenplay in 96.
or 97 97. all right 1600 bit 1700 1600
about 1700 1700 1700 1600 and 1700 1600
1700 1579
1600 and 1700 going once
sixteen hundred and Seventeen hundred
dollars going twice last call
sixteen hundred dollars to buy our
number 200 buyer number two hundred lot
161 we have an original cover here for
Detective Comics
762s of the penciler John McRae the
anchor James Hodgkins and McRae of
course did uh the Hitman we sold a
bunches earlier this evening uh here's
Batman and uh spoiler I believe is that
who that is up in the air with him I
believe so yeah
2324 23 talking about twenty four
hundred number twenty four hundred
twenty three hundred and twenty four
hundred twenty three hundred by twenty
four hundred about twenty five hundred
twenty five hundred about twenty six
hundred twenty six hundred six hundred
twenty seven hundred twenty seven
hundred twenty seven hundred twenty
seven hundred what do you say talking
about 2700 by 2600 by 2700 wait 600 by
2700 2600 by 2700 2600 about 2700 by
2600 by 2700 going once doesn't get
better than buying a cover that's if you
know if you only can buy one piece of a
comic of course you want it to be the
cover yeah no absolutely
2017 my 2700 going once twenty six
hundred about twenty seven hundred
dollars going twice last call
sold 2600 wire number 200 buyer number
two hundred
lot 162. uh these are Peter baggy that's
how you pronounce his name right back
yeah did a book called hate for years
and years uh wonderful book and he's an
amazing comic book artist he did this
Spider-Man book for Mar years ago and
these two pages are from that so this is
Peter bagg doing Peter Parker that's why
we yeah that's why we couldn't find it
Eric and I must have spent like a couple
hours we were looking through scans of
all the hate issues by Peter Beck trying
to figure out
it's actually on Marvel paper so they
brought him in to do an issue of of
Spider-Man I forget what it was called
but I got two pages from it because that
was such a big Peter bag fan
yeah you know they reached out to him
originally to do the Mallrats poster oh
really yeah yeah cool we eventually Got
Juice true's end so we it was an
embarrassment of riches in that
situation of course everybody talking
about 500 five and a quarter five and a
quarter five and a quarter five and a
quarter five and a half five and a half
five and a half five and a half High
seventy five I-75 575
600.75 you're talking about six and a
quarter six and a quarter six and a
quarter six and a half six and a half
six and a quarter six and a half six
seventy five six seventy pocket about
six seventy five now seven hundred seven
hundred seven hundred six seventy pocket
about 700.75 700 seven and a quarter
seven and a quarter seven a quarter
seven a quarter seven a quarter yeah
seven and a half seven and a half seven
and a half seven and a half seven and a
half seven and a half seven seventy five
seven seventy five seven seventy five
seven figures about seven seventy five
seven seven five seven seventy five I'm
thinking about seven seventy five eight
hundred eight hundred eight hundred
eight hundred seven seventy pocket about
800.75 800 going
once Eleven Hundred by twelve hundred
dollars in time thirteen hundred dollars
thirteen hundred by Thirteen hundred
thirteen hundred twelve hundred thirteen
hundred thirteen hundred fourteen
hundred fourteen hundred fourteen
hundred thirteen hundred about fourteen
hundred going once thirteen hundred
about fourteen hundred dollars going
twice last call
sold thirteen hundred dollars higher
number 200 thank you both for bidding
buyer number two hundred lot 163. Kevin
if you could uh tell us the story behind
this Frank Miller Sketchbook photocopy
you have this is a Sketchbook that uh we
had uh sold at uh fundraiser September
11th fundraiser uh that uh Nick the guy
who runs Dynamic force is one and then
he gave it to me uh it's the signatures
by Frank Miller but it's a study
character study for Sin City if you open
it up take it out the bag and you could
flip it open and kind of show people
what it looks like inside but it's
basically this book that is Frank I
guess put together and then signed and
they put it out for auction but you
could see inside a series of sketches he
did of his characters from Sin City his
Sin City work is so just iconic and cool
and like inimitable it can only be Frank
Miller agree that did those what's cool
about that you get behind the mind of
him actually drawing and stuff like that
in that Sketchbook you know this is
crazy rare they never published it or
anything like that right so there you go
the only way you're gonna get it is
right here I got 500. kids you want to
show that off what's inside
here he comes
there you go almost there there you go
now there's some great stuff in there
check out the images that are in there
and the sketches that are fantastic
five and a quarter five and a half 575.
fine 755
575. you have a loved one who collects
comics and they have everything this is
the type of thing that you get them
because they don't have this
that is true 575 now 600 yep six and a
quarter six and a quarter get about six
and a quarter about six in the corners
they're talking about six in the corner
is it coming about six in the corners
six and a half yeah six and a half six
seventy five six seventy pocket about
six seventy five six seven five six
seventy five six fifteen about six
seventy five six five six seven five six
five six seven five six about six
seventy five six fifty gonna buy Six
seventy five six make it about six
seventy five six seventy five now seven
hundred seven and a quarter seven a
quarter seven a quarter seven hundred by
seven a quarter no I'm gonna buy seven
twenty pocket about seven hundred by
seven twenty five twenty five seven
fifty yeah about seven fifty Seven
seventy five I'm thinking about seven
seventy five seven seven seventy five
seven seven eight hundred eight hundred
eight and a quarter eight a quarter
eight a quarter eight hundred by eight
twenty five eight hundred by eight
twenty five hundred and eight twenty
five hundred away twenty five eight
hundred number eight twenty five hundred
away twenty five hundred away twenty
five going once eight hundred by eight
twenty five going twice last call
sold eight hundred dollars nice buy
buyer number 200 buyer number two
hundred
this is fresh off the press yes well
164. Kevin just autographed this right
in front of me
when you make movies they put directors
chairs up and they put these backings on
them so everybody gets one uh this was
because I was director and and an actor
in the movie and a writer and stuff so
I've had this since so 2001 so it's 22
years old sign and it could be yours if
the price was right there you go another
true Just One of a Kind artifact there
600 by six and a quarter six and a half
six and a half because
56 75 675
675 now 700 700 700 675
700 by 6 70 pocketed by 700.75 700.75
700.675 now 700. where are you gonna get
one ladies and gentlemen this isn't
something like you just signed it's his
this was his director's chair from the
uh movie guy 700 seven and a quarter
seven and a quarter seven and a quarter
seven and a quarter seven and a half
seven and a half keep that in mind
nobody has this this is not like a
reproduced thing this is what he used he
sat there in it through the movie Eye
750 bit 775. I'm thinking about 775
775 a lot of sweat there I'm sure yeah
that's right you could clone me from the
DNA in that chair that's great
750.75
775 going one seven seventy five now 800
800 800 come on back now 800 800 775
being 800 going once 775 been eight
hundred dollars going twice last call
sold 775 dollars the buyer number 200
buyer number 200.
165. this is uh just about to be
autographed by Kevin here this is his
director chair back for Southland tail I
was an actor in Southland Tales directed
by Richard Kelly and so I've had my
chair back of course ever since I
finished and right now I'm gonna tag my
name over my name there you go two and a
quarter by two and a half two and a
quarter in about two and a half get
about two weeks about two weeks about
two minutes
about two twenty [__] about 250 225
250. new 2500 by 250. new 25
minutes about two seventy five two
thinking about two seven five two
picking up my twins
275 275 300.75 300 three and a quarter
three and a quarter three and a quarter
three and a quarter three hundred number
three twenty pocket number three hundred
number three twenty five three hundred
number three twenty five he has he had a
black one up there that we were using or
it's right here 325 3003 25 300 about
three twenty [__] about three hundred
about three twenty five three hundred
number three twenty pocket about three
hundred by three twenty pocket about
three hundred about three twenty five
going once 300 by 325 going twice last
call yep
and I have three and a half three and a
quarter but three and a half half three
and a quarter but three and a half three
and a quarter but three and a half read
a quarter of three and a half once again
this is not something you could just get
this is something that you have to be uh
in yeah you had to be on that movie and
your name had to be Kevin Smith in order
to get that chair back exactly that's
what I'm saying man there ain't nothing
else in the world like it now I'm just
curious do they just issue one or do you
have multiples or just one just one that
when you're done in the movie they give
it to you wow just one guys this is just
one of one think about that one of one
my goodness let's go 300 about three and
a quarter three and a half three
according to three and a half three and
a quarter but three and a half three and
a quarter but three and a half going
once guess it wasn't in budget for two
huh yeah going over three and a half
going twice last call
yes three and a half 375 just got in
there three and a half and 375. maybe
get about three seventy five three
picking up on three seventy pocket about
350 number three seventy pocket about
three fifteen about three seventy five
going once yeah
400.75 about
400.375 bid 400 going once reach 70
pocket about four hundred dollars going
twice last call
sold 375 buyer number 200 buyer number
200. La 165 from Zach and Mary mcporno
this is Kevin Smith's director chair
back about to be signed right in front
of you again folks this is a true one of
one I didn't write you directed that
movie I did I did and they put my name
director on the chair so I knew where to
sit I'm gonna sign this right up top
it is a great movie that that yes it's a
great movie yep six and a half 675 700
700 one of one guy seven hundred seven
and a quarter seven and a half seven and
a half seven and a half seven seven
fifty one up one seven fifty yeah
seven five seven fifty seven twenty five
in about seven fifty seven twenty five
seven fifty seven twenty five seven
figures about seven twenty pocket about
seven pick it up at 7 25 bid 750 going
once 720 pocketed by 750 going twice
last call
sold 725 here buyer number 200 buyer
number 200.
167. this is Kevin's director chair back
for yoga hosers
producer oh sorry producer so you could
tell people I produced yoga hosers but
why you would want to do that I have no
idea I'm gonna sign it on the yoga hoser
side for you right now putting it under
the name of the movie there you go three
and a quarter three and a half a three
and a half 375 375 400 number three
seventy [__] number four hundred
number three seventy [__] about four
hundred three [__] about four hundred
about four hundred about four hundred
about four hundred about three seventy
five now four hundred four and a quarter
what according to about four and a
quarter four and a quarter four and a
quarter four hundred about four twenty
five we're talking about 425. we're
talking about four twenty pocket about
400 number four twenty pocket about four
hundred about four twenty five going
once
that is a different lot well that's that
was from uh um uh
from the from Michael's estate yep four
twenty [__] about 450. which one
don't get about four picking up a four
twenty [__] about four figures about
four twenty five bid 450 going once
what's 25 about 415 going twice last
call
sold 425 buyer number 200 buyer number
200 so this lot ladies and gentlemen
this spot and the next three lots
actually came from the estate that we
sold this morning this morning we sold
it a state of comic books and he had a
so yeah first of all he loved Kevin
Smith and was one of your favorite fans
and he actually had a tattoo on his uh I
believe on a spy right and uh he did
pass away and we did said it would be
better just to put the three lots in
here as a tribute to him uh because we
knew it would do better with all the
fans watching so this is what's coming
up here so I don't want anyone to think
this is not the script you owned yes
this is not my script so this is a
Clerk's movie script but I did sign it
yes
um for Michael back in the day there you
go five and a quarter five and a half
yeah five and a half I-75 575 600.60
[__] devices
or six and a quarter six and a quarter
six twenty five six twenty five six
twenty pocket of my six hundred about
six twenty five six hundred by six
twenty five gonna buy six hundred by six
twenty five six hundred by six twenty
five going once all right now folks
Michael's stuff that we sold before
didn't exactly
um go through the roof price wise so if
some of you maybe if you have a little
bit of extra money and you're looking to
kind of do like a nice thing for the
family for the family here if you could
bid some extra money at this maybe more
than you'd be willing to pay on these
next few lots that might help to ease
the family's pain in their grief a
little bit because they they did lose
their son and his stuff you know did not
he was young too yes yes he was a very
very young man
um
you know he uh he he he got sick and I'm
sure that they would appreciate if
people uh exactly did bid really hard on
these couple things 600 gonna buy six
and a quarter six and a quarter six
hundred about six twenty five six
hundred by six twenty five going once
did coconut by 6 25 going twice last
call
600 hours wire number 234 234. Lot
number 169 this is an autographed
Clerk's framed print subscribed to Mike
you can include signatures from Kevin
Smith J Muse Brian Johnson Marilyn I
don't know
gigliotti and Jeff Anderson Brian
Johnson or Brian o'holland
it says Brian Johnson on fair enough on
there I mean we hey maybe we I don't
know you want to bring it over yeah yeah
let's let's have Kevin Johnson but Brian
Allen is the guy that played Dante
oh my God no worries
yeah that's Brian O'Hara okay Brian
o'hall in Maryland oh my God no worries
and me and Jay and it's inscribed to
Mike so if your name is Mike or you know
it Mike this is perfect 500 and five and
a quarter five pocket about five and a
quarter five and a quarter five and a
quarter five hundred number five twenty
five five [__] about five twenty
pocket about five twenty pocket about
500 number five twenty five [__]
number five twenty pocket about five
[__] number five twenty pocket about
five twenty pocket about five [__]
number five twenty five five twenty
[__] about five fifty five twenty
five five twenty [__] about five I
get about five twenty [__] about five
I get about five twenty five bid 550
going once
excuse me high
259 going twice last call
sold 525 buyer number 100 buyer number
200 200 buys okay is there only seven
Lots left this this six more is that
right that is correct oh my Lord we're
almost at the end of this we've seen yes
we got some great time we got some great
stuff coming up here yes there's some
really nice pieces coming up so uh this
is lot 170 and again I know that this is
not Darren's auction this is partner's
option but I was wondering if we could
call just a slight audible here and
maybe have Kevin sign yeah that Kevin
Smith Pop I would love sure I like that
idea there's a a Mallrats uh script book
that's signed by me and Jay and there's
a Kevin Smith director of Funko Pop
which I'm about to tag right now there
you go there you go you saw it here 180
190 180 191 99 200. I heart you on it
there you go I Heart You 190 but 200.
we're not gonna buy two I can about you
talking about talking about 200 about
2005 200. We're not gonna buy 200 two
and a quarter two and a quarter two and
a quarter two and a half do it according
to get about two and a half get about
two weeks
about two twenty five two twenty five
bit two fifty two 25
bid 250 going once you got a story
behind that autograph folks yeah that's
a really One of a Kind only done in this
moment autograph on this pop 250 275 25
come on back now two seventy five two
picking about two seven
going once 250 but 275 dollars going
twice last call
250 to 234 234. Lot number 171 this is a
large autographed clerks movie poster
autographed by Kevin J Muse Bryant
O'Halloran Marilyn gigliotti and Jeff
Anderson
how can you go wrong guys 775 and 800
going twice last call
sold 775 buyer number uh 100 200 buyer
number two hundred
172. this is Starman number 33. this is
a colored cover by Tony Harris but uh
great so this is
from uh Starman DC Comic star man back
in the day uh issue 33 Tony Harris did
the cover and it features Batman and it
features uh the Starman main character
and all of these look at that painting
look at that oh my God it's gorgeous it
is gorgeous every single one of these
star man
covers has this iconic Tony Harris look
to it so like I you know just from
looking at it if you're like a nerdy DC
vertigo Comics guy you know just from
looking at it oh that has to be a star
man cover nothing else looks like that
yeah they did kind of an art deco look
and vibe to all their covers of the
storm yeah this is a wonderful book and
and Tony Harris is a fantastic artist
look at that yeah ex machina with uh
Brian Cave on this right this is just
just gorgeous really really tremendous
and it's framed kids Madden and frame
boy this is suitable for hanging up it
hung in uh the secret stash for years
and years and years now can hang in your
house seven thousand gonna buy 72.50
seventh hacking about 72 fitting in
about 72 57 000 72 58 about 72.50 I got
a seven thousand dollar bid bid 72.50 I
mean it's not gonna buy 72.50
2500 7 500 7 500 7 500 77.50 77 50 7750
77.50 77 58 77 50 70 50. I got 7 500 bid
seven thousand seven hundred and fifty
dollars guys sleeper of the sale let's
go seven seven to fifty seventy seven
fifty get about 77 50 70 50 75 750 going
once 7 500 bit 700
750 going twice last call
nice buy for seventy five hundred
dollars the buyer numbered 200 buyer
number two hundred lot 173 we have two
Daredevil Pages here Pages 10 and 11
from issue number five of the Marvel
Knights series penciled by Joe Casada
Inked by Jimmy palmiati signed by Kevin
Smith Jimmy pomiotti and Joe Casada
Kevin what more can you tell us about
this you know how many Daredevil pages
are out there from casada's run no very
few if any man
um so this is a rare find it features
not only Joe casadas and Jimmy
palmiati's rendition of Daredevil but
also Mephisto you know the devil in the
Marvel Universe and of course Doctor
Strange man so uh these characters were
in play back when I did this book God in
98 I think it was long before they did a
doctor strange movie or a daredevil Tv
show uh two stunning
pages with all the word balloons all
over look at all those words man and
it's so cool how the balloons have it's
they've changed color I guess from the
glue that was used on them yeah and it's
it's cooler yeah this is uh it's this is
these are rare finds kids get your hand
on Casada Daredevil artwork it's it's
it's it's it's tough going out there so
here's your chance and Casada ended up
being the editor-in-chief of Marvel yeah
he became a Marvel big wig yeah and
Jimmy pomiotti went on to be a writer of
uh Harley Quinn amongst other things uh
Joe what are we gonna do with this I got
52 50 5500 57 50 57 57 about six
thousand dollars six thousand six
seconds
sixty two fifty sixty two fifty sixty
two fifty sixty five hundred sixty five
hundred sixty five hundred fifty five
hundred about 67 50 67.50 about seven
thousand dollars seven talking about
seven talking about seven talking about
sixty seven Fifteen by seven thousand
dollars seven thousand about 67.50 by 67
I'm thinking about seven thousand
dollars going once don't miss out later
this is really nice seven thousand
seventy two fifty seventy five hundred
seventy five hundred seventy five
hundred seventy five I'm gonna divide 75
I'm gonna buy 72.7500 come on back I
think you could think you should 7500 72
but you get about 75 I get about 72.75
7500 going once 72 50 bit 7500 going
twice last call
sold seven thousand two hundred and
fifty dollars by our number 200 buyer
number 200 lot 174. two more pages
Daredevil we have Pages 21 and 22 so
these would be the last two pages
of Daredevil Issue Number Four again
pencils by Casada Inked by palmiati
written by Kevin Smith signed by all
three of them and page 22 is just a
giant Splat of Bullseye oh it's so great
look at that is the end of Issue four
kids the last two pages and the last
page of Issue four as you can see is
this giant Bullseye splash page it sure
is reading The Catcher in the ride in
the back there's some fun pull quotes
you know uh books have pull quotes on
the back and stuff oh cool I think me
and my friends are the ones listed on
the back of of the book full of poll
quotes and this is uh this is already
professionally framed and matted and if
you know the story you also have
Mysterio in that in these two pages as
well the guy in the big mustache who was
uh kind of uh an homage if you will to
will eisner's the spirits Chief oh cool
that's that is Quentin Beck the guy who
eventually reveals himself as Mysterio
in the book
stunning two pages by Casada 16 of these
anywhere in the world nah that last page
is beautiful 6500 about 67.50 65 I can
divide 67.5
by seven thousand dollars don't miss out
now seven thousand seventy two fifty
seventy two fifty seventy two fifty
seventy two fifty come on now seventy
two fifty what's another two hundred and
fifty dollars seventy two fifty seventy
five hundred eleventy five hundred
what's another bid seventy five hundred
another 250. come on now seventy five
hundred seventy five hundred seventy
five hundred seventy five hundred
seventy two people by seventy five
hundred about 72 52.75 seventy five
hundred thirty two minutes
seventy five hundred going once I think
you're all missing the book that last
page that last full slash image is so
phenomenal guys yep 77.50 77 50 gigabyte
seven seventy fifty seventy seven fifty
I got 7 500 now with seventy seven fifty
Seven seventy fifty seventy seven fifty
seven thousand seven seven hundred and
fifty dollars going once seventy five
hundred seven thousand seven hundred and
fifty dollars going twice don't miss out
one more bid last call
sold for seven thousand five hundred
dollars the buyer number 100 buyer
number one hundred lot 175 another
original comic art pair of pages here
from Daredevil issue number five we have
pages eight and nine once again penciled
by Casada Inked by Paul miati signed by
the writer Kevin Smith as well as Paul
miati and Casada we have a stunning pair
of pages that features Doctor Strange
Daredevil Mephisto it's uh Doctor
Strange summoning the devil for uh
doctor strange and Daredevil to ask
questions of Mephisto the sanctum
sanctorum Doctor Strange's home in the
village is uh depicted in the upper
left-hand corner
um this was uh one of the funnest uh
scenes to write in the entire Daredevil
run as a young Catholic kid summoning
the devil was a fun thing to do and look
at that rendition look at the you know
the rendition of Mephisto that Joe
Casada did he's huge yeah gigantic
compared to how small the characters are
uh gorgeous pair of pages uh whoever
wins them could be very lucky to own
some Casada art 62 50 bit 6500 about
65.65 about 6500 62.65
6500 going once 62 fitting about 6 500
going twice now 67.50 65 and thank you
divide
67.567.50 going once 6500 67.50 going
twice last call yes seven thousand
dollars seven thousand dollars I've been
talking about seven thousand seven
talking about seven seconds
about seven thousand dollars going once
sixty seven fifty bit seven thousand
dollars seventy two fifty seventy two
fifty which is one of the last Primo
pieces you can buy in this sale guys
here it is 72.50 72 but you get about
seven Target about 72.50
seventy five hundred seventy five
hundred seventy five hundred seventy two
minutes
seventy seven fifty seventy seven fifty
seven seven fifty seventy seven fifty
seven seven fifty seventy five hundred
about seventy seven fifty come on one
more time seven seven fifty Seven
going once 7 577.50 going twice yep
eight thousand dollars eight thousand
dollars eight thousand by eighty two
fifty eighty two fifty eighty two fifty
eighty five hundred eighty five hundred
eighty five hundred I think you could
think you should eighty five hundred one
more time 8 500. what's another two
hundred and fifty dollars on these Primo
two pages professionally mounted ready
to go from Kevin Smith's uh uh
collection eighty five hundred eighty
seven fifty eighty seven fifty do it
again 87.50 one more time 87.50 87.50
don't let them have it now 87.50 come on
back 87 picking up I can see it on your
wall I can see it in your collection
ladies and gentlemen you can say you
bought it right here from bonders a part
of Kevin Smith's sale 87.50 85.87 50 750
going once 85 I could buy eighty seven
eight seven fifty nine thousand dollars
nine thousand dollars don't let him have
it come on hit it again nine thousand
dollars what's another bid thank you
92.50 do it again 92.50 don't let him
have it 92.50
going once you're gonna wake up tomorrow
and you're gonna say damn it I should
have been One More Time come on now 9
seconds of a 92.50
going once nine thousand ninety two
fifty going twice last call
sold nine thousand dollars fire numbers
one hundred buyer number one hundred
I know it's the last I'll make my
announcements and then we'll sell it and
then we'll uh sell the last live first
of all I'd like to thank all of you for
joining us all day today we really
appreciate it you will be getting an
invoice uh in uh your inbox in the next
20 minutes to a half hour please pay
first pay first to ship keep that in
mind anybody that has a bill over ten
thousand which is probably gonna be
everybody
there is a bank wire transfer required
with that payment all right so keep that
in mind we'll email you the details of
our bank uh information uh and we will
take your money bank wire transfer once
again we do appreciate everything uh if
you are picking up from us you can pay
with cash uh and that will be happening
uh on Thursday Friday Saturday and
Monday more than likely no pickups will
happen tomorrow being how late it is
because normally you need 24 hours to
make that pickup request uh but
definitely Friday Saturday and Monday we
will have pickups here at our location
we appreciate it Kevin I really
appreciate everything you'd uh for
giving to giving me the opportunity to
sell the collection I hope I hope hope I
did a fantastic job phenomenal job Joe
well thank you for watching you I
appreciate people who are excellent at
what they do and you are excellent at
what you do well thank you very much
absolute pleasure spending this many
hours listening
to you speak like I could do that over
and over again I would I would put that
on and go to sleep to that it's so sweet
so comfortable
eat them Chimes yeah
the Joe Bodner just just bid me to sleep
I think I should start a YouTube channel
there you go at any rate
last item of the day here we go this is
it kids the very last piece man tell
them what we what they're what they're
looking at we have a lot 176 here from
Kevin Smith's Green Arrow this is issue
number five pages eight and nine and you
get images of Green Arrow and Batman
this Green Arrow and Batman in the
Batcave after Batman is examined Green
Arrow to see if he's the real Green
Arrow uh spoiler the spoiler is uh in
there uh Stephanie who would later go on
to become Robin and stuff uh but it's a
double page spread uh matted and framed
uh suitable for hanging as you can see
it used to do that hung in my house for
15 good 15 years man
thousand dollars but Eleven Hundred
about twelve hundred Eleven Hundred by
twelve hundred about twelve hundred by
twelve hundred by twelve hundred by
twelve when I get about 12 seconds
don't miss out ladies and gentlemen last
item of the sale is all that Batman For
Heaven's Sake yeah really come on guys
1100 by 1200. 1200.
1200 going once 11. hook it up by twelve
hundred dollars going twice it's gonna
be the the the steal of the day yep 1200
now thirteen hundred well [__] about
thirteen hundred thirteen hundred
thirteen hundred fourteen hundred
fourteen hundred fourteen hundred stable
steel what do you think about fourteen a
legal steal as well 1400 number 14 13 14
1500 hours going once and again folks
just to be clear Kevin wrote this yes
it's not just the Batman page that Kevin
bought it is the Batman page that Kevin
has helped produce that's right it
wouldn't exist if I hadn't open My Big
Fat Mouth so here we are
creating problems and trying to sell
them off to y'all this is a great page
man if you like Green Arrow you like
Batman look at all that Batman look at
all that bat cave
um hang this up in your house hang it up
in the [__] right across from the
toilet give you something to Aspire to
look at the bodies on these guys
I'm teasing you nothing about 14 I get
about 1500 1500 about 1500 about 1500
about 14 how can about 1500 1500 1500
1600 1600 1600 1500 divide 1600 1500 by
1600 1500 1600 1500 by 1600 1500 1600
going once fifteen hundred about sixteen
hundred dollars going twice last call
sold fifteen hundred dollars thank you
all for joining us all day long buyer
number 200. we did it absolutely we did
it 176 Lots all right congratulations
everybody pay your bill
uh that was buyer number 200 buyer
number 200. all right let me end this
day and the auction yes you gotta turn
the live feed off